...
Scholastic audio presents...
Wings of Fire.
Book 13, The Poison Jungle, by 2ET
Sutherland, read by Shannon McManus.
The Lost Continent Prophecy.
Turn your eyes, your wings, your fire, to
the land across the sea, where dragons
are poisoned, and dragons are dying, and
no one can ever be free.
A secret lurks inside their eggs.
A secret hides within their book.
A secret buried far below may save those
brave enough to look.
Open your hearts, your minds, your wings
to the dragons who flee from the hive.
Face a great evil with talons united, or
none of the tribes will survive.
Prologue.
The hive wing city loomed out of the
savannah, impossibly tall and imposing
and indestructible looking.
And honestly, it's big smug aura would
have been enough reason to burn it down
in Bryany's opinion, but it was also
bonus full of their enemies.
Not to mention that it was made from
trees that had been stolen from her own
tribe, the leaf wings, long before she
hatched.
She had never known those trees herself
but she should have.
They should have lived 100s of years
whispering to their seedlings and slowly
reaching toward the light instead.
They had been murdered, ground up into
splinters, and mixed into the mash hive
wings called tree stuff.
Every hive was made of it.
Which is why every hive is going to
burn.
Eventually, this one was a bit of a trial
run.
Bloodworm hive.
Even the name gave her the creeps.
She was glad her leaders had chosen one
so palpably horrible.
She might have felt a tad less
enthusiastic about burning the prettier
jewel hive they'd flown past a few days
ago.
Then again, maybe not.
All she had to do was picture the dragons
inside, and even the sparkly glitter
bazaar became instantly more sinister.
But it didn't matter.
They were here, behind a greenhouse
outside bloodworm hive in the middle of
the night, moments away from executing
their great mission.
I think it's kind of funny that all the
hives have greenhouses.
She said to hemlock and pokeweed.
It's like the hive wings wiped out all
the trees, thinking they were so clever.
And then after they were done, they
realized, oops, plants are kind of useful
actually.
Maybe we should make some little houses
and grow a few.
She brushed one of her leaf shaped wings
across the panes of glass.
Easy enough, once they also stole the
silk wings fire, I guess, she added.
Hemlock and pokeweed, as usual, were
being stoic and boring and ignored her by
staring grimly off into space, as if they
were too busy envisioning heroic things
to trouble with conversations.
She rolled her eyes, crouched beside them
and peeked into the jar Belladonna had
left them.
Bryany had seen fire before.
Once when lightning hit a tree and burned
it to charred ash.
But she'd never seen it like this.
A long thread curled quietly inside stone
glowing, like a bit of captured sun.
It was so small.
Especially compared to the giant hive in
front of them.
How can this possibly work?
She whispered.
How can this tiny bit of fire bring down
a whole city?
We follow the plan.
Hemlock said.
He gestured the bags of detony and other
flammable plants they'd brought with them
from the jungle.
This would be easier.
If we had sun do with us.
Pokweed pointed out, in his deep, slow
voice, I don't understand why she isn't
here.
She's busy.
Hemlock said curtly.
Doing what?
Bryony asked.
Although she knew perfectly well, he
would continue to not tell her anything
about his daughter's mystery activities.
I thought she was going to help.
Pokweed said again.
I thought the plan involved flaming ivy
growing up the walls.
It will, Hemlock said, lifting his claws
and flexing them significantly.
Pokweed gave him a dubious look.
Maybe we should wait for her, he said.
Maybe she'll come soon.
Pokweed.
Hemlock said, finally letting a bit of
exasperation slip into his voice.
Don't be annoying.
Hmm.
Pokweed grumbled.
That's nice.
The plan is fine.
Hemlock picked up the jar and cupped it
between his talons.
The glow lit up his face from below
casting his eyes into shadows.
We have what we need.
Not being annoying.
Pokweed muttered.
Being sensible.
Another dragon appeared around the corner
of the greenhouse, and for a moment
Bryony tensed, ready to fight.
But it wasn't a hive wing.
This dragon had golden rod yellow spots
on his wings, but the rest of his scales
were shades of gray, pale and dark
overlapping, like a chintilla, or a
snuggled up pile of chintillas.
She'd only known this silk wing for a
day.
But every time she saw him, she thought
of small, adorable furry things.
Grayling, she whispered.
Hi, Briony, he whispered back, smiling.
Is it done?
Hemlock interrupted.
We did the best we could, Grayling said.
All the soak wings who sleep in the hive
have been worn to stay near an exit, and
keep their dragonettes with them so they
can evacuate first.
We have members of the chrysalis assigned
to retrieve our eggs, and the dragonettes
going through metamorphosis right now, and
we've sent messages along the webs that
connect this hive to Jewel Hive and
Mantis Hive.
He hesitated.
If we had one more day, we don't, Hemlock
said, not unkindly, but with absolute
finality in his voice.
Grayling's gaze went to the long bridge
of silk overhead that stretched toward
mantas hives.
It glimmered a little, as if some of the
starlight was caught in the silvery
filaments.
Do you really think the whole city will
burn?
he asked.
And the webs along with it?
We are not going to set the webs alight
on purpose.
Bryany answered.
But if the hive burns down like we're
hoping.
She didn't have to finish the sentence.
It was pretty clear what would happen to
the webs that were woven to the top
levels of the hive.
When sundew had 1st told them about the
underground movement of silk wings called
the chrysalis.
Briony had thought someone must have
cracked her very hard on the head.
She had grown up side by side with Sundoo
who was only a year younger than her.
They had both been raised with the
absolutely certain knowledge that silk
wings were weak and timid and never stood
up to anyone.
And then when Sundew said they needed to
warn the chrysalis before burning
bloodworm hive.
Well, that was truly epic nonsense.
Wouldn't someone go straight to tell the
hive wings?
Wouldn't that ruin the whole plan?
But then they found grayling, and a few
other dragons from the bloodworm hive
chrysalis.
And now Briny couldn't even think about
what would have happened if they'd burned
it without getting the silk wings out
first.
She'd never have known Greyling at all.
He might have died.
And she wouldn't have known she'd lost
him.
All right.
Grayling said, shaking himself.
Then how can the chrysalis help?
You would do that?
Bryony asked, surprised.
A spark kindled in hemlock's eyes.
You could burn it from the inside too.
He said.
That would be very helpful.
Greyling looked up at the hive.
No, not the hive, Bryany realized.
He was looking at the webs where he and
his family lived, the home they had spun
for themselves, the only home they knew.
This mission, if it succeeded, would
leave them lost in the Savannah, with no
idea where they'd end up.
You don't have to do anything, she said
earning herself a frown from hemlock.
It will be massively dangerous.
He met her eyes and tipped his head to
the side.
I've wanted to fight back against the
hive wings almost since the day I hatched
he said softly.
They let my father die, and they sent my
brother away to the Setsi hive.
Lady Bloodworm, is one of the cruelest of
wasps' sisters.
That's why the chrysalis here has so many
members.
I'm ready to do something real.
I think we all are.
Excellent.
Hemlock said.
Let's choose locations and plan our
timing.
We all have to act fast and as
synchronized as possible.
Bryony said to Greyling, Queen Wasp will
be inside all these dragons the moment
she realizes what's happening.
By then, it has to be too late for her to
stop it.
I'll show you the plans we have for
burning.
Pokweed said lugubriously.
I can do that.
Briony jumped in.
You and Hemlock reviewed the interior map
of the hive we got from the chrysalis.
She brushed Grayling's wing with her own
and beckoned him over to the supplies.
As she described each plant, how quickly
it would burn, which ones would spray
burning oil, she caught Grayling watching
her with a strange expression in his
eyes.
What, she said, putting down a bundle of
dead palm fronds they had gathered that
morning along the shore of Dragonfly
Bay.
It's just, he hesitated.
I'm just amazed at how much trouble your
tribe has gone to.
All these plans and all this work, just
to save us.
Briny tried not to show how startled she
was.
To save you?
She echoed.
The silk wings, he said.
You could have left us to rot in Queen
Wasp's talent, after we abandoned you
during the tree wars, but you didn't.
You came back to set us free.
Oh, the guilt.
Bryney felt it stabbing all her internal
organs at once.
How could she tell him that she'd never
once thought about the plight of the silk
wings before she met him?
That their mission was vengeance, not
rescue.
It's not, not, she stammered.
I mean, we, we are doing it for
ourselves.
Honestly, please don't think of us like
heroes or saviors or anything.
He flicked his tail. nearly toppling a
neat pile of dry grass.
Maybe as friends then?
he asked.
That works for me, she said.
I'm sorry we're burning down your home.
It's more like a cage anyway.
He said.
Where are you going to go after it
burns?
We found some underground caves to hide
in for a few days, she said.
Belladonna said we had to lie low, so we
wouldn't lead wasp back to everyone
else.
Oh, he said.
Running his claws over one of the palm
fronds.
Any chance there's room in there for a
small, friendly silk wing?
She smiled at him, and he made a, sorry
about this face, or a couple 100 of
them.
I'll talk to Hemlock about it.
She promised.
She could see the older leaf wing
beckoning them.
His talons holding down the scribbled map
of the interior of the hive.
Thank you, Grayling said.
She twined her tail around his.
Let's go set a fire.
Part one.
Roots and sprouts.
Chapter one.
Sundoo sometimes like to imagine that she
could fly all the way around the world
without stopping, using nothing but her
fury to keep her going.
When she got tired, she'd think about all
the things that made her angry.
Hive wings, hive wings, hive wings, Queen
Wasp, the murder of the trees, the
attempted murder of my entire tribe.
Hive Wings, Mother and Father, No, those
weren't allowed on this list.
Hive wings.
Sundu imagined stabbing her claws into
their necks, ripping their smug
expressions off their faces, choking them
with strangler vines, releasing fire ants
into their eyeballs.
A flash of yellow and black caught her
eye, and she whipped her head toward it
with a hiss.
Sorry.
Cricket dropped to a different air
current and called up.
I didn't mean to startle you.
You didn't.
Sundew snapped.
It was sort of difficult to rage fly on
the power of hating hive wings when there
were 2 hive wings flying right alongside
her, being extremely noisy and
distracting.
Also, when one of those high wings was
sort of practically almost a friend-ish
kind of dragon, maybe, and the other was
the size of a large mango, and madly in
love with sundew.
Snoodoo, cried the little dragonette, tied
snugly to Cricket's chest.
Bumblebee reached her tiny talons towards
sundew.
Marbles snoodoo.
Is that tiny lizard trying to say my
name?
Sendu asked, alarmed.
How did that happen?
She is very smart.
Cricket said proudly.
Not if she thinks she wants my attention
Sundew pointed out.
She turned her head north again, beating
her wings harder.
There was a dark line on the horizon
ahead.
They were almost there.
The poison jungle.
Home.
Or never home, as some of the leaf wings
called it, but the only home sundew had
ever known.
Her tribe's true home, the rest of the
continent, covered in vast ancient
forests, only existed in stories of the
old days and dreams for the future.
Sundew breathed and flew.
Each wing beat brought her closer.
Closer to the thorn sharp, fangs bared
twisted safety of the poison jungle.
Closer to the dragon she wasn't allowed
to think about.
She felt the pout she kept over her heart
thump once, twice, again in rhythm with
her wings.
It was the only pouch, out of the many
wrapped around her, that didn't hold
venomous insects or useful plants.
Inside, it was nothing but a small jade
frog.
Which didn't help with the not thinking
about, it served, in fact, the opposite
purpose.
But sundew still brought it with her
everywhere.
As long as her parents, Belladonna and
Hemlock, didn't know what it meant.
They couldn't do anything about it.
Um, sundo?
Blue asked nervously from her left.
She tilted her head toward him.
It was weird to know a silk wing.
After years of scoffing about how
beautiful and useless they were, even
weirder.
He'd turned out to not be useless at
all.
Flame silk.
I should have been a flame silk.
If I had the power of fire.
Well, I sort of do, now that we have
blue.
That thought made her uncomfortable, and
she wasn't sure why.
She bared her teeth at a passing starling
and it nearly fell out of the sky in
fright.
Blue's wings glimmered azure in the rays
of the setting sun.
Um, isn't the poison jungle really
dangerous?
Or is that a lie?
Soretel asked from our other side.
Like, maybe leaf wings spread stories
exaggerating how dangerous it is, so that
no one else would go there.
That would make sense.
I bet that's it.
Sundu laughed.
How could we spread stories?
she said.
We haven't communicated with any silk
wings or hive wings since the end of the
tree wars 50 years ago?
We were supposed to be extinct.
That was kind of your whole goal
remember?
Not our goal.
Blue protested in distress.
No, everything you've heard about the
jungle is true, Sundew said to Sordail.
Queen Wasp sent a few expeditions to the
poison jungle looking for resources, and
trying to make sure no dragons were
hiding from her there.
Almost all of them died.
The rest are the ones who brought the
stories back to you.
She frowned.
One of the expeditions was sent to burn
down the jungle, because Wasp wanted no
more trees anywhere.
None of those dragons survived.
She flicked her tail.
We helped the jungle make sure of that.
No one who comes for the trees again will
be allowed to live.
But then, how have you survived?
Blue asked, how can there be a whole
tribe living in a place that's so
dangerous for dragons?
We didn't have a choice, Sundu answered.
It's easier when you grow up knowing what
to avoid, and how to treat snake bites
and where the quicksand is.
Nowadays, we only lose a few dragons a
year to the carnivorous plants.
The what now?
Sortell said, his voice rising in
octave.
Carnivorous what?
Yeah, you will probably get eaten, Sundu
said with a shrug.
They always get the loud, flappy ones, and
that hive wing dragonette is Cobra Lily
food for sure.
Zami!
Bumblebee shouted from behind them.
I am not enjoying this conversation
Storytell observed.
Do we have to go to the place with the
certain death?
Blue asked.
Yes, because it's my home, Sundoo said.
And also the only place you'll be safe
from Queen Wasp after burning down her
greenhouse of mind control plants.
And also, because there's a dragon there
who I'm definitely not thinking about, and
certainly do not think about all the
time.
We'd be safe across the ocean, wouldn't
we?
Cricket offered, flying back into sundews
line of sight, in the distant kingdoms.
Sundew laughed.
If you would all like to fly out to sea
in search of an imaginary continent, go
for it, she thought, but did not add
except for you, Blue.
You belong to the leaf wings now.
The group fell silent as they drew closer
to the edge of the poison jungle.
The snarling river, dark and swift
flowing, marked the boundary, but the
jungle was always prowling across the
line, pitcher plants and cobra lilies
grew thick along the shores on both sides
and every time sundew flew this way, she
saw more plants extending their tendrils
across the water.
More twisted little thorn trees starting
to muscle their way up on the wrong
side.
If we set it free, The poison jungle
could devour the continent for us, and
all the hive wings too.
If I set it free.
I could unleash the jungle and send it
forth to strangle our enemies.
I won't though.
I don't want to pentala covered in
poisonous dragon eating plants.
I want the pentala of the old stories.
The giant forests that stretched from
shore to shore.
She closed her talons into fists.
But if I can't have that, beating all the
hive wings to overgrown bladder wards is
a solid plan B. Sundew was over the river
when she realized the others had stopped
hovering in midair to stare at the
trees.
She swung around and flew back to them.
They're so big.
Cricket said, in an awe struck voice.
Her gold orange wings hummed like a cloud
of dragonflies.
The late afternoon sunlight caught in her
glasses, reflecting the rippling water
below.
I didn't know trees grew so enormous.
Some of them look as tall as the hives.
How old are they?
Can you tell?
Would they all get that big if they lived
that long?
Are they all dangerous?
Oh, please tell me you have books about
all these plants.
I want to know how you can fly in there
when everything's so close together
Swartell declared, squinting at the
tangle of vines, fallen trees, giant
spider webs, and thickets of plants that
wove impassable barriers between the
trees.
It feels like one vast creature with a
1000000 eyes.
Blue added softly.
I can almost hear it breathing.
Like it's waiting for us.
The others stared at him, and even Sundew
who was used to the creepy aura of the
poison jungle, felt a trickle of ice run
through her veins.
Arglar, flirt.
Bumblebee announced, jabbing Cricket's
chin with one of her claws and breaking
the spell.
E, pal, Snoodoo?
She reached hopefully towards sundew.
I think E-Pal means eat now, Cricket
explained with a sigh.
She's been yelling it for the last half a
continent.
E pow!
Bumblebee demonstrated with expansive arm
gestures, trying to wiggle out of her
sling, eat, pal.
You can wait until we get to the village
Sundu said sternly.
Don't make that face at me.
No whining, or you can wait until
tomorrow morning.
Bumblebee flopped slowly over backward, so
her head and wings drooped toward the
river below.
Never, she said, mournfully and
distinctly.
Aw, Cricket said, tucking the dragonette
back into place and patting her head.
She's such a quick learner.
Bumblebee snuggled into her chest and
gave a loud, dramatic sigh.
Sundew turned to sword tail.
We keep the outer layers of the jungle as
wild and impenetrable as possible, she
said, for obvious reasons, of, oh, she
means you.
He said to Cricket.
The obvious reasons are your murdery
tribe and your evil queen.
Swordtail.
Come on, Blue said, drawing closer to
cricket.
Your tribe isn't exactly welcome here
either, Silkwing.
Sundew pointed out.
She had a feeling she was going to get a
pretty strong reaction when they got to
the Leaf Wing village.
But it was Belladonna's fault for leaving
and setting a hive on fire, instead of
waiting for sundew to meet her as she'd
promised.
If she didn't want sundew bringing
strangers into the jungle, she should
have stayed in one place till they came.
Sundew looked up at the press of jostling
tree trunks that rose before them.
Flying gets easier farther in, she
explained, but for now, we climb.
Follow me, stay close, and don't touch
anything I haven't touched first.
She arched her wings and caught an air
current that smelled faintly of salt and
distant whales.
It lifted her up and up toward the
swaying tops of the trees.
Up here, the branches were like 1000s of
long spider monkey arms.
They reached and caught one another
bending back and looping around, fuzzy
with pale green moss, or marked with the
scratches of dragon, jaguar, and tamarind
claws.
The spot where the Machahillas grew was
well camouflaged.
Other plants with similar leaves had been
planted all around it, up and down in
along the wall of foliage.
The sundew never had any trouble finding
it.
She could have flown to it with her eyes
closed.
She could sense the vibrations of the
Makahia leaves, like quiet music in her
head.
They were higher, and trembled more than
the vibrations of other plants.
Sunday slowed down and brushed her tail
lightly across the center of the Makahia
cluster.
At once, the long, oval, fern like leaves
began folding together.
Pair after pair along the stems, like
butterfly wings closing up.
As they closed, they revealed a gap in
the branches behind them, just large
enough for a dragon to fit through.
Whoa, Blue whispered.
I've never seen a plan do that before.
Oh, I think they're called touch me nots
aren't they?
Cricket asked Sundoo.
That's one name for them, Sundu
answered.
Ooh. said Swordtail.
That sounds super dangerous.
Touch me not, or you will die.
Sundew snickered, and Cricket covered her
snout to hide her smile.
Actually, Sundew said to SwordTail.
This is probably the only plant up here
that won't kill you.
Hmm, he said skeptically, squinting at
the folded leaves as he followed sundew
through the hole.
Stepping into the jungle always felt like
plunging underwater.
If that water was actually thick green
soup in a cauldron, boiling, and full of
insects, Sundu hissed at a mosquito the
size of her ear, and it veered away in
search of more docile prey.
Behind her, Cricket let out a yelp, and
lifted one talon to reveal a crushed mess
of yellowy orange ooze that had probably
been a tree slug.
Mmm, yum?
Bumblebee inquired, reaching for it.
E?
No, cricket said.
Gross, bumblebee.
Gross!
Bumblebee cried, waking up in anaconda as
thick as sundoo's tail in the next tree
over.
The snake raised its head slowly and
narrowed its eyes at the little
dragonette.
Shh.
Let's move.
Sundu whispered.
She ran lightly along the branch and
leaped to another, then scrambled up to
one that crisscrossed above them.
The trees shook as the other dragons
tried clumsily to follow her.
Sundew could sense the message spreading
through the trees.
Something new.
Leaves whispered to leaves, roots and
networks of underground filaments
flickered the news along like twigs in a
current.
Watch, listen, be safe.
Caution, stand guard.
She didn't have time to dig her talons
into the dirt and shape the story.
She had to hope she could get her dragons
to the village quickly.
And then she could take a moment to talk
to the trees.
You're like a monkey.
Sortell panted, catching up to her when
she stopped to wait for them.
I mean, in a good way.
Like, uh, very fast, jumps, good jumps
not foodishly.
I mean, not in a dinner way.
Just so fast.
He wheezed to a stop.
Cricket balanced along the branch to a
spot behind him, digging in her claws in
a way that made sundew wince.
The trees wouldn't like that.
But Bumblebee kept lunging sideways
nearly out of her sling, reaching for
bright flowers or shining beetles, so
Sundew could see why Cricket needed to
hold on tight.
Bringing up the rear behind her was Blue
who looked as if he was trying to swallow
the jungle with his eyes.
It's scary.
Like being high up in the webs, he said
thoughtfully, but loud, like the inside
of the hives, except the buzzing isn't in
a language you can understand.
And the smell is way worse.
Swartell observed.
Sundew bristled.
No, it isn't.
The smell of 100s of dragons trapped in
one structure is much worse.
This is what plants and fresh air and
freedom smell like.
Isn't it also what rotting plants smell
like?
he asked.
And dead animals, and I don't know what
else.
Swamp gas?
You smell like swamp gas, she said
furiously.
I'm sorry, Blue interjected.
I only meant it's interesting.
I'm trying to map it onto something I
felt before.
But it's so different from anywhere I've
been.
Yeah, sorry, so I tell agreed, giving
Sandu an abashed look.
It's not that bad.
Some of it is kind of cool.
Like that flower right below us.
Look, Blue.
It's like an enormous wild, pink, open
book.
I mean, so pink.
And it actually smells kind of.
Do not, Sundu shouted, as he leaned
toward it sniffing.
But it was too late.
Sortail's nose brushed the pink surface
and the plant's jaws snapped shut around
him, yanking him off the branch and
swallowing him whole.
In an instant, Swordtail was gone.
Chapter 2.
Touch the Venus dragon trap.
Sundew finished with a sigh.
Cricket shrieked, and 8 more dragon traps
snapped shut all around them, excited by
the noise.
The hive wing jumped back and crashed
into blue, nearly knocking them both off
the branch.
Sore tail!
Blue shouted.
Swordtail.
I was about to point those out, Sundew
said.
One of the most dangerous plants in
here.
Never touch those.
Never, never.
She gave Bumblebee a very stern look.
Never, small dragon.
Do you hear me?
Snabble.
Poof.
Bumblebee said in an awe struck tone
staring at the spot where Sortail had
been, Blue scrambled around Cricket.
Soretail, can you hear me?
He reached toward the overstuffed plant
below them, where SoraTail's long blue
and orange tail dangled, flailing from
between the trap's jaws.
Sundew smacked Blue's knuckles.
What did I just say?
She barked.
Never touch them.
How do we get him out?
Cricket asked frantically.
Muffled yells were coming from inside the
plant.
The sides bulged as swordtail thrashed
and struggled.
But Sundu knew that there was no way for
a dragon to escape on his own once he was
inside.
Swordtail!
she shouted.
Stop moving.
Of course, he was yelling too loud to
hear her.
Basic carnivorous plant safety lesson
number one.
Sundew said to the others, but mostly to
bumblebee's wide-eyed face.
If you fall into a dragon trap, go as
still as you can.
If the plant thinks you're just a rock or
tree branch that fell in by accident
it'll open back up and drop you.
But if you flail around like an idiot, She
shouted at SwordTail, then it will.
Know you're a delicious snack for sure.
And then what?
Cricket asked, wide-eyed.
Then it releases its digestive juices and
eats you, Sundew said.
Obviously.
She swatted it blue as he tried reaching
for Sordell again.
Swordtail!
Cricket and Blue yelled in unison.
It's pretty definitely figured out he's
alive by now.
Sundu said.
She pointed to the long hairs along the
edges of the plant's mouth, which were
starting to lock firmly together.
It won't drop him even if he does shut up
long enough to hear us.
But it's a slow process.
It'll take at least half a day before it
kills them.
Can't we slice it open and cut him out?
Cricket asked, raising one of her talons
to flex her claws.
Sundu shook her head.
They've adapted for that.
It takes forever to saw through the shell
of a dragon trap.
Plus, they grow in clusters like this on
purpose.
So if you try, another one will get you.
She pointed to the gaping pink jaws
hanging from the trees all around them
particularly the one leaning over sword
tail's plant, ready to swallow any dragon
who tried to help him.
Blue paced up and down the branch.
Soretail, he called again.
We'll get you out, I promise.
So, what do you normally do?
Cricket asked Sundo.
Your tribe must have found a way to
rescue dragons from being eaten.
Sort of, if having me counts as finding a
way.
Sundu had been studying the nearest plant
as they talked.
There was a promising kudzu vine choking
one of the trees below them, or a thorny
greenbrier vine system tangled through
the branches just behind the dragon trap
cluster.
The sharp, dark stems prickled in the
corners of her mind, coiled and
dangerous.
If she could get to one of them.
But then she'd have to reveal her secret
abilities to blue and cricket.
They're going to find out pretty soon
anyway.
And it's the only way to save sword
tail.
I can, she started.
There was a flash of bright orange light
and heat beside her, a long thread of
flame silk flew out of Blue's wrist and
slithered around the dragon traps, leaves
and stem.
Stop, Sundew yelled.
She lunged across cricket and grabbed
Blue's arm, slamming it down to the
branch.
Why are you all impossible?
She whirled, and saw the fire already
beginning to catch, and spread down the
length of the dragon trap stem toward the
tree where its roots were.
As the stem burned through, the squirming
bulb of the dragon trap drooped and
lulled sideways, setting off 3 more
plants as it knocked into them.
Sundune leaped up to a higher branch and
seized a cluster of giant bromeliads.
A small blue tree frog jumped out of one
of them, and gave her a reproachful look
as she ripped the flowers free.
Inside each cluster of leaves was a pool
of water.
Some the size of her cupped talons, some
much bigger.
She swooped down and poured them over the
fire.
It sizzled and hissed at her.
Half the flames went out, but one end
began sprinting faster toward the tree.
The smoke was already thick and curling
into our eyes, making them water.
All the nearest dragon traps had drawn
back as far as their stems would allow.
Leaves all around her curled away from
the fire.
She could feel the trees screaming deep
in her nerves.
I need a fire resistant plant.
Something full of water or sap, or giant
leaves I can use to smother the flames.
Sundew glanced desperately around, and
spotted a choke cherry tree on the jungle
floor, far below her.
She leaped through the smoke to the trunk
of the burning tree, and pressed her
talons against the bark, sending her
power down through the wood, through the
roots, through the mycelium threads under
the soil, into the choke cherry tree.
The choke cherry tree burst upward
growing at the speed of an erupting
volcano.
Its branches smacked other plants aside
its roots burrowed deep and fast to keep
it steady.
In a matter of heartbeats.
The top of the tree was level with
Sunday's head, and the berries on it were
enormous, the size of her fists.
She grabbed talonfuls of berries and
smashed them onto the branch below the
fire, smearing the juice around and
around.
The flames reached the wet barrier and
slowed, prodding the goop in a
disgruntled manner.
More water splashed down on the fire from
above.
Sundu looked up, and saw cricket, with
her claws full of bromeliads.
Bumblebee was buried deep in her sling
her snout covered by the striped fabric.
Cricket poured out the stored rainwater
in the flowers, methodically covering all
the flames until at last, they were
extinguished.
Sundew rested her forehead against the
tree, checking it for damage.
Apart from one burnt limb and the smoke
clogging its leaves, the rest of it was
shaken, but unharmed.
The dragon trap, however, was definitely
dead.
She turned toward it and realized that
Blue was holding up the head and trying
to pry open the jaws at the same time
mostly unsuccessfully.
Cricket hovered beside him, supporting
the weight of the plant and sword tail.
The other dragon traps, which had been
scared back by the fire, were slowly
inching toward them again.
Sundew flew over to blue.
She could hear Swordtail coughing inside
the plant.
That was incredibly stupid.
She snapped her tail back and forth.
Her insides felt as though they were
boiling with anger, as though the flame
silk had gone straight into her veins as
well.
You could have set this whole jungle on
fire.
I'm sorry, Blue said.
And at least he looked like he meant it
unless the tears in his eyes came from
the smoke in the air.
I panicked.
I only wanted to save Swordtail.
I had no idea it would spread like that.
You should have thought about it.
You just saw a wasp's greenhouse go up in
flames.
A fellow leaf wing would have roared back
at sundew, a dragon from her tribe would
have bristled, defended himself, argued
stormed around, pointed out all the ways
she was wrong.
Most conversations in her village ended
in fights or started with a fight, or at
least involved some shouting.
But Blue nodded, and wiped his eyes, and
apologized again.
You're right.
I'm really, really sorry, Sundo.
Which made it kind of impossible to keep
yelling at him.
The ball of sundew's anger bounced back
inside her. and started mutating into
something useless and distracting, like
guilt or pity or something.
She scowled down at the dragon trap, which
was starting to crack open where Blue was
pulling on it.
I bet your flame silk is hard to control
isn't it?
Cricket asked breathlessly, trying to
hold up the still smoking plant.
Yeah, Blue said.
So, it was extra stupid of me.
We'll help you practice with it, Sundew
said, wondering if she could really offer
something like that.
There wasn't a leaf wing alive who knew
anything about managing plame silk.
But for now, promise me you won't use it
in the jungle unless I tell you to.
I promise, he said.
I really promise.
Can you help me get sore tail out?
He must be so scared.
No, not scared.
Sortell half yelled, half sputtered
through the crack in the plant's jaws.
This plant is in big trouble.
I'm going to slice it up from the
inside.
I'm going to give it such a stomach
ache.
It'll seriously regret trying to eat me.
You deserved it.
Sundu barked at him.
It was a relief to have someone she could
be mad at without feeling bad.
She hooked her claws around the top edge
of the plant's mouth, and motioned for
Blue to take the bottom edge.
You basically fed yourself to it.
I did not.
That is, it, I was just smelling it.
Sortail growled.
Sundew flapped her wings, pushing herself
backward as hard as she could.
The smell is designed to attract dragons
she conceded.
But only dragons with no brains in their
heads, who like constantly causing
trouble for their traveling companions.
I said you would get eaten right away, and
I was right.
With a ripping, crackling sound.
The jaws finally parted.
Swordtail hauled himself out and back
onto the 1st branch, coughing and
blinking rapidly.
The others let go of the dragon trap, and
the head broke off from the blackened
stem, tumbling away to the forest floor.
Sundew could sense the hunger of the
surrounding dragon traps.
As the smoke faded into the air, they
were getting bolder, wrestling closer in
their stealthy way.
She shoved cricket and bumblebee back
onto the branch, and Blue clambered after
them.
I've never seen such a pile of idiocy, she
said.
Now really stay close to me and really
don't touch anything.
I feel like we could have gotten a bit
more of a warning.
Swortail objected with a cough as they
started walking again.
Like, it'd be pretty helpful if you'd
point out, that's a carnivorous plant, and
that one is super flammable, and that one
can kill you.
All right, Sunday said, waving at the
entire jungle around them.
These are dangerous plants, and most of
them are carnivorous, and all of them can
kill you.
Do not sniff, touch, eat, poke, lick, or
set fire to any of them, or you will
probably die.
And next time, I will let you.
She doesn't mean that.
Cricket whispered to bumblebee, who
chirped sleepily back at her.
It must have been pretty awful when your
tribe 1st got here, Blue said.
Sundew did not dignify that with an
answer, since she was pretty sure it
would involve more yelling at him, and
apparently she didn't really enjoy
yelling at Blue.
Yelling at sore tail on the other hand
was always satisfying.
They climbed in silence for a little
while, hopping from branch to branch as
they descended through the jungle.
It was a prickly silence, though.
Blue had an aura of guilt around him.
Swordtail kept muttering under his breath
and Sundew could feel Cricket's eyes on
her.
She knew her well enough by now to guess
that cricket was trying really hard to
hold back a question, and that pretty
soon she would fail.
Sundoo?
Cricket burst out as they passed a
cluster of glowering giant hogweeds.
Ah, what, Sundew said, casting a glance
over her shoulder at the hive wing
Crickets glasses were fogged up from the
humidity, and she kept swiping at them
with bumblebee's sling.
It's just...
Cricket hesitated.
And Sundu realized what she was going to
ask.
Even in the midst of fighting the fire
with Bromeliad pools?
Of course, cricket would notice what
every dragon around her was doing.
Especially if it was something weird and
unscientific.
Cricket tilted her head at sundew.
Did you make a tree grow?
Chapter 3.
Sundew winced.
Her gift was no secret inside the tribe
but Belladonna had been very clear that
she wasn't supposed to let any hive wings
or silk wings find out about it.
Sundew had already risked exposing it
twice.
Once, when she grew the vines that helped
Blue and Luna escape the flame silk
cavern.
Once, when she used seaweed to help her
transport an unconscious sword tail
across Dragonfly Bay, she had gotten away
with it both times, she'd even managed to
avoid cricket's questions.
But there was no way to get around the
poison jungle without using her power.
She couldn't even walk through the leaf
wing village without dragons asking her
for help with their plants.
Cricket and the others would know
everything soon anyway.
Yeah, she said to Cricket.
I do that sometimes.
Grow trees?
Cricket asked, like, really tall trees
out of nowhere before anyone can blink.
Not out of nowhere, Sandu said.
I can only help along whatever plant is
already there.
I can't make plants or seeds appear.
If I could.
I'd have been throwing down oak trees and
beech groves and pine forests all over
Pantala by now.
But that's amazing, Blue said.
Why didn't you tell us?
Because you didn't know if you could
trust us.
He answered himself immediately.
Because you wouldn't want Queen Wasp to
find out.
As if we would ever tell Queen Wasp
Sortell objected.
Oh, Blue said.
I remember reading something about this.
Leaf Wings who could control plants.
I remember thinking that sounded like
magic, and wondering what I would grow
with it if I could.
Can all leaf wings do this?
Cricket asked.
Sundew shook her head, but she was
rescued from any further questions by an
eruption of roars from the jungle below.
The others jumped, and Bumblebee woke up
and poked her head out of the sling.
R?
she inquired.
Bamo slamoee now?
Everyone, shush, Sundu said, crouching
low to the branch.
Especially you, she whispered to
Bumblebee.
You sha, hush, shush.
Bumblebee declared proudly.
Cricket produced a berry from somewhere
and the little dragonette seized it and
stuffed it whole into her mouth, which
would keep her quiet for most 10
seconds.
Thick leaves hid them from what was
happening below.
But Sundew could clearly hear at least 3
dragons bellowing, and a 4th roar that
didn't sound like a dragon to her.
She rested her ear against the bark of
the tree, and tried to get the tree's
sense of what was going on.
But whatever it was, the tree was
apparently not threatened, and therefore
not interested.
Come on, Mandrake, one of the dragons
bellowed.
Strangle it or something.
It's moving too fast.
Mandrake's voice shouted back.
If it would just, can we back it over to
or next to that?
Can't I please just kill it?
yelled that there a dragon.
We could be home and cooking it by now.
This panther will die of old age before
mandrake finds the perfect vine in the
perfect place and figures out what to do
with it.
Oh, poor mandrake.
Sundew could guess exactly what was
happening now.
She'd seen enough of the hunt this
hapless dragon had been dragged into by
his father and sister.
Stay here, she whispered to the others.
Sundew swung lightly down through the
branches, slipping carefully through the
leaves and avoiding the spider webs as
well as she could.
In a moment, she found a spot near the
trunk with a view of the jungle floor
where, if she kept still, the clusters of
giant rattling seed pods should keep her
hidden.
Now she could see mandrake, darting
helplessly around the clearing, grabbing
at plants, but letting them go without
using them.
His father and sister watched from the
low branches of the nearest trees, with
matching critical expressions on their
faces.
The panther slunk after him, snarling.
Its teeth bigger than mandrake's claws.
Its black fur rippled over huge muscles.
Only the biggest, strongest, scariest
mammals could survive in the poison
jungle, so all their panthers were
unnecessarily gigantic and terrifying.
Terrifying to dragons like mandrake, that
is, not at all terrifying to sundo, who
was in charge of hunting their prey for
every big tribe feast.
How dare they have mandrake do it
instead?
She thought with a flare of anger.
Are they having a feast without me?
Don't they care where I am?
Aren't I their precious savior of the
world or something?
Then again, her last fight with
Belladonna had been quite dramatic.
It would be just like her mother to spite
her by burning down a hive and
celebrating with an all tribe panther
feast, while pretending she didn't care
whether sundew was there or not.
She knew Sundew would have to come back
eventually.
Sundew had nowhere else to go.
But if I did, if I could just fly away.
Would I?
Sunday's talons went to the pout with a
little jade frog in it.
I could have left.
Belladonna doesn't even know I could have
left them.
But I didn't.
Because I have a purpose, and that
purpose is vengeance.
I hatched for one reason.
To destroy our enemies.
That's why I will always come back, not
for Belladonna, or Hemlock.
I come back, so that one day I can be the
one who wipes out the hive wings
forever.
A tiny face clamoring, Snoodoo, poked its
way into her thoughts, and she scowled.
Or, oh, the high wings except two, I
guess.
Below her, the panther pounced
experimentally toward mandrake.
Mandrake shrieked and threw a seed pod at
it before running off to the other side
of the clearing.
Nettle sighed loudly and rolled her
eyes.
He has to learn how to do this.
Wolf Spain said to her.
Why?
She complained.
I could do it so much faster without any
magical powers.
And if we need the magic, We have
sundew.
We don't have sundew right now.
Her father pointed out.
She might have to go on another mission
like this one.
And what if we're attacked and Mandrake
has to step up.
Then we're all going to die.
Nettle said flatly.
I can hear you, Mandrake protested, and
it is not helping.
He dug his talons into the leaf mulch
underneath him and closed his eyes.
By all the trees, Sundew thought.
Don't close your eyes, mandrake.
Not when there's a panther stalking you.
This was why mandrake was never assigned
to offensive plant magic.
He always had to focus and breathe, even
in the middle of an actual emergency.
Well, sundew couldn't let him get mauled
by a panther, even if that might make her
life a little easier.
She sent her magic down through the trunk
and into the ground and through the roots
and the mosses and ferns to the thicket
of thorn tangles behind the panther.
As it crouched, growling, ready to spring
at mandrake, she felt into the root
system that extended below the panther's
paws.
Just before the giant cat leaped.
A new thorn bush burst out of the ground
and slammed into the panther's
underbelly.
Thorns stabbed and tangled the panther's
fur as they sprouted, trapping the animal
in place, with a furious yowl it tried to
struggle.
But its movements only ensnared it
further.
Across the clearing, Wolfsbane and Nettle
goggled at the panther in bewilderment
Sundew had to cover her snout to keep
from laughing.
Mandrake cracked one eyelid, then opened
them both, looking startled and pleased.
Whoa.
Did I do that?
He asked.
Son.
Wolfsbang crowed.
Look at you.
That was incredible.
Uh-uh, Nettles said, resettling her face
into its usual sneer.
No way.
Send do.
Send you.
You can't fool me.
I know you're here somewhere.
Sundew held her breath, wondering if she
could brazen it out.
Wolfsbane and mandrake squinted up into
the trees, and of course, right into that
moment of silence, a very loud, high
pitched voice howled, Snoo doo.
What was that?
Mandrake asked, looking spooked?
Sounded like a dragonette, said his
father.
Sounded like proof that I am right.
Nettle barked, come on out, sundew.
Sundew sighed.
There was no hiding the wrestling and
shushing noises coming from above, or the
e, e, now. wail that followed.
Dragonettes, 100% the worst.
She swung down from the tree and thumped
to the ground in a cloud of damp leaf
fragments.
Hey, mandrake, she said with a nod.
Oh, he said, his wings drooping.
It was you.
Pardon me for making sure you didn't
become her feast instead of the other way
around, Sandu growled, flicking her tail
of the panther.
I knew it, Nettle said.
Sorry, I mean, thank you, said Mandrake.
I was just excited for a moment.
I know, Sundoo said, but you have to
learn to feel the plants, with your eyes
open.
She glared at wolf's vein.
Especially if your irresponsible family
is going to keep trying to get you
killed.
I was watching him.
Wolf Spain said dismissively.
Sundo.
What is that cacophony up there?
He pointed out with his eyebrows raised
as though there was anything unfamiliar
about the sound of a hungry dragonette
throwing a temper tantrum.
You can come down.
Sunday's shouted to her friends.
Go to the trunk and work your way down
slowly.
Don't touch anything but the tree.
Metal's mouth dropped open again.
Who is that?
She demanded.
Someone who doesn't know our jungle?
Did you bring strangers into our trees?
Don't be a drama queen.
Sundew said sharply.
They can help us.
Do your parents know about this?
Wolfsbane asked, which was only the most
irritating question in the universe, and
one Sunday was very sick of hearing.
Belladonna and Hemlock had gone ahead and
burned down a hive without asking her
first.
So it served them right for her to bring
hive wings and silk wings into the jungle
without their permission.
Sortell hid the ground first.
His talons sinking into the layers of
moss and dead leaves with a squelch.
He looked a little the worse for wear
after his tussle with a dragon trap, but
still very clearly a silk wing.
Nettle was about to snap something
furious.
When Blue climbed down behind Swordtail
and she lost her powers of speech, There
was nothing that color blue in the poison
jungle.
He was a kind of shiny that sundew's
tribe wasn't used to.
But even blue's beautiful wings couldn't
distract the leaf wings from the
appearance of cricket, cradling
bumblebee.
Nettle flared her wings with a violent
hiss.
Wolfsbane whipped a long, thorny vine off
his tail and held it ready to fight.
Even mandrake growled softly under his
breath.
It's all right, calm down, Sundu said.
They're with me.
That doesn't make it all right, Nettle
cried.
Hive wings in here?
What is wrong with you?
Queen Wasp will be right behind them.
No, she won't.
Sundew snapped.
She can't mind control these two.
She doesn't know where they are or where
we are.
Nothing has changed, except now we have a
flame silk.
Wolfsbane let out a little huff of
surprise and pointed at Blue.
That one.
Sundew hesitated. and was furious at
herself for hesitating.
Why did she feel weird about this?
Yes, she said.
She felt a twinge of that weird feeling
at the nervous look on Blue's face.
But he doesn't have anything to worry
about, she told herself.
He can be useful to us, and will protect
him from wasp.
Win-win.
I wouldn't say you have a flame silk.
Swartell said pointedly.
I mean, he is a flame silk, and he's here
but he has himself.
No one else has him.
I mean, he is not for having.
He's his own dragon.
Hmm.
Wolf Spain said, ignoring him and
studying blue with fathomless brown
eyes.
So why not kill the others and just keep
this one sundo?
Because they're all useful, Sundew said
quickly.
She tried to make her voice sound as
aggressive and no nonsense as she could
especially the hive wing.
She's immune to the mind control, and we
think she's figured out how WASP does
it.
What about him?
Metal asked, pointing its sword tail.
He looks unnecessary.
All right, maybe useful is the wrong
word.
Sendu amended, earning an offended look
from the blue orange white dragon.
But we can't kill him without upsetting
the flame silk, not worth it.
Blue blinked, and sidled a step closer to
SwordTail.
His antennae had unfurled into thin
trembling stems over his head, like
tentacles of ivy looking for a place to
land safely.
I am useful, Swartel protested, I have
many uses.
I am smart, and I know things, and I can
fight hive wings, and I am in the
chrysalis.
Hello, which everyone seems to forget
secret revolutionary over here.
And I am also, by the way, extremely good
company.
And the dragonette, Wolfbane asked
Sundew.
An experiment, she said.
We think she's immune to the mind control
too.
Youth think?
Nettle demanded.
That's quite a risky experiment, you
idiots.
It's going great so far, Sundew flared.
You get away with everything, because
you're Belladonna's daughter, and you're
so special.
Nettle shouted, but you've gone too far
this time sundew.
No one will stand for this.
Let's go ask Belladonna what to do
Wolfsbane said, resting one talon on
Nettle's shoulder.
Fine.
Nettles shook him off, but I know what
she'll say.
We'll be back soon to execute your new
pets.
She folded her wings and hissed at sundew
one more time before turning and marching
away.
Wait for us here, Wolf Spain said.
I'll stay with them.
Mandrake offered.
Wolfbane gave a faint shrug and followed
Nettle into the undergrowth.
Sundew sat down with a snort of disgust.
This wasn't how she'd planned to arrive.
She was supposed to be the one who
explained all this to Belladonna.
Not that she wanted to, but she didn't
want stupid wolfsbane to do it.
He'd get it all wrong.
But it didn't matter.
Belladonna wasn't the boss of Sundew
except in the literal, she ran the whole
tribe sense, but Sundew was going to save
the world, and wreak furious vengeance on
those who deserved it.
So there wasn't anything Belladonna could
do to her or her friends, not if she
wanted a part in a vengeance.
Just try me, mother.
Oh, Blue said, that didn't sound like it
went very well.
Really?
That was a pretty average conversation
with Nettle, Sundew said.
She took a breath, searching the greenery
with her mind.
There.
A bush covered in small pale globules.
Her power slipped through the roots and
stems to grow just one of the branches
out until she could reach it.
She took one of the sticky white berries
and threw it at the panther.
It snarled and snapped the berry out of
the air.
A moment later, the panther keeled over
dead.
Oh, cool, Mandrake said with a flick of
his wings, which were dark green with
thin gold stripes on top and mahogany
brown underneath.
But everyone can still eat the panther
right?
Yeah, I use these on prey all the time
she said, tossing one to him.
Harmless to dragons, deadly to mammals.
No idea why.
Really?
Cricket said.
Mandrake handed her the berry, and she
gave it a fascinated look.
E?
Bumblebee asked, leaning out of her sling
hopefully.
Maybe not this, Cricket said to her, just
to be safe.
Here, these are all right to eat, Sundew
said, unearthing a tuber from the dark
earth and flinging it to cricket.
Snoodoo.
Bumblebee cooed, with a worshipful look.
Maybe she thinks Snoodoo means food
Sundoo guest.
Pretty sure she knows it's you.
The hero who provides all the best food
cricket said, tucking the root into
bumblebee's tiny talons, the dragonette
wrapped her little arms around the tuber
and began gnawing on it with great
determination.
Excuse me.
Should we be running away?
Swartell asked, maybe hiding?
Boss?
Don't you think hiding us might be a good
idea?
No, you nitwit?
We're trying to get to the village, not
hide from it.
Getting there was the whole point.
Nobody's going to execute you.
Sundew said impatiently.
Not until I tell them to anyway.
They need me.
Because of your power, cricket guest.
They need yours too.
Sundew pointed out to Blue.
So tell them exactly what you want.
Don't let them walk all over you.
Oh, but all right.
But mild dragons are hard to deal with, he
said.
Are all leaf wings that, um, shouty?
Everyone but me.
Mandrake answered with a nervous laugh.
That's not true.
Sundew thought, touching her jade frog
lightly through the pouch, but he's never
met the others.
The one nice leaf wing, Swartail said
sounds like a good dragon to know.
I'm Cricket.
This is Bumblebee.
That's Blue, and that's Swordtail, cricket
said.
She tilted her head at Mandrake.
Who are you?
I'm Mandrake, he said, smiling his non
threatening, crooked smile at all of
them.
Sundu's fiance.
Chapter 4.
Cricket world to stare at sundew.
Her what?
Sword tail echoed.
I thought we agreed not to use that
word.
Sundu grumbled at Mandrake.
Well, future husband sounds weird, he
pointed out.
So does fiance, super weird.
She snapped a dying branch off the
nearest bush and broke it in her talons
over and over until it was a pile of
splinters.
But you, this dragon?
Blue said, bewildered.
I just Didn't picture your one true love
being someone like this.
Cricket finished for him.
Nobody said anything about true love.
Sundew yelped.
At the same time as Mandrake stammered, no
no, that's not at all.
No, we are not that, no.
Cricket and Blue exchanged puzzled
glances, which made Sundo want to poke
them quite hard with her claws.
Just because they were all melty and
silly over each other didn't mean
everyone else in the world got to be that
way.
But, I thought, cricket started, and
Sundew suddenly had a horrible flash of
memory.
Oh no.
She'd said something to the nosy hive
wing a few days ago about how she
understood Sordail's obsession with Luna
because she had a one true love too.
A thing she hadn't even thought about
blurting out, because she'd never
expected to see cricket standing here, in
the poison jungle, right in front of
Mandrake, about to spill the biggest
secret was keeping from her tribe.
Nope, she shouted, before Cricket could
finish her sentence, wrong, bad, no
thinking.
Whatever you thought, stuff it back in
there.
She bumped Mandrake's side, and did a
weird hopping sidestep that was
definitely not going to convince anyone
of her sanity.
We're just betrothed.
It's not weird.
It's normal fine.
Oh my goodness.
Blue said, blinking.
What is happening right now?
Swordell asked.
All right, I'm sorry, Cricket said.
She took a step back from sundew, tilting
her wings calmingly.
I totally misunderstood.
She hadn't, and she didn't, and she knew
it.
Sandu couldn't read other dragons the way
she could read plants, but cricket was
like a wide open encyclopedia, and at the
moment, her pages were turned to mystery
I am biting my tongue about for now, but
will definitely solve eventually.
Which did not bode well for sundew's
secret.
So, how can you have a fiance?
Cricket asked. aren't you the same age as
I am?
I'm six, Sundew said.
But ever since we hatched, the plan has
always been for us to get married
eventually.
We both have the strongest leaf speak in
the tribe, which means our dragonettes
should be even more powerful, and that's
what the tribe needs to defeat the hive
wings and restore the trees.
Unless I can do it all myself.
Then I could be with a dragon I choose.
Mandrake was nodding.
Sundube's leaf speak is much stronger
than mine, though, he said.
The strongest our tribe is seen in
centuries.
That's why Belladonna and Hemlock got
together to have me, Sundu said.
They had the strongest leaf speak in the
last generation.
The tribe has been working toward having
a dragon like sundew ever since the tree
wars, Mandrake added.
Oh, Cricket said, as though several
answers were finally clicking together in
her head.
When did my parents get back?
Sundew asked Mandrake.
She wanted to know, and she also very
much wanted to get off the subject of her
future marriage.
Not long before you, he said.
Maybe half a day?
And only Belladonna and Odalum.
Hemlock and the other 2 were going to
ground near the, uh, the target.
He cast a nervous glance of the other
dragons.
They know, she said.
We saw the fire, from a distance, I
mean.
His eyes lit up.
Oh, wow.
Was it amazing?
Billadonna said they torched the whole
thing.
Flames brushing the clouds, hive wings
screaming with rage.
We weren't that close.
Sundu said, we just saw the smoke.
I don't know if the whole hive burned
down.
And I wouldn't trust Belladonna's
report.
Her mother had a tendency to exaggerate
especially when it came to grand plans
against Queen Wasp.
The whole hive.
Blue echoed, gazing up into the trees.
And all the webs connected to it.
Mandrake had the grace to look a little
abashed.
Was that your hive?
He asked.
No, Swordtail answered.
You guys burned down bloodworm hive.
And good riddance.
Good riddance to all of them.
Sundew saw cricket flinch, and Blue
gently rest his tail on hers.
Blah!
Bumblebee announced suddenly.
She threw the tuber at Sortail's head
bonking him on the snout.
No, blah.
Gimme go.
Give me go.
Hey, ow, you violent little larva, sword
tell yelped.
Bumblebee, calm down, Cricket said, trying
to wrestle the dragonette back into the
sling, but the little hive wing was too
furious to be handled.
She yowled and threw out her yellow and
black striped wings, and flung herself
around, wailing, until she managed to
topple out of Cricket's arms onto the
leaf mulch.
Immediately she popped up and sprinted
over to sundew, as well as she could
sprint.
It was more of a wattle, if one were
going to be strictly accurate.
Bumblebee collapsed on top of Sundew's
foot, and batted her woebegone amber eyes
up in Sundew's general direction.
Snoodoo, she sniffled.
Snoop, blimy.
Whatever is snoobly me is?
It's not my problem.
Sundu informed her.
Bumblebee clutched her ankle as Sundew
tried to pull away.
Hubble, snowble, boo, she said
piteously.
Eee, Snorf.
How starving can you be?
Sundu demanded.
We'll be in the village soon, and there's
plenty of food there.
Bumblebee's pinprick claws dug into
sundew's scales as she clambered up onto
the leaf wing's shoulder and snuggled
into the curve between her wing and
neck.
Penny foo, she said confidently.
Sundew had never held a dragonette, or
ever had anything climb on her, apart
from unpleasant insects, as far as she
could remember.
Her mother had outlawed pets in the
village, because they wasted resources
and distracted dragons from their
mission.
Dragonettes were strictly supervised and
kept to their own area for their safety
and also probably because Belladonna
didn't like them anymore than Sundew
did.
All her front of brain thought, told her
to peel off the baby hive wing and give
it back to cricket.
She did not need to walk into her tribe
with a tiny enemy plastered to her neck
burbling cheerfully.
Also, she shouldn't let bumblebee get any
more attached to her.
Also, also, what if Queen Wasp did jump
into bumblebee all of a sudden?
Then the dragonette would be in the
perfect position to strangle sundew.
I'm not scared of wasp.
She scolded herself.
I can protect myself from a dragonette
and I don't have to prove anything to
anyone in my tribe.
So what if they don't like that I've got
a hive wing on my shoulder.
I am going to let her stay there.
Just to show them I don't care.
This is stupid.
We don't have to sit here and wait for
Wolfsbane, she said, resettling her wings
to keep Bumblebee in place.
I don't need permission to go into my own
village.
Come on.
She marched toward the trees.
But sundo, Mandrake protested, it'll only
be a moment.
Don't make them mad.
They're already mad, she retorted.
They're going to be mad no matter what we
do.
And it's not like we're going to spend
the night in the jungle.
We're going in.
Follow me and don't ask questions, she
said, giving Cricket a stern look.
Even, I mean, yes, and do, Cricket said.
Bring the panther, Sundoo said to
Mandrake.
She sent a message to the Thorn Bines, and
they relaxed, releasing the big cat's
body enough that Mandrake could haul it
over one shoulder and stagger along
behind them.
The outer perimeter of the village was a
short walk away.
It looked like an upside down nest, a
huge emerald and chocolate colored living
dome made of interlocking vines and
shrubs that soared up and up between the
trees.
The barrier enclosed the entire village
protecting the dragons inside from all
the ways the jungle might try to sneak in
to kill them, hemlock, belladonna, and
sundew's grandmother had started it with
their limited leaf speak, but sundew had
perfected it.
She tested it as they approached, sending
her senses along the roots under her
talons and out through the weaving
branches to search for any holes or
weaknesses.
There was a patch where the leaves were
thin.
After a moment of pressing the edges with
her mind, she found an infestation of
caterpillars that were nibbling their way
through the roof.
Oh no, you don't.
Nobody eats my work.
You will die for this caterpillars.
She summoned another vine to coil across
the thin spot, blending in with the other
leaves, except this one was full of toxic
sap.
When the caterpillars tried to eat it
they would be poisoned.
Or they would see their friends dying
wise up, and go find a different plant to
invest.
It was very satisfying.
If only all sundew's problems could be
solved that easily.
Wow.
Cricket said as the whole barrier came
into view, rising far over their heads.
How did you, er, I mean, I really wonder
how dragons could build something like
this and how long it would take.
And which plants were used and how it
survives, but notice how I am totally not
asking, although I am definitely
listening, should anyone around here
maybe feel like talking about it?
I'll give you a tour later, Sundew said
hiding her amusement.
Of course, sundew could go in and out of
the barrier anywhere she wished, just by
communicating with the plants, but for
the sake of appearances, when anyone was
watching, she went through the main
gate.
Unless it was super annoying, and that
depended on who the guard on duty was.
A long, elegant dragon sat in coiled
stillness by the entrance, as poised as a
carnivorous plant waiting for her prey to
pass by.
Sundew squinted at her, and saw streaks
of pinkish red along her horns, and the
veins of her summer green wings.
She exhaled with relief, they were in
luck.
It was Cobra Lily, one of sundew's
favorite dragons.
Cobra Lily was the opposite of Nettle.
She was never annoying or judgmental, and
she rarely shouted.
When Cobra Lily got angry?
It was a deep, cold, icy anger that she
held on to for the rest of her life, and
only friends like Sundew knew it was
there.
Sundew had once seen her slip a deadly
mantineal fruit into another dragon's
lunch as payback for insulting her sister
2 years earlier.
He'd survived, but only barely.
Cobra Lily was kind of awesome.
Hello, beautiful.
Cobra Lily said languidly, as they came
up.
You've got a little monster on your
neck.
You have no idea, Sundu agreed.
How's the village?
Did I miss anything?
Boring without you?
Cobra Lily leaned down to nudge sundew
with her snout.
You were gone forever.
I nearly murdered Nettle just to make
something interesting happen.
I can't imagine anyone objecting to
that.
Anyway, I know, but wait till you see
what I brought back.
Sundew moved Bumblebee to her back so she
could sort through her pouches.
Spies and slugs by the look of it, Cobra
Lily guest, eyeing the other dragons over
Sundew's shoulder.
The book of Clearsight.
Sundew said, as she hauled it out and put
it in Cobra Lily's talons.
And the secret of wasp's mind control, we
think.
She brought out the length of vine she'd
cut off the plant in Wasp's greenhouse.
Any idea what this is?
Cobra Lily studied it for a moment. before
turning her eyes back to the book.
Never seen it before, she said.
That was disappointing.
Cobra Lily was always top of the class.
Sundew had hoped she'd be able to solve
the mystery quickly, but there were other
leaf wings Sundew could ask.
Thump went the little jade frog over her
heart as she tucked the vine away again.
Belladonna said this was useless, Cobra
Lily flipped through the pages of the
book, scanning Clearsight's prophecies.
It's not, no way, Cricket burst out
because now we know the truth.
Did she tell you what's in there and how
it changes everything?
Cobra Lily leveled her cool gaze on
cricket.
Why is your prisoner talking to me?
She asked Sundu.
She's not my prisoner.
She's, I don't know, an ally, I guess, and
she's right.
I mean, we nearly got killed stealing it
so it better not be useless.
I can't believe Belladon has said that.
Sundu growled softly.
Was Belladonna trying to downplay Sundu's
successful mission?
Cobra Lily handed back the book.
Cool.
Good luck explaining them to everyone
else.
A moment later, they were inside, or at
least into the detoxification chamber.
Cricket looked around in puzzlement at
the tightly woven branches that
surrounded them.
The space where they stood was barely big
enough to fit 4 dragons, and one tiny
dragonette, squeezed in together.
It was meant for three, but of course
SwordTail squashed himself in as well.
Mandrake, on the other talon, was
politely waiting outside for his turn.
Get off my tail, Sundu said.
Shoving sword tail away.
Bumblebee, close your eyes.
The dragonette tilted her head
quizzically, and send Drew reached out to
cover the little high wings face with one
of her talons.
Why are we all, Blue shrieked, as a
cascade of water poured over them.
Cricket threw her wings over her head, and
Soritel blundered back onto Sunday's tail
so she had to push him off again.
As quickly as it had come, the water was
gone. sluicing away through a channel
that led outside the barrier.
That's to wash away any seeds that might
have been trying to sneak in.
Sundew explained.
She pointed at the clusters of thorn
balls and tiny winged seed pods that were
spinning away on the surface of the dirty
water.
The poison jungle is always trying to get
through, and it has many tricks, but so
do we.
But you feel stupid now, seeds, she
shouted at them.
The seeds feel stupid.
Blue asked, blinking.
Well, they should, Sundew said.
I've told them a 1000000 times to stay
out of here, but it's the one order they
can't seem to get through their thick
heads.
Pods, bark, arr.
There isn't a dragon speak word for it.
Maybe the instinct to spread is too
strong, Cricket said thoughtfully.
It's survival to them, sticking to
whatever will carry them the farthest
trying to plant themselves wherever they
can.
I mean, is it disobedience if they can't
help it?
How would a plant teach its seeds to fall
off our feet before we enter the
village?
That would be so amazing if it could
though.
Some kind of warning system maybe?
But it would have to know that going
inside the village would kill it
somehow.
She trailed off, as Sundu pushed open the
chamber door, and they all stepped
through into the murky green light under
the dome.
This was the village, Sundew's home.
The safest place in the poison jungle.
A circle cleared of all the deadliest
plants, so that leaf wing dragonettes had
half a chance of surviving to adulthood.
Instead of menacing Strangler vines
dragon traps, or deadly sandbox trees
looming overhead.
There was open air all the way to the
roof of the dome, as high above them as
the tree canopy.
It was high enough for dragons to fly, and
for dragonettes to learn to fly, without
the danger of anything snaring their
wings, or dripping poison on their
scales.
Sundew was kind of unreasonably proud of
this feature.
Belladonna had started the walls, but
she'd never managed to complete the
overhead enclosure on her own, so it had
only become truly safe in here once
sundew came along.
Fatalities, especially among the
Dragonettes, had dropped significantly.
But of course, we can't talk about that.
We can't take a moment to say, hey, things
are a little better, aren't they?
We can only talk about the hive wings, and
our fury, and all the things we're going
to do to them.
No time to pat you on the head or say
thank you, Sundo.
She took a deep breath.
Stepping into the village always made her
heart beat faster. and her ears lie flat
as though she was preparing for battle.
It should have been the other way
around.
It should have been the jungle that set
off her danger sensors, but in here
Sundew knew that her mother was always a
few steps away, that they were always
only moments from a fight.
Sundew.
Case in point.
Belladonna came thundering out of the
meeting house, her wings billowing like
storm clouds.
She flew down the steps and landed with
one claw already in sundew's face.
How dare you bring enemies into our
village?
I told her to wait outside.
Wolvesbang cried, aggrieved.
Hey, I told you to wait outside.
Yeah, not share where you got the idea
that you can tell me to do anything.
Sundew said to him.
She batted her mother's claw aside.
And you might remember, mother, that
working with these dragons was your idea
in the 1st place.
Out there, Belladonna yelled, pointing
vaguely out of the jungle, not in here.
What is that on your neck?
This is Bumblebee.
Sundew said.
She had to admit, she was kind of
enjoying how much she'd thrown her mother
for a loop.
Isn't she cute?
Me, mommy.
The dragonette said, curling her tail
around sundew's neck and edging a little
closer.
Other leaf wings were gathering
whispering, arguing in hushed tones all
around them.
One of them pointed at cricket, and there
was a ripple of scowls across all the
green and brown faces.
These are our allies, Sun to announce, in
a raised voice.
Anyone who hurts a scale on their bodies
will find his or her eyeballs on the
wrong end of a bombardier beetle.
She turned back to Belladonna.
Cricket, as you know, is immune to wasps
mind control, and blue is a flame silk.
They helped us get the book of Clearsight
as you requested, and now they need a
place to hide from WASP.
Seems like the least we could do, right?
A flame silk, one of the leaf wings
called.
Prove it. called another.
Sundew grabbed Blue's wrist to stop him
but he'd remembered her lecture and was
already shaking his head.
Not in here, you bees for brains.
She spat at the offending leaf wing.
He doesn't have to prove it, Belladonna
said regally.
We know what he is.
It was his flame silk we use to burn down
bloodworm hive.
Blue gasped. and pulled away from sundew
as the dragons around them went, Oh, in
hushed, pleased tones.
Wait, what?
Cricket said, blues, flame, silk, but
how?
They didn't know.
They never put it together.
It hadn't occurred to Sundew that this
would be a surprise to them.
Maybe an unforgivable surprise.
Judging by the looks on their faces.
Is that true?
Blue asked.
Send you, Cricket said.
How did your parents get their claws on
Blue's flame silk?
Chapter 5.
I gave it to them.
Sundu said defiantly.
Of course I did.
So what?
Blue sat down and clutched his head.
When?
he cried.
How did you even have any?
I gathered some when you 1st came out of
your cocoon, Sundu said.
Don't you remember?
I put it in a stone jar.
I wasn't sneaky about it.
But you were with us from then until we
escaped Jewel Hive, Cricket said.
Weren't you?
I thought you didn't see your parents in
all that time.
I saw them the night after I got Blue's
Flame Silk, Sundu said.
While you were all asleep in the carpet
stall outside the glitter bazaar, I got
up early and met them to give them my
report, and the flame silk as they had
requested.
And to ask for more time, as you
requested, which they said no to again
and then came back and rejoined you
before you woke up.
Why didn't you tell us?
Swartell demanded.
I don't report to you, Sundew pointed
out.
Belladonna was my mission commander.
Not that you follow my orders very well
either.
Belladon observed.
I can't believe this.
Cricket said to Sundo.
I keep thinking you, but then I keep
being wrong.
Their expressions gave Sundew a squiggly
feeling that she wanted to stab and stab
and stab until it was dead.
How can you possibly be surprised?
she asked.
Where did you think they got the fire to
burn down bloodworm hive?
I didn't think it was from me.
Blue said.
He buried his face in his talons.
Cricket sat down next to him and spread
one of her wings over him.
You took such a little bit.
You only need a little bit of flame silk
if you have the right materials.
Belladonna said briskly, although, of
course, more is better, which is why
you're going to be so useful for the rest
of the war.
Blue shuddered.
No way.
He said.
I don't want to be useful for killing
anyone.
Billadonna's look was almost pitying.
Sundew could almost see a dragon in there
who felt guilty about what she wanted to
do, and who maybe understood why Blue
didn't want to do it.
But that dragon was never going to be the
one everyone else saw.
You can't imagine we'd let a weapon like
yours fall into our talons and not use it
Sundu's mother said.
Try to think of what we're doing as
freeing your tribe, rather than killing
the other one.
Does that help?
No, Blue cried.
If you want his cooperation, Sandu
interjected.
You're going to have to take care of his
friends.
Safe harbor for both silk wings and both
hive wings, and I do mean safe.
No mysterious leaves in their food, no
fire ants in their beds.
If you want the flame silk to help you
you have to take care of them just as
well as you take care of him.
But Sun do, Blue started.
Then yelped as Swordell trod on his
foot.
What she said, Swartell talked over him
exactly that, especially the no fire
ants.
Please.
Belladonna sat back on her haunches, and
regarded them with narrowed eyes for a
long moment.
Hmm, she said.
Very clever, sundew.
Sundew managed by the skin of her teeth
not to say, really?
In an excited little dragonette voice
she'd outwitted her mother.
It was just like she'd said to Blue.
He had to realize he had the power here
and together they could use it.
They just had to be smart, and maybe he
wouldn't want to use his flame silk at
first, but she could convince him, or
figure out a way to use it that he
wouldn't have a problem with.
Yes, Belladonna said.
Flicking her tail and shooting sundew and
approving look.
Bringing us hostages to leverage in case
the flame silk was reluctant.
Very, very clever.
I knew we'd raised a smart little
warrior.
Sundew's jaw dropped.
That wasn't, she hadn't, That was not how
this was supposed to go.
Cricket and bumblebee weren't leverage.
There were even minutes when she liked
swordtail.
Every once in a while.
She certainly hadn't meant to turn them
over to her mother as hostages.
And maybe Belladonna knew that.
Maybe the betrayed look on cricket's face
was exactly the reaction she'd been
hoping for.
Or maybe her mother really did think
Sundew had tricked all these dragons into
walking into her claws.
Either way, Belladonna saw them as her
prisoners now.
Sundew's rage pulsed under her scales.
She wanted to flay something.
She wanted to upend all her pouches over
Belladonna's head and let the insects
devour her.
She wanted to scream and tear down the
barrier. and let the jungle come surging
in.
I meant what I said, she hissed.
Anyone who harms these dragons will
answer to me.
That includes you, Belladonna.
All right, dear, her mother said
dismissively.
Which was the worst.
Sundew was going to straight up stab her
just for that tone of voice.
Never mind everything else.
Belladonna turned and waved one talon at
Wolfsbane.
Let's put them all in poke weed's nest.
He'll be hiding out with hemlock for who
knows how long.
We'll take Bryonies too, Sundoo said.
She knew which nests were free.
She knew which dragons had been sent to
burn the hive.
And she wasn't going to let Belladonna
pen up Cricket and the others in one tiny
place.
It didn't have to feel like prison, even
if it kind of was.
Even if this whole place feels like a
prison to me sometimes.
From the moment she'd stepped back into
the village, Sundew's claws had been
twitching.
She was so close to where she really
wanted to be.
She'd been gone for so long, and she'd
managed to focus on the mission for all
that time.
But now, all she wanted to do was blast a
hole in the barrier and run to her
dragon.
She touched the pout with a jade frog in
it.
Not much longer.
Don't make a stupid mistake now, with
everyone watching.
Get them settled and come report to me.
Belladonna said to send you.
I particularly want a full explanation of
that. thing.
She flicked one claw at Bumblebee.
We'll get the feast ready, Wolfsbane said
hurrying to where mandrake had dropped
the panther.
Bumblebee grabbed Sundew's ear and
whispered, he into it.
Yes, come on.
We'll find you something.
Sundew turned toward the food stores.
Wait, Swordell said, jumping forward.
Sundu, ask about Luna.
Sundew was pretty sure her tribe hadn't
found Luna.
If they had captured another more willing
flame silk already, They wouldn't be
reacting this way to blue.
But she had promised to ask.
She lifted her chin and looked up into
her mother's sharp green eyes.
Has anyone seen another silk wing?
She was blown out to sea several days
ago?
We wondered if she came ashore in the
jungle?
Belladonna turned to look at one of her
lieutenants, who shook her head.
Those are the 1st silk wings I've ever
seen.
Biblus said, pointing at blue and sword
tail, we haven't run into any strange
dragons in our territory.
She started to say something else
hesitated, and then shook her head
again.
No, we haven't brought anyone unusual
into our village.
There was a very slight, barely
perceptible emphasis on our.
Sundu heard it, and she knew what that
meant, and that the smart thing to do
would be to wait and get answers her own
way later.
But unfortunately, cricket heard it too
and she pounced.
Did you say our village?
What does that mean?
She asked.
What were you going to say?
Biblus shifted on her talons, stirring
the leaf mulch under her claws, Nothing
she said.
No confirmed reports, only rumors.
I don't bring every silly rumor back to
our commander.
She bowed her head toward Belladonna.
Rumors of what?
Soratell nudged Sundee's side.
Make them tell us, Sundu.
I must admit, I'm curious as well.
Belladonna said archly.
I give you permission to share, Biblus.
Well, all right.
The other leaf wing looked very
uncomfortable.
Biblus was one of Belladonna's most loyal
dragons.
She was in Sundew's earliest memories
following her mother's orders, watching
over Sundew, making sure all the rules
were followed.
Biblus needed rules.
She liked everything to fit into
squares.
She never set foot outside the barrier
unless she was on a specific mission, and
then she came right back.
Sharing an unsubstantiated rumor without
evidence to back it up, must have felt
like rubbing nettles on her palms to
her.
A few of the guards on patrol mentioned
that there was increased activity over
there.
She said.
More noise, voices raised.
Agitated trees.
The ones with leaf speak said there was a
whisper of something new.
But you know how plans can be.
They often don't know what they don't
know.
We believe we noted slightly more prey
being caught.
Nothing definite, mind you.
But potentially consistent with the
possibility of one or more strange
dragons perhaps having arrived.
There.
Where?
Thordell cried.
What are you talking about?
Are you saying there's another village in
the jungle?
Cricket said, glancing at sundew.
Who lives there?
More leaf wings?
Billadonna snorted.
They don't deserve to be called leaf
wings.
We are the leaf wings.
We're the ones who are still fighting for
our future.
We're not giving up on our tribe and
rolling over like pill bugs, leaf wings.
Pah.
She stabbed her claws into the ground
dragged out a flailing earthworm, and
sliced it into pieces.
Mother has a bit of a complex about the
other tribe.
Sundu explained.
We call them sap wings.
Biblis added, by order of the commander.
My order was to never speak of them.
Belladonna hissed.
They might as well not exist for all the
use they are to us.
She scrabbled up the dirt and reburied
the carved up earthworm bits.
But Luna might be there, Swartel asked.
We should go ask.
Sundu.
Can we go ask?
No one is going anywhere.
Belladonna commanded.
Sundew frowned at her.
And perhaps something in her look got
through.
Tonight, I mean, Belladonna added, a
little reluctantly.
It's too dark for anyone to wander around
in the jungle, especially brainless
outsiders who can't wait to get eaten.
I will consider sending them a message in
the morning if everyone behaves.
For some reason.
She looked at sundew.
Sundew gave her a matching glare.
Moon is a flame silk too, Sortell said
quickly.
She's way more likely to help you than
Blue is.
If the sab wings have her, you should
definitely try to get her back here.
Belladonna rubbed her chin.
Hmm, she said.
An interesting point, butterfly dragon.
I will include that in my
considerations.
She turned to go back into the meeting
house in a definitive this conversation
is over kind of way.
As soon as she was gone, Bumblebee tugged
on Sundu's ear again. she said
vehemently.
The food nets were full to overflowing
most likely in preparation for the feast
Sundew walked bumblebee over to them, and
let her pick out a mango.
Then a piece of dried capybara, then a
bowl of river snails, which bumblebee
took one bite of and promptly flung its
sundew's face.
And then another mango, and then she had
to wrestle the dragonette away from the
food and drag her back to the others.
Bumblebee growled.
She flopped onto Sundu's shoulder and set
her tiny teeth into a piece of capybara.
Which Sundew suspected was a 2nd strip
the dragonette had smuggled away
somehow.
Blue and Cricket and Sword Tail had
fallen silent as she came up to them.
They were all looking at her as if they
weren't quite sure whether she was sundew
the dragon who'd been helping them and
protecting them and saving their butts
for the last several days, or a
dragonette eating crocodile instead.
The nests are this way, Sundoo said
stomping past them.
She didn't have to explain herself.
She was a leaf wing.
Besides, they were her prisoners when she
met them.
They should be grateful that now at least
they were valuable prisoners.
And she'd helped with their problems too
hadn't she?
She'd helped save Blue's sister, even
though it made Belladonna grumpy.
It certainly wasn't Sundoo's fault that
Blue had immediately lost her again.
Sundew had also helped swordtail find the
chrysalis, and she'd helped with
cricket's starry eyed, let's save the
tribes with truth, and flyers plan.
She'd done all kinds of dangerous
nonsense for these outsiders.
How dare they be all aghast that she was
still a leaf wing, loyal to her tribe at
heart.
I don't need them to like me.
I don't need anyone to like me except one
dragon.
Here, she said, stopping at Pokweeds
Nest.
It was a ramshackle assortment of
branches woven into a sort of egg shape.
Sundew wasn't even sure if it would keep
out the rain.
Pokweed was a big dragon who didn't care
much about his own physical comfort.
He lived to destroy hive wings. was all.
But at least his nest was big enough to
fit 2 sleeping dragons comfortably.
Blue and sore towel can take this one
Sundoo said.
Cricket and bumblebee in that one.
She pointed to Bryony's nest, which was
close by and much tidier than poke
weeds.
The 2 of them were near the outer edges
of the village.
Along a path lined with nests that led to
the meeting house.
What about you?
Blue asked.
Aren't you going to stay with us?
Sunday squinted at him.
Hadn't he just been giving her an oh
you're a monster face?
Maybe I misread it.
That was cricket's expression.
But maybe blues was just sad face, and I
mistook it for hating me face.
I have my own nest, she said, flicking
her tail toward the woven sphere where
she slept.
She'd been so thrilled when she turned
too, and Belladonna and Hemlock had given
her permission to move out of theirs and
build her own.
It had taken her a while to notice that
no other dragonettes left their families
before the age of five.
But she didn't dwell on that.
After all, she saw plenty of her parents
all day long during training and
lessons.
She liked the peace and quiet of being
completely alone at night.
I do like it.
Besides, it's much easier to sneak out of
the village this way.
Oh, of course, Blue said.
How will we remember which ones are for
us?
Cricket asked, pacing around the cluster
of nets.
They all look the same.
Sundew grunched her eyebrows
quizzically.
They looked nothing the same.
The branches came from different plans or
were woven in different ways and She took
a deep breath, help one more time, and
then I can leave them to Belladonna if I
want to.
Sundoo reached into the ground with her
leaf speak.
She found a tendril and followed it back
calling roots to her, until a vine curled
through the soft, dark earth and climbed
up, weaving around the doorway of
Bryony's nest.
Purple morning glories burst from the
buds as it settled in place.
There, she said.
Think you can figure it out now?
Thank you, Blue said.
So cool, so tell breathed.
Sundo, cricket started.
I have to go report to Belladonna.
Sundew disentangled Bumblebee from her
neck and pastor into cricket's talons, the
dragonette protested sleepily, breathing
capybara breath into sundew's snout, but
it didn't take long before she was curled
up in cricket's arms with her eyes
closed.
It's just Aren't you our friend?
Cricket asked.
There's so much you didn't tell us, like
about the flame silk or the other village
or the secret plans to burn the hives, or
the dragon you're going to marry.
Maybe not everything is your business
Sundew Flair.
Maybe you don't need the answer to every
question in the world.
Maybe I was a little busy helping you
investigate Queen Wasp and burning down
greenhouses and keeping you alive.
It's not her fault, cricket.
Blue said, leaning against the hive wing
side.
His shimmering blue purple scales were
dimmer in the green light that filtered
through the dome, but his flame silk
glowed like fireflies under the scales on
his wrists.
She was trying to help by bringing us
here.
She's been working on her tribe's plan
her whole life.
She's only known us for a few days.
It makes sense that she didn't tell us
everything.
And you know she didn't want them to burn
bloodworm hive.
Do I know that?
Cricket asked.
Send do.
Can you protect Blue if he doesn't want
them to use his flame silk anymore?
Of course I can, Sandu shouted.
And they all jumped back.
By all the trees.
It's like you cannot keep straight in
your heads who are the good guys and who
are the bad guys here, when it is very
obvious.
R at you.
She whirled and flung herself with a path
toward the meeting house.
As she stormed off.
She heard Swordtails say, She's right.
I have no idea if her mom is the good guy
or the bad guy or what right now.
Sundew did not let herself think.
Neither do I. She did not.
Let herself worry about who was honest
with her, and whom she would rescue from
a burning hive, and whether being
manipulative was normal for a mom and a
leader.
And what was going to happen next to blue
and his friends.
She gave her report.
She showed Belladonna the length of vine
from Wasp's greenhouse.
Belladonna recognized it from the days
they'd spent hiding there, but neither
she nor any of the dragons she summoned
knew what it was either.
Sundew also explained what they'd learned
about wasps' mind control, just as she'd
promised cricket she would.
And as she'd predicted, Belladonna didn't
care.
The entire hive wing tribe was still
trapped in wasp's power.
It didn't matter how they got that way.
They still had to be defeated, every last
one of them, and the only decision left
to make, according to Belladonna, was
which hive to burn next.
After giving her report, Sundew stopped
by the weapons storehouse, where mandrake
as usual, was sorting and taking care of
the hazardous insect collection.
He was always happiest in here, tending
to the bullet ants and venomous
centipedes.
Sundew took off her empty pouches, and
reorganized her weaponry and supplies
between the rest of the leafy bags, then
resettled them around herself.
Do you want to restock?
Mandrake asked.
He gestured the wall of neatly labeled
boxes.
More sleep lilies, or smoke leaves?
Not tonight, sundew said.
Maybe tomorrow.
She was too tired to plan a new set of
weapons, and she didn't know what the
next threat would be anyway.
Sundew sat through the feast, but she
didn't feel like eating Panther, or
dancing with Mandrake, or smiling at any
of the dragons who came to congratulate
her on a successful mission.
As glowing night blooms at the village
she watched her fellow leaf wings sidle
up to blue and sore tail, testing out
questions, slowly letting them in.
She saw cricket try to join the
conversations, and she saw all the leaf
wings turn away from her with their wings
curled and teeth clenched.
She saw the looks they gave bumblebee as
the little hive wing dragonette ate
everything she could reach, and she saw
how bumblebee seemed to sense it and grow
smaller, staying close to the shelter of
Cricket's wings.
Don't make every problem your problem
Sandu.
Not right now.
Just get to midnight and deal with
everything else tomorrow.
And then finally, finally, the feast
ended.
The leaf wings started crawling into
their nests.
Two dragons took up their posts outside
the village entrance.
Blue paused in front of sundew as they
headed down the path to the nests.
Are you sure you don't want to stay with
us denied?
He asked.
She shook her head.
She wanted to be with someone who made
her feel more like herself, not dragons
who made her feel like an untrustworthy
snake.
Sortell waved from the doorway of
Pokweed's nest, and she nodded back.
She climbed into her own nest. and
watched through the branches as the
village went quiet.
Finally, finally, the time came.
Almost midnight.
Time to go.
Sundew slipped out of her nest, and
padded stealthily to the far side of the
barrier from the entrance.
The plants here knew her very well.
They'd been trained to grow in a way that
looked impenetrable to anyone else, but
as she approached, they sensed her and
leaned away from one another, bending and
twining, until there was a hole in the
barrier just big enough for a small leaf
wing.
She hopped through and let it close
behind her.
The jungle night was noisier than the day
between the insects and night prowling
predators, the declarations of the frogs
and the skittering clouds of bats
overhead.
She used her leaf speak to clear the way
warning off the dragon traps and
sundews.
She knew this route by heart.
Better even than she knew the names of
her fellow leaf wings.
Soon she was at the pond.
Dark water ribald in front of her
reflecting slivers of light from the 3
moons.
Sundew set the small jade frog on the
boulder in the center of the pond, climbed
the nearest safe tree, took a deep breath
and curled herself on a branch to wait
for Willow.
Chapter 6.
It was the frog's fault, really, that
Sundew had discovered the sap wings when
she was only 2 years old.
Not the jade frog.
This was an actual frog.
Small and brownish green, with orange
flecks across its knobbly back.
A frog that hopped into sundew's bowl of
tarot, snarfed up the sugar sprinkled
grasshoppers she'd been saving for
dessert, stuck out its tongue at her, and
then jaunted off into the jungle, as if
it aggravated dragons every day with no
consequences.
Well, that was not going to stand.
No, sir.
This time, there would most definitely be
consequences, frog.
She chased the frog to the thorn vine
fence.
Belladonna's original version of the
barrier, where it popped through a gap in
the leaves and vanished into the jungle.
Now, dragonettes under 4 years old were
not technically allowed outside the
safety perimeter of the village on their
own, but sundew was not like the other
leaf wing dragonettes, and really, she
was almost three, which was practically
four.
And plus also, what was she supposed to
do?
Just let the frog taunt her like that?
Besides, she knew the jungle better than
any of the other dragonettes.
She was a Venus dragon trap slayer.
She had battled cobra lilies and thundoos
and pitcher plans and beaten them all.
She had mighty superpowers.
No one could stop sundew, chosen one
daughter of the leaders of the leaf wings
especially not on a quest for vengeance.
This frog was going down.
Sundew glanced around to make sure no one
was watching.
Most of the adult dragons were in a
council meeting, so it seemed fairly safe
and then hurtled over the fence.
The jungle on the other side of the
thorns looked a lot like the jungle on
her own side, except maybe the plants
were bigger, and grew more thickly
entwined.
She spotted the miscreant frog right
away.
It was squatting in a patch of wet leaf
mulch, chewing in a very self satisfied
way, chewing her grasshopper.
Aha!
Sundew roared, pouncing on it.
Her claws squished into the
disintegrating leaves and mud, but
somehow missed the frog, which leaved
several feet into the air and bounded off
through the undergrowth.
No, Sundew shouted.
You will pay for this.
She shot after the frog. ducking under
snapping plant teeth, and weaving through
thickets of Strangler vines that tried to
tighten and ensnare her.
She was moving too fast for them, but not
fast enough to catch the frog, who could
bound to right over quicksand that she
had to go around.
At one point, she lost the frog and had
to freeze for a moment.
And then it made the mistake of leaping
away again, and she was after it at
once.
Sundew was surprised when they broke
through into a clearing, and she realized
the sky was turning purple.
She didn't think she'd been chasing the
frog for that long, but she hadn't been
paying attention to anything except the
flicker of its legs up ahead.
One of the moons was already climbing the
sky.
Belladonna and hemlock were going to be
furious.
Not as furious as I am, she thought, with
this frog, who caused all this trouble in
the 1st place, and must feel my wrath.
She slowed down as she slipped out of the
trees, realizing there was a pond in the
clearing, fed on the far side by a small
silvery stream, a boulder as smooth as
obsidian stuck up out of the water, near
the middle of the pond, and some of the
far trees leaned down toward it, like
parent dragons feeding their little
ones.
Not particularly like Sundu's parents
that is, but like a few other parents she
had seen among the tribe.
The frog had paused by the edge of the
pond. half buried in the mud.
Sundew could see its eyes rolling back
toward her and its throat pulsing
rapidly.
She crept forward on stealthy talons
placing each claw silently, crouching
close to the ground, and holding her
wings perfectly still.
Here I come, frog.
Prepare to die.
One step, another, closer, and pounce.
Her claws closed on mud and thin air.
The frog disappeared into the pond with a
smug plop.
Sundew roared, shaking the leaves on the
trees overhead, and making several dragon
traps snap shut on nothing.
You slippery, flea brained, smirking, bug
eyed son of a hive wing.
I am going to destroy you.
Even in her rage.
She knew better than to leap into an
unfamiliar body of water without checking
for water wheels and bladder warts
first.
She whipped around, wrenched a large
branch out of the nearest tree, and
started furiously stabbing the water with
it.
Droplets flew up and drenched her face
and wings, and the underbrush rippled
with tiny animals scurrying away from the
enormous splashes she was making.
She checked the sharp end of the branch.
No impaled frog, no tangles of deadly
underwater plants either, but that didn't
mean there weren't any.
If she went into the water, and got
drowned by a hungry water wheel, instead
of fulfilling her great stupid destiny.
Her parents would strongly disapprove.
But the frog, it couldn't get away with
this.
Come out and face me like a reptile
Sundew shouted.
I'm going to bite off your legs and feed
them to a tarantula.
I'm going to pour piranhas into this pond
and tell them all to eat you slowly.
By all the trees, said a voice above
her.
Who are you talking to?
Sundu jumped back, startled.
A pale green dragon sat on the boulder
blinking down at her.
She had definitely not been there a
moment earlier.
Also, she was a dragonette.
Out beyond the safety perimeter, just
like sundew.
Also, Sundew had never seen her before.
Which didn't seem possible in a group as
small as the leaf wings.
Also, she had the deepest brown eyes
sundew had ever seen.
My arch nemesis.
Sundu growled in response to her question
who is hiding in this pond, but not for
long because I am going to destroy him or
her, whatever it is.
The new dragon tilted her head to study
the water.
Wow.
What did this terrible, extremely doomed
fiend do to you?
It stole my grasshopper, which I was, you
know what?
It doesn't matter, Sundew said.
Noticing the amusement that was sneaking
onto the stranger's face.
What it did is not the point.
What I'm going to do to it is completely
justified, trust me, I just have to catch
it first.
Are we?
We're not talking about a dragon.
The stranger asked.
No, send do admit it.
The other dragon wrinkled her snout
thoughtfully.
A crocodile?
A monitor lizard?
Oh, a Gila monster.
Those things are cranky.
I nearly got in a fight with one last 2
moons night because I stepped on its tail
but I obviously didn't mean to.
Hey, maybe it's the same one.
It's not.
Sundew snapped.
She scowled the water.
It's a frog, she said at last, but a very
bad frog who deserves stamping on.
Oh no.
That's, oh, dear.
The stranger covered her face, as though
she was overcome with sympathy, but
Sundew could see her shoulders shaking.
Don't you laugh at me.
She yelped.
You would understand if you'd seen its
stupid smug face.
I can't stand smug faces.
I just want to smush them all flat.
You should have been here 5 heartbeats
sooner, then you could have seen it
smirkety smirking its way into the pond.
Sundew glanced around at the dimming
sunlight.
Where did you come from anyway?
The stranger waved one of her wings of
the trees behind her.
From the village, of course, silly.
But the village wasn't behind her.
It was quite a long way in the opposite
direction.
Um, what?
Sundu asked, which wasn't exactly the
incisive line of questioning she'd been
planning on.
Who are you?
The other dragon asked.
I feel like I should really know you
already.
Sundew drew herself up and made her
fiercest face.
It was one thing for sundew to not know
this stranger, but it was inconceivable
for this stranger to not know her.
Yes, you should.
I am sundoo.
Who are you?
The dragon tilted her head.
Her scales were dappled with darker green
leaf shapes, like the shadows of long
oval leaves.
Her eyes looked like they were smiling.
Her whole face was doing a weird, crinkly
sparkly thing that made sundew's face
want to do the same thing.
Crinkling and sparkling.
What kind of weird brain magic was this?
Sundew, really?
That's an unusual name.
She said.
No, it's not, Sundu snapped.
I mean, it is, technically, because I'm
the only one who has it, but everyone's
heard it, so it's very well known, which
means it can't be unusual by that
definition, I mean, is my point.
And besides, your name is the weird one.
It's just so weird.
The brain magic was doing something to
her words too.
She frowned as severely as she could.
Stop crinkling face.
I haven't told you my name yet, said the
other dragon, sparkling even more.
Well, I bet it's weirder than sundew.
Sundew fluffed out her wings.
I'm Willow, said the dappled green dragon
with a perfect face.
There, see?
I was right, sundew said.
Like, whoever knew anyone named Willow.
Not me.
Willow tilted her head, looking
confused.
What do you mean by well known?
I've never heard of you.
Should I have?
Sundew flicked her tail and accidentally
knocked a startled lizard into the pond.
I'm the daughter of Belladonna and
Hemlock, she said.
You know, the whole plan.
I'm the one who has to save Pantala.
Save Pantala from what?
Willow asked.
Sundew's jaw dropped.
From the hive wings?
she cried.
Don't you know anything?
Where have you been?
Who are you?
Oh.
Willow's front talon flew to her face.
She stared at Sundew, as though a
lightning bolt had dropped out of the sky
and asked for directions.
I know why your names are weird.
You're a poison wing.
A what?
Sundew barked, but Willow had already
flown off the boulder to land beside
her.
She circled sundew, studying her wings
and tail with wide eyes.
Up close.
She carried a scent of mint and chocolate
and new rain.
But how can you be?
You look just like us?
Willow said.
Maybe a little prettier.
She met Sundew's eyes, and ducked her
head, doing that full face smile crinkle
thing, and trying to hide it at the same
time, maybe a lot.
Which was a weird and wrong observation
because Willow was the one with the river
deep eyes, and the sparkle face, and that
wasn't the point, Sundew.
I'm not a poison anything, Sandu said.
I'm a leaf wing.
But you're one of the offshoots, aren't
you?
Willow asked.
She stopped circling and sat down
checking the ground below her for
anything thorny first.
The scary dragons with all the dangerous
plant names.
Sundew stared at her.
Offshoots?
She echoed.
I thought, we were the only ones, the
only leaf wings left.
Willow's sparkly look dimmed a little, as
though someone had thrown cobwebs over
her starlight.
Oh, no, she said, there's us.
The rest of us.
The, um, sorry, I'm not sure how else to
say this.
The real leaf wings, the ones who stayed
with Queen Sequoia and are still loyal to
her.
Queen Sequoia is still alive?
Sundu said, startled.
Wow, Willow said, her wide eyed look was
sort of unreasonably adorable.
I can't believe they keep us a secret
from you.
We learn all about the poison wings in
school.
What do you learn?
Sandu asked.
Curiosity warring with anger.
Did mother know about this?
If so, how dare she hide anything from
sundew?
What do they tell you about us?
Oh, you know, how some dragons wanted to
keep fighting the tree wars, so they
split off from the rest of the tribe when
we reached the poison jungle, and then
they started naming their dragonettes
after deadly plants, instead of giving
them tree names, like leaf wings always
have, and how they've been plotting
revenge on the hive wings all these
years.
Queen Sequoia met with their leader last
moon cycle.
She's always trying to convince her that
it's safer to stay here and lie low until
Queen Wasp dies.
Met with their leader.
There was only one dragon that could be.
Belladonna, Sundu's mother.
Sundu wondered which hunting expedition
or council meeting had been the lie
Belladonna had tossed her way to hide her
secret meeting with a leaf winged queen.
The queen who was still alive.
Even though Sundew and the other
dragonettes had been taught that she died
during the tree wars.
Willow was still talking.
I mean, can you imagine how dumb it would
be to go poke one of the hives?
As long as they think we're extinct.
We're safe.
But if we let them know we're still out
here, she shuddered.
Excuse me, Sundew said, bristling.
So your suggestion is we let them win.
We let them steal our continent and revel
in our extermination.
We just accept living here.
She waved her wings at the Venus dragon
traps overhead, which had been slowly
leaning down toward them, closer and
closer as the conversation went on.
Sundew dug a rock out of the mud and
threw it at the nearest plant.
It snapped shut and drew back, and the
others around it bristled.
It's not that bad here, Willow said.
Right?
I mean, I think it's better with, um
interesting company.
She gave Sundew that crinkle, sparkle
smile face, that made all the words in
Sundew's head run around bumping into one
another, like disoriented moths.
Do not smile back at her son do.
She is fundamentally wrong about your
entire life purpose.
What is your face doing, Sundew?
We deserve to be out there, Sundu said
trying to focus on everything she'd been
taught.
Belladonna had trained her to summon her
anger at a moment's notice.
That was a safe place to go when sundew's
other emotions got too complicated.
Wasp could live for another 100 years, or
she could be replaced by someone equally
bad.
We can't just sit around and wait for
history to sort itself out.
We have to fight.
We have to make things better with our
own claws.
Willow blinked at the fist Sundew was
making, and then she reached out and took
it between her own front talons.
She smoothed out the tension and laid one
palm over sundews.
Her scales warm and light as a fern
frond.
Sundew could feel Willow's heartbeat
going only about half as fast as
sundews.
Willow said softly.
You don't have to do anything right this
second.
Just be here.
Breathe.
No one had ever told Sun do to breathe
before.
Her 1st instinct was to scoff, that she
already was breathing, and she did it
rather often and was quite good at it
thanks very much.
But there was something in Willow's face
in her eyes as she gazed down at sundew's
talons, that made her impossible to scoff
at.
They stood like that for a moment.
One of Willow's graceful wings was a
breath away from brushing sundews, like a
butterfly hovering just over a leaf.
Sundoo wondered if the butterfly was as
aware of it, as the leaf was.
She wasn't sure if her heartbeat was
slowing down, or Willows was speeding
up.
But at some point, she realized they had
synced.
Don't you think?
Bump is a terrible word.
Willow said thoughtfully.
I mean, that's what most dragons would
say our hearts are doing, but it doesn't
feel thumpy to me.
Pulse doesn't seem right either.
Beat sounds too violent.
It's not quite tapping.
There should be a better word for this.
For 2 heartbeat finding each other, Sundew
said, as quietly as she could, trying not
to break the spell.
Willow gave her a shy, sideways smile.
I hope so.
Sundew didn't know what to say.
Belladonna would have told her to push
the other leaf wing into the pond, and
yell at her about the tree wars, and how
important it was to go kill wasp.
She would have pointed out that sundew
had a duty to marry mandrake and raise
superpowered danger babies to destroy
their enemies.
Belladonna would have said, there was
nothing more important than their
vengeance, and that Willow was not worth
talking to.
But Belladonna was a liar.
And Willow was the only dragon who'd ever
given sundew this all over inside
sparkles feeling.
She let her wing brush willows lightly.
Guess what?
I've made a decision.
You have?
Yes.
Sendu cleared her throat and made a
portentous face.
I have decided to spare that odious
frog's life in your honor.
Oh, Willow laughed.
That's too bad.
I had just decided to camp out by this
pond until it emerges so I could murder
it for you.
What?
Sundew couldn't stop herself from
laughing too.
No one has ever offered to murder a frog
for me before.
Well, no one has ever offered to not
murder a frog for me before.
Willow said.
It's very magnanimous of you.
That's me, said Sundew, ever so magna
ganimus.
Can you come live with us?
Willow burst out.
Come be a leaf wing, and meet Queen
Sequoia, and forget about fighting, and
see me every day?
That was the 1st time she had asked, but
it wasn't the last.
Nearly every time they met.
Willow offered again to bring Sundew into
the other village, to give her a home, and
teach her how to be a peace loving sap
wing, a name Willow never used and quite
disliked.
But every time, sundew had had to say
no.
No, I have a purpose.
No, my tribe needs me.
Your tribe needs me to do this too, even
if none of you realize it.
No, I have to save the world first.
I'm sorry.
She'd said that 1st time.
I can't.
Willow had looked away.
Wings sliding slowly down, but Sundew had
caught her talons before she could pull
away entirely.
But can I see you again?
She'd asked.
Tomorrow night?
And the night after that?
Maybe also the one after that.
And the one after that, and the one after
that, I can sneak out.
It's easy.
Willow had laughed again, and the next
night she'd given sundew the jade frog.
Our signal, she'd said, so I know if
you're there.
Leave it on the rock.
And I'll come find you.
In the ensuing 4 years, Sundew had
convinced her mother that even the
youngest dragonettes needed to know about
the sapwings, instead of only learning
about them when they turned four.
But Belladonna never took her to her
meetings with Queen Sequoia, nor did she
ever tell the council what they talked
about.
She'd forbidden sundew to go to their
village, or try talking to any of them.
She seemed to find Sundew's interest in
them suspicious, and she hated hearing
about them in any case.
So Sunduke kept Willow a secret.
Her secret.
This was the longest they'd gone without
seeing each other.
She'd told Willow it might be a while, but
she'd been gone even longer than she
expected, and she hadn't told Willow why
or where she was going.
A light rain started to fall.
Misting through the leaves above sundew.
She wasn't sure how much time had
passed.
Only one of the moons was visible through
the canopy now.
Will she still come?
What if she's given up watching for the
frog?
But at last the shadows around the pond
rippled, and one glided up to the boulder
and then down to the moonlight in front
of her, becoming the silhouette of the
only dragon Sundu ever looked forward to
seeing.
Sundew leaped out of the tree and bounded
over the grass into Willow's wings.
Chapter 7.
You were gone forever.
Willow said, clasping sundew's front
talons and hers.
I have so much to tell you.
I've been waiting and waiting, and
checking the boulder every night, and it
was dreadful, and I didn't like it, and
let's never do that again.
I was half afraid Belladonna must have
found out about us.
I started to wonder whether I needed to
mount a daring rescue operation.
Blast through the barrier.
Knock the other poison wings aside, tear
down your prison and sweep you away to
safety.
Wouldn't that have been so heroic?
Sundew twined her tail around Willows.
The most heroic, romantic thing ever, but
totally unnecessary.
You know, Belladonna couldn't keep me
locked up, even if she wanted to.
She reached her leaf speak into the earth
sending her power along their roots until
she found what she wanted, and summoned a
spray of violets from the ground.
They sprang up, small and beautiful and
purple, right beside Willow's claws.
Show off.
Willow said affectionately.
This particular clearing was probably the
most colorful spot in the jungle, thanks
to the clusters of flowers scattered all
over it, which sundew had grown for
willow in the last 3 years.
So what have you really been so busy
with?
I had this awful nightmare that you left
the poison jungle and ran into WASP.
It felt so real.
I almost told Queen Sequoia about it.
But she's always reassuring us that
Belladonna wouldn't endanger the rest of
us by, that she'd at least to tell
Sundu.
She said.
Her voice faltering at the expression on
sundew's face.
What is it?
She let go of Sunday's talons and covered
her mouth.
Oh no.
I did leave the jungle, Sandu said.
Don't freak out.
But you weren't seen, Willow said.
Nobody saw you because you were careful
right?
We were careful.
Sundu said slowly.
I mean, we were careful.
Who's we?
Willow asked.
What does that mean?
Belladonna, Hemlock, and I made it to
Wasp Hive without any trouble, Sandu
said.
But we couldn't get inside at first.
And then we ran into these other
dragons.
Oh no.
Oh no, Willow whispered.
But it was all right, Sundew said
quickly.
Two of them were silk wings, and the
other is a hive wing who can't be mind
controlled, and she's on our side.
Now, I mean, we kind of dragged her onto
our side, but I think she was heading
that way anyhow.
Technically, she's really on this one
particular Silkwings side, but he might
be with us, unless Belladonna has ruined
it.
But the point is, they were fine and
wanted to help.
Well, agreed to help.
And couldn't say no, but basically
agreeable-ish sort of way.
I'm going to have a heart attack, Willow
said.
So you met some allies and came straight
home safely, without being seen.
Well?
No, Sandu admitted.
We...
Kind of stole the book of Clear Sight.
What?
Willow shrieked, sending an explosion of
sleeping birds catapulting into the night
sky.
Sandu said. reaching to cover Willow's
snout.
We had to have it.
We needed to take away Wasp's secret
knowledge of the future, or at least we
needed to know what it says too, right?
Isn't that one of Sequoia's eternal
arguments that we can't do anything
against WASP because she has this all
knowing book to warn her of our every
move?
Yes, but that's insane, Willow said.
That book must have been the most heavily
guarded object in the most heavily
guarded hive in Pentala.
It was, Sundew said, but not anymore.
Ha ha.
Now it is mine.
No way, Willow said.
You really did it?
Did you read it?
Are you now the most all knowing dragon
in all the land?
The future is spread out before you?
All the secrets of what's to come?
So, said Sundew.
No.
Turns out, the whole book Mystique was an
enormous lie.
Clearsight did leave a few prophecies, but
they petered out over a 1000 years ago.
Nothing WASP told us was true.
Willow stared at her in the moonlight.
Wow.
She said softly.
Didn't you once guess that?
A couple years ago?
You said, what if none of it is real?
What if there never was a clear sight?
And everything we've been told about the
book was made up by a sinister hive wing
somewhere along the way?
Did I say that?
Sundew flicked her wings, pleased with
herself?
Well, I was half right.
It looks like clear sight was real, but
so were the lies, and the sinister hive
wings all over the last 1000 years.
Willow took a deep breath.
Okay, she said.
So that's amazing.
You snuck into the hive, into the temple
stole the book, got back out again, and
came straight home without being seen
right?
Um, said Zundoo.
No.
No?
Sundoo.
Not exactly.
I mean, we did sneak into the hive
without being seen, and the temple.
The actual stealing and running away went
Less well.
By all the trees, Willow said, you were
seen, sundew.
Tell me you weren't seen.
Her wings were shaking.
Sundu grabbed her front talons again.
It's all right.
I'm here, aren't I?
I made it back safely.
I even brought our new allies with us.
One of them can shoot fire.
A fire blasting dragon and the book of
Clearsight.
That's a pretty successful mission, don't
you think?
But Hive Wings saw you.
So they know we're not extinct.
Oh, maybe no one will believe them, Willow
said.
It'll be like seeing ghosts or scavengers
a dramatic story to tell at parties, but
no one takes it seriously, right?
Maybe the others will think they were
hallucinating.
Having wild visions, imagination run amok
and everyone will laugh at them and say
ha ha.
Leaf Wings.
They're all dead, you goof.
We scoff at your hilarious story, and
definitely are not even remotely
considering going out with an army to
hunt down and kill the rest of the tribe
because there aren't any left.
Leaf wings.
How amusing.
This could happen.
That's probably how it will be.
I mean, how many hive wings saw you after
all.
One, two?
Sundews grunched up her face.
Three?
Willow said nervously.
More like, All of them?
Sundu admitted.
All of them?
You have got to stop shouting, Sundu
said.
Your village isn't that far away, and I'm
not up to dealing with any dragons who
aren't you tonight.
You can't possibly mean all of them
Willow said.
Well, Sundoo said, in the sense that
Queen Wasp possessed the entire
population of Wasp Pive, summoned them to
the temple, had them all attack us, and
then watched me escape, I think
technically, yes, all of them is pretty
accurate.
Oh wait.
Actually, only all of the ones in Wasp
Hive, not the other hives.
So that's only one out of 9 hives, like
so really, only one ninth of the hive
wing population.
See?
You were right.
Not all of them after all.
All the dragons in Wasp Hive.
Willow said faintly.
With the queen in their heads. attacked
you and saw you, and watched you escape
with the book of Clear sight.
Yes, Sundew said.
Now you've got it?
It was a very impressive escape if I do
say so myself.
So, Willow said, basically, we are all
going to die.
No, Sandu cried.
She reached up and brushed her claws
gently along Willow's face.
No, we're not Willow.
We're going to win this time.
How can you possibly think that?
Even if we could win eventually?
War means dead leaf wings, especially war
against Queen Wasp, and we can't win
because nothing is different from last
time except there are fewer leaf wings to
start with.
That's not true, Sundoo said.
Things are completely different.
She started counting off on her talons.
We have a flame silk.
We have the book of Clearsight, and know
the truth about it.
Our half of the tribe has been preparing
for war for 50 years, and have lots of
new weapons.
The silk wings are restless and depressed
and unhappy.
I mean, not all of them, I think, but
enough to have formed an underground anti
hive wing movement, so they won't just
blindly go along with a wasp this time.
Also, the hive wings will be too scared
to come fight us in the poison jungle.
And we know the secret of Queen Wasp's
mind control.
She let go of Willow and tugged the vine
out of its pouch.
It's a plant.
This plant.
She must eat it or something, and she
injects it into hive wing eggs to put the
dragons inside under her power.
She held it out, and Willow sniffed the
leaves, then ran one claw lightly along
the prickled stem.
I don't know it, she said.
If it grew here, surely you'd be able to
sense it, wouldn't you?
I tried.
Sundew had been trying.
From the moment they stepped into the
jungle.
She'd been sending her leaf speak out
into the jungle, tracing along route
pathways and tangles of underground
Mycelia as far as she could go.
A couple of the oldest trees did that, hmm
thing they do when something seems
familiar.
And once I thought I heard a relative of
this plant echo back from somewhere far
away.
But I lost it.
And none of the trees could tell me where
it might be.
There are dragons we could ask in my
village, Willow said.
She hesitated, then touched her forehead
to sundews for the length of 5
heartbeats.
I think you need to come to my village
Sundew.
I think it's time.
Time to meet the Sapwings.
To see how the other tribe lives.
What it's like to be a village of
cowardly dragons instead of warriors for
justice.
Time to finally see Willow's home.
I can't.
Sundu let go and stepped back.
I'd be betraying my tribe.
Belladonna would be furious.
And wouldn't you get in trouble?
Not as much as you will, Willow said.
I mean, a lot of dragons will be mad, but
we have to tell Queen Sequoia about all
this.
Don't you see?
She needs to know about the book, and the
flame silk.
Sundew started to interrupt, then stopped
herself, but Willow knew her too well to
miss that.
What?
Is there something else?
she asked.
Maybe, one more thing, Sandu said.
She'll probably want to know about the
hive we burned down.
Willow opened her mouth, then closed it
again, then opened it again, like a
really adorable but totally flabbergasted
dragon trap in the rain.
Sorry, I didn't get to that part.
Sundew said.
Hemlock took a few other dragons to burn
down one of the hives.
I only saw it from a distance, but there
was a lot of smoke.
So, I think it must have worked.
She decided not to mention burning wasps
greenhouses as well.
She'd let that come up later.
At a more natural and hopefully less
tense point in the conversation.
Then we don't have any time, Willow said
taking a step back toward her village.
I thought we'd have a moment to plan, but
that's an act of war, Sandu.
WASP is probably on her way here right
now, with the whole brain washed hive
wing army behind her.
Doubtful, Sandu scoffed, and I still
can't.
I agree with Willow. interjected a new
voice.
An enormous, long necked leaf wing
emerged from the trees behind Willow
ducking her head to avoid the lower
branches, and dangling dragon traps.
Her tail was scarred with claw marks, and
dragged in the pond as she came toward
them.
Sundew saw, with horrified fascination
that she was missing an ear and half of
one of her horns.
This was a dragon who had been in battle
and fought hard.
This was also a dragon who had been alive
for a very long time.
A dragon who could still remember the
ancient forests before the tree wars.
And from the way she walked, and the way
she tilted her head to look down at them
and the way she held her wings like
majestic jewels, this was a royal
dragon.
The Royal Dragon.
Hello, Belladonna's daughter, said Queen
Sequoia.
Willow is correct that I need to know
everything.
I think, it is high time you joined the
real Leaf Wings.
Chapter 8.
Your majesty, willow gasped.
Sundew found herself bowing her head
instinctively, and she quickly jerked it
back up again.
She was a true leaf wing, or a poison
wing, as the Sapwings called them, and
more important, she was sundew, and she
bowed to nobody.
Queen Sequoia smiled faintly.
You have exactly your grandmother's
stubborn expression.
I saw it many times during the tree
wars.
My grandmother?
Sundew echoed, surprised.
She'd heard of her, of course, all the
time, but she'd died before sundew
hatched.
She was my best general.
Sequoia side.
And my most loyal, until I finally gave
her an order she couldn't follow.
Give up and run away.
That's when she left me and started your
group instead.
She turned, offhandedly sweeping a noisy
toad into the pond with one talon, where
it sank with a startled glorp.
Come, we will be safer in the village.
I shouldn't.
I should turn and run home.
Belladonna will lose her mind if she
discovers I've run to the sapwings to
tell tales on her.
She wasn't sure whether it was the idea
of Belladonna's apoplectic face, or the
air of authority around Queen Sequoia, but
she found herself following the queen
with Willow by her side.
Did you tell her about me?
Sundu hissed at Willow.
Did you bring her here?
Sundew, Willow said patiently, in the
tone of a teacher reminding her students
that 3+3 always equals 6.
I wouldn't do that, and you know it.
She did sort of know it.
But there was a part of her that was
still mad that she'd been caught like
this, and she wanted someone to blame.
Sundu scowled.
I can blame Queen Sequoia.
What was she doing spying on us?
How dare she?
I will definitely tell her how I feel
about that in as mad a voice as I like.
I don't have to treat her like a queen.
I can yell at her if I want to.
Maybe not.
Right this 2nd, maybe later.
When I feel like it.
Don't be scared.
Willow whispered.
I'm not scared.
Sundew snapped. loud enough for the queen
to glance over her shoulder at them.
She lowered her voice.
When am I ever scared?
What do I have to be scared of?
She's just a big dragon.
She doesn't even have an army.
I'm not scared.
Willow stopped and took one of Sundew's
talons.
In the dark, Sundew felt the smooth
familiar weight of the jade frog come to
rest in her palm.
She tucked it back into her pouch, brushed
her wing along willows, and felt her
heart rate start to calm down.
I'm sorry she followed me.
But I'm not sorry you're coming to the
village, Willow said, starting to walk
again.
There's something I can't wait to show
you.
You did say you had something to tell me
Sundu remembered it sheepishly.
What is it?
I mean, I think it's exciting, Willow
said.
Maybe not as much to you, after all you
are almost dying and war starting.
But guess what?
There are strangers in our village, 3 of
them, and you'll never believe where 2 of
them come from.
It's amazing.
Wait until you see them.
Is one of them a silkwing?
Sundu asked.
One of the silk wings I brought to the
rainforest is looking for a sister.
She stopped herself just in time from
adding, and our spies thought you might
have her.
She was quite sure that Queen Sequoia was
listening to them, even though she was
several steps ahead.
Actually, yes, the 3rd one is a silk wing
Willow said.
Aw, I hope we can reunite them.
Sundu flicked her wings, surprised and
pleased.
What were the chances that Luna would
have blown ashore here, and survived and
been rescued by the sapwings, before
sundew's tribe mates or the dragon traps
or the cobra lilies or the snakes got
her?
That would solve a few problems.
If we could give Luna to Belladonna
instead of blue, a willing flame silk
ally would be a much better bargain than
hostages who have to be coerced into
helping us.
Then blue and cricket could do whatever
they want to do next.
And if they don't want to be my friends
anymore, that's just fine.
But first, Sequoia would have to agree to
give up Luna.
What if she has her own plans for using
flame silk?
And the other two?
she asked.
You'll see.
Willow flashed her an unmistakable grin
sparkling even in the darkness under the
trees.
Sundew felt a funny shiver in her chest
as though her heart had shaken raindrops
off its wings.
Even after everything I just told her
even though she thinks I've endangered
her tribe, and restarted a war she
doesn't want.
She still loves me.
In Zendu's life, love mostly came in the
form of yelling and criticism and
judgment.
Her parents loved her and showed it by
telling her everything she did wrong
correcting her mistakes, and starting
shouting matches whenever they were the
slightest bit aggravated.
It still confused her sometimes when
Willow did none of that.
It was confusing her right now.
Wasn't Willow angry at her?
She'd never seen Willow get angry.
It was kind of unsettling, honestly.
Sundew had thought about it for years, and
eventually came to the conclusion that
Willow must just hide her anger really
well.
But did that mean it would erupt one day
all of a sudden, and burn down their
relationship.
These were the things Sundew worried
about at night.
She'd expected to find a wall or barrier
or fence, like the one she'd built around
her own village, but instead, the sapwing
village crept up around them, like
termites.
The 1st sign was that all the dragon
traps disappeared.
Sundew had never walked through a stretch
of jungle with no dragon traps in it.
Nor, she realized, were there any sundews
or pitcher plants, or anything else that
ate dragons.
Sundew was looking so carefully for
carnivorous plants that she missed the
1st few leaf houses, but then they were
overhead, and it was dark.
Suddenly she noticed a cluster of
phosphorescent moss in a tree up ahead
and as they approached, she realized it
lit up the interior of a kind of leaf
globe tree house perched in the higher
branches.
Whoa, she said, stopping without
realizing it.
Willow nudged her forward again, and then
Sundew spotted more and more of them.
The trees were full of the leaf houses
not so different from the nests in her
village, except that they were in the sky
covered in leaves, and much bigger than
her own.
She guessed each would fit at least 6
dragons comfortably.
At least of the ones she saw.
Now she heard voices too.
Here and there the murmur of dragons
talking, and not far away, someone
singing a lullaby.
She heard a dragonette chirping, and his
parents sending him back to bed.
She heard the soft rustle of dragons
leaping from tree to tree, possibly
tracking the queen's movements.
And mine, she guessed, her claws curling
into the dirt.
Willow and Sequoia spread their wings at
the same time, and Sundew followed suit.
They leaped into the air and led her to
the largest tree house of all, a
structure that spiraled all the way
around an enormous baobab, with several
levels, balconies, and rooms built out
along the massive branches.
Sundew couldn't see all of it in the dark
but from the night blooms that were lit
up in a few rooms, she was able to see
dark, purple, and white clematis vines
twining all around the columns and bright
red trumpet creepers dangling from the
ceilings.
They landed in a room on the top level
with a smooth, polished wood floor that
must have taken a lot of work to make so
slippery and shiny.
A young leaf wing was waiting for them
curled on a mahogany throne, sewing
sheets of speckled paper together to make
a book.
She looked a little older than Sundo, with
large brown eyes and deft, dark green
claws.
Hazel, Queen Sequoia said reprovingly, as
the dragon looked up.
What have I told you about bookmaking at
night?
It's an efficient use of my time.
Hazel guessed, with a mischievous grin.
You will ruin your eyes.
The queen tugged the pages out of her
talons as Hazel protested, and then we'll
either have to steal glasses from the
hive wings or have a blind queen, and I
don't like either of those plans.
Sundew gave Willow a startled look.
That's the queen's great granddaughter.
Willow whispered, Princess Hazel, next in
line for the throne.
Oh, right.
Willow had mentioned Hazel a few times
mostly in the context of why Queen
Sequoia refused to restart the train wars
something about not wanting to lose any
more dragons.
I think glasses are cute, Hazel said
breezily, and we won't have to steal them
if the scouts are right about the poison
wings capturing a real flame silk today.
Hazel, the queen said in a warning tone.
This is sundoo.
Belladonna's daughter.
Hazel's jaw dropped.
She stared at Sundew for a long, awestruck
moment.
That's how you were supposed to react
when you met me, Sundu whispered to
Willow.
These sundew?
Willow gasped, widening her eyes
theatrically.
The one and only sundew, the one who
almost slew the great and terrible
grasshopper stealing frog menace of the
jungle?
Sundew bopped her on the nose with her
tail, and Willow dissolved in giggles.
Am I allowed to say hi?
Hazel asked her great grandmother.
Yes, of course, Queen Sequoia said, a
little impatiently, especially if it gets
you off my throne.
Go on.
Chairs are for old dragon bones.
Not bendy little saplings like you.
Hazel bounded off the throne and skidded
across the floor to Sunday's feet.
Hello, I'm Hazel.
Sorry, you know that.
I hear about you all the time.
Belladonna thinks you should be queen
instead of me.
Do you think so too?
She's so scary.
Sorry, I know she's your mom.
Ah, I'm saying all the wrong things.
She drew herself up and did a rather
impressive imitation of Queen Sequoia's
regal expression.
Even her voice went hilariously fancy.
Welcome to the Leaf Wing Village.
We are delighted you could join us.
T?
Oh, you don't have to be queen face hazel
for Sundu, Willow said.
Yes, she does.
Queen Sequoia called, just as Hazel was
starting to relax her wings.
She snapped them back into elegant arches
immediately.
It's good practice, and none of us know
Belladonna's daughter as well as you
apparently do, Willow.
Oh, I, we met um, Willow stammered.
By accident, Sundew said, it was my
fault.
Not that we have anything to apologize
for.
Whoever said we couldn't know each
other.
I mean, that would be a stupid rule.
I believe that is Belladonna's rule.
Sequoia said, rubbing her forehead, isn't
it?
No fraternizing between poison wings and
leaf wings.
We are not poison wings.
Sundew snapped.
And even if it is her rule, it's still
stupid, and she didn't even make it until
after I met Willow, and she can't tell me
what to do or who to like anyway.
It's none of her business.
It's a little bit of her business, Sequoia
pointed out, as both your mother and your
commander.
But I'm not actually remotely interested
in you and Willow or how you met, or why
she's been sneaking out and staring
wistfully at an empty pond for the last
several nights.
She pointed one long claw at sundew.
I heard you say something about a book.
A flame silk, and a burned hive, the full
story.
Now.
Sundew didn't have to tell her
technically, this wasn't her queen, if
the tribe had officially split in two, but
then again, if she had to choose between
obeying this queen or following her
mother's orders, she kind of liked the
idea of choosing this one, and she did
need help identifying the vine.
If she was still following Cricket's daft
plan of trying to unbrainwash the hive
wings.
Plus, it would make Belladonna so mad, and
she fully deserved it.
So Sundu told the queen everything.
The whole story about leaving the jungle
hiding in the greenhouse, meeting blue
and cricket, stealing the book, rescuing
blue, sneaking into jewel hive, finding
the chrysalis, spreading the truth about
the mind control and the book, cricket
kidnapping and egg for some reason
escaping, figuring out that the mind
control was connected to a plant, watching
bloodworm hive burn from a distance, and
then taking advantage of the tribe's
distraction to burn down wasp's
greenhouse of mind control plants.
And then we came home, she finished, and
nobody followed us and everything is
fine.
Mission accomplished.
All good.
Vengeance on track.
The queen leaned back into her throne
with a weary expression.
Sundew wondered how old she was, as old
as she looked.
The tree wars were only 50 years ago, and
she'd been a young queen when Wasp tried
to steal her power and usurp her tribe, if
Sundew remembered her history correctly.
I can't believe Belladonna did it.
Queen Sequoia said in a thin voice, after
all our conversations, after everything
I've said to her, her mother was so loyal
but that viper, she snapped her jaw shut
suddenly and took a deep breath through
her nostrils.
Great grandmother?
Hazel said.
Do not talk to me.
I am calming down, Sequoia barked.
The 3 younger leaf wings looked at one
another, then back to the queen.
Sequoia was staring so hard at a knot on
the end of her throne, that Sundu thought
it might burst into flames.
She kept breathing in and out, extremely
loudly. through her nose.
Are you?
Hazel started.
No, I am not.
Sequoia growled.
Shush.
Hazel sighed.
This could take a minute, she whispered
to Sundu.
Does this happen a lot?
Sundu whispered back.
Only when she's really mad.
Usually she can squash it pretty well
without this whole theatrical interlude.
I can still hear you.
Sequoia thumbed to the side of her throne
with her tail.
I am trying to count until I feel calmer
and less like murdering everyone.
Sendu tilted her head at the queen.
Count?
she echoed, glancing at Willow.
That's why all her meetings with
Belladonna takes so long.
Hazel joked.
Because she has to take deep breaths and
count to calm herself down after
everything her mom says, or else she
might end up strangling her.
She should try, Sundoo said.
Why doesn't she just yell at her?
Or us?
Willow gave her an alarmed look.
I don't want her to yell at us.
But then maybe she'll feel better, Sundew
pointed out.
Well, I wouldn't, Willow said.
I'd feel awful, and I bet she would too.
Does yelling make you feel better?
It's only ever made me feel worse.
Oh my goodness, Sandu said, I must hear
every story about you yelling at someone
right this minute.
Willow grunged your nose at her.
I was very little.
It was only once, and I still feel guilty
about it.
Well, I'm sure they deserved it, Sundoo
said loyally.
Great grandmother tries very hard not to
yell at her subjects.
Hazel said, in her queen face voice.
She was a more impulsive, angry dragon
back during the tree wars, and she has
come to believe it got several of her
subjects killed.
She has made an effort to become a wiser
calmer ruler, thanks in large part to the
implementation of this counting to 10
strategy.
She must be past 10 by now, Sundu said.
I could have counted to 900 in this
time.
Not with a trio of aggravating twigs
chattering like magpies in the
background.
Queen Sequoia interjected sternly.
She took another deep breath.
I am calm.
Everything is fine.
I just want to say, Sandu blurted, that I
for one, am very glad you were an angry
dragon when the tree war started, because
it meant you fought back against wasps
power grab, and didn't just roll over for
her like monarch did.
I'm glad you fought for our tribe and
protected us from her.
I would hate for the leaf wings to be
stuck where the spineless silk wings are
right now.
So thank you for being a mad dragon, and
I say keep it up, and let's go fight some
more.
The queen gazed down at her for a long
moment, and then a flicker of a smile
crossed her face.
I think Belladonna made a mistake leaving
you out of our meetings for all this
time.
She said.
You're considerably more persuasive than
she is.
Sendu fluffed up the frill along her
spine and beamed.
Take that, Belladonna.
I knew I should have been invited, just
like I've been saying.
But no, said Queen Sequoia.
Sundew deflated as she went on.
My leaf wings are not getting involved in
another war.
Do we have a choice?
Willow asked.
Won't wasp come after all of us now, after
what happened to bloodworm hive?
I suspect she'll be even angrier about
her greenhouse than the hive, Sequoia
said thoughtfully, especially if that was
her only supply of this mystery plant, and
she needs it to control her tribe.
Let me see that vine.
Sundu pulled out the cutting, which was
looking a little the worse for wear after
going in and out of her pouch several
times.
She stepped forward and draped it over
Sequoia's outstretched talons.
Something happened to the Queen's face.
It was fast and hard to catch in the dim
phosphorescent light, but Sundew thought
she saw recognition and horror flashed
through the queen's eyes.
Her claws closed around the vine
compulsively, crushing it slightly, and
then she released it again and took
another deep breath.
You know it, Sundu said.
You've seen this vine before.
I'm...
Not sure, Sequoia said.
She rose abruptly to her feet.
I need to consult my books.
Go away and come back after dawn.
All 3 of you, she added with a stern look
at Hazel.
Sundew kind of wanted to ask for the vine
back, but she had a pretty strong feeling
the queen would say no, and then what was
she do?
Try to wrestle it out of the massive
dragon's talons?
I'll get the truth out of her when we
come back, though.
She thought, as they all took a step back
toward the edge of the balcony.
She definitely knows that plant.
Can I take Sundu to meet the new
dragons?
Willow asked.
Yes, yes, the Queen answered, waving them
off.
They're asleep, you nut?
Hazel pointed out with a granite willow
that made son do absolutely wild with
jealousy.
Then we'll just peek at them, Willow
said.
Come on, Sundoo.
The new dragons, it turned out.
We're only a few levels down the same
tree, in 2 side by side interior rooms
that Sundew noticed were not prison
cells.
Exactly.
But we're not exactly wide open to the
rest of the village either.
She also couldn't help but notice the
vines of thorns and toxic sap that wound
around the doorways, or the 4 leaf wings
stationed nearby. casually playing pick
up twigs in the hall in the middle of the
night.
They gave Willow and Sundew suspicious
looks, but went back to their game with a
shrug when they saw Hazel with them.
The silk wing is in there, Willow
whispered, pointing to the 1st doorway.
Sundew peered inside, her heart
thumping.
This whole time, she'd felt confident
that Luna was all right.
Her sense of Luna, from the short time
they'd been together, was that Luna could
absolutely take care of herself.
But Blue and Swordtail had worried so
much and so incessantly, that it must
have rubbed off on her a little, because
now she felt a tremor of weird excitement
as she peered into the dark room.
Luna, at last, safe and sound, so
everyone could shut up about her and
focus on the mission, except it wasn't
Luna.
She couldn't see the sleeping silk wing
very clearly, but she could see that the
wings were a dark color, maybe blue or
purple, not the pale pearly green that
Luna's were, and there was no flame silk
glow from this silk wings wrists.
What's wrong?
Willow said softly.
Not the dragon we're looking for.
Sundew shook her head with a sigh.
Blue was going to be disappointed.
Sortell was going to be worse.
He was going to be super annoying about
it.
But Luna had to be all right.
She must have just landed.
Somewhere else.
Where did you find her?
Trapped in Origula, not far from the
border, Willow said.
She's lucky we got there before it ate
her.
I wonder what a silk wing was doing
inside the poison jungle.
Sundew said thoughtfully.
Escaping from hive wings, I think.
Willow said.
Now, come see the others.
She tugged on Sunday's elbow and led her
to the 2nd doorway.
Sundew found herself holding her breath
as she looked inside.
For a moment, she didn't know what she
was saying.
There were 2 dragons, asleep back to back
with the bigger one's wing tented over
the smaller one.
The smaller ones seemed to be greenish
like a leaf wing, but the wing she could
see was an odd shape, not leaf like at
all, and the other dragon was, not
green.
Maybe blue?
Like a silk wing.
But with only 2 wings?
Strangest of all, they were both kind of
glowing.
She squinted at them.
Yep.
Little patterns in their scales had a
faint glow to them, all along their wings
and across their snouts and down their
tails, as though they had rolled in
phosphorescent moss, except it seemed to
be really part of them.
What are they?
She breathed, awestruck.
They call themselves sea wings, Willow
whispered.
And they come from the distant kingdoms.
Chapter 9.
Willow and Sundew spent the rest of the
night in a pile of leaves in Hazel's
room.
Willow offered to take Sundew back to her
own home, but she was clearly nervous
about waking her dad, and explaining
sundew to him in the middle of the
night.
So they decided it would be easier to
sleep in the queen's tree house and deal
with grown ups in the morning instead.
With daylight to help, and after the
queen spoke to them.
Sundu fell asleep almost as soon as she
lay down next to Willow, the long days of
flying and stress catching up to her all
at once.
She had a moment to breathe.
A moment of feeling Willow's tranquil
heartbeat through their scales, a moment
to think, Stay on guard.
I don't know this village.
There are strangers all around me, except
Willow.
I have Willow, right beside me.
And then she was out, in a darkness
beyond dreams.
She slept well past dawn.
As she realized when she finally awoke to
find the sun shining cheerfully, already
ambling up the curve of the sky.
She sat up quickly and blinked at Hazel
who was perched in her hammock, reading a
book.
Hazel's room was bright and airy, studded
with open windows and balconies so the
breeze flew through it, but sheltered
from the rain by an overhanging roof of
large, round leaves.
Three desks took up half the room, even
when they were shoved into the corner to
make space for the leaf pile sundew had
slept in.
Each desk was covered in a mess of
bookbinding supplies made from jungle
ingredients, some kind of sap glue
dripping over the sides of its pot, tree
fiber threads draped everywhere, and bark
for the covers scattered about, dyed in
colors from deep berry red to summery
daisy yellow, to a swirl of purple and
pearl white.
Bright red trumpet creeper flowers poked
through the roof, and Hazel had hung
small paper dragons and clouds from every
leaf stem, so there was a little blizzard
of them flying overhead.
Sundew blinked again, and looked over her
shoulder to see Willow still asleep
beside her.
Willow had one wing flung out to the side
the way a baby dragonette might sleep, and
her cheek was pillowed on her front
talons in a cute smushy way.
Focus, undo.
Or pause for a moment to be happy.
That's what Willow would say to do.
After all the craziness with silk wings
and sneaking through hives, and dealing
with strangers, I am back with her at
last, where I can just be myself.
She sighed.
All right, moment over.
Hazel, she said, and the princess finally
looked up from her book.
Aren't we late to meet your great
grandmother?
Weren't we supposed to be there at dawn?
Hazel's wings lifted and bell in a
shrug.
She sent a messenger that she wasn't
ready yet.
She'll call us when she wants us.
Don't worry.
Sundew frowned at her.
And what am I supposed to do until then?
Just sit around this village like an
orchid waiting to be stomped?
Dragons will be looking for me.
Also, I have things to do.
She thought of blue and cricket, and a
bumblebee and swordtail, would they worry
about her?
Or would they think she'd abandoned them
as would be typical of her according to
them, apparently.
I hope someone feeds bumblebee.
She caught herself thinking, and then she
wanted to smack herself.
That dragonette would 1000% make sure
someone fed her.
She didn't need sundew for that. of them
needed her.
You're doing the most important thing.
Willow said sleepily.
You're investigating the mind control
plant and warning us that the hive wings
know we're here.
That's pretty important if you ask me.
The hive wings don't know we're here
Sundew pointed out.
They know we're still alive, but they
don't know where.
Willow propped her chin on one talon and
gave sundew a skeptical look.
You don't think they'll guess pretty
quickly?
Hmm, where could those dragons who like
trees possibly be?
Oh, perhaps in the only bit of forest
left on the whole continent, which also
happens to be the only place we haven't
been able to go for the last 50 years?
What a coincidence.
Sundew felt unease ripple under her
scales.
Was Willow right?
Would it be that easy for Wasp to find
them?
She'd assumed Wasp would come after them
eventually, but also that she'd waste
some resources searching the whole
continent first?
It doesn't matter if they guess right, she
huffed.
The poison jungle will fight them off.
Even if they arrived at the snarling
river today, they couldn't get through to
either of our villages.
The jungle will eat them alive.
I hope you're right, Willow said.
Hey, while we wait, let's go talk to
those sea wings.
Don't you want to meet them?
Sundew scales prickled with excitement
and nerves.
She'd nearly forgotten about them while
she slept.
Dragons from the distant kingdoms.
She couldn't believe it, but Cricket was
right.
It was a real place where dragons really
lived.
Yes, she said.
Let's do that right now.
We can take them some breakfast, Willow
said, sitting up and stretching.
Hazel, want to come too?
The princess shook her head.
I met a really good part.
She said apologetically, holding up her
book.
You know, great grandma usually never
leaves me alone for this long, so I want
to take advantage of it while I can.
I get that, Willow said.
See you later.
Bye, Sundew mumbled. following Willow out
of the room.
They flew down to the kitchen level, where
2 busy dragons waved at Willow, and made
puzzled faces at sundew, but didn't stop
their whirl of chopping and peeling and
preparing.
Willow scooped up 2 halves of a coconut
gave one to Sundew, and filled them both
with strips of dried mango and raw fish.
It seems like most of the dragons in the
palace know you, Sundu observed.
I guess, Willow said, glancing around at
the chefs.
I mean, everyone kind of knows everyone.
There aren't that many of us in the tribe
after all.
Because the hive wings tried to wipe us
out, and then half of us left to form our
own tribe, Sunday thought.
With an odd twist of guilt under her
usual anger.
Do you come here a lot, though?
Sundew asked.
Watching Willow dig out and open a barrel
of macadamia nuts?
To the palace, I mean?
Maybe to see Hazel?
Willow crinkled her snout at sundew.
Hazel is a friend of mine, she said.
Like all the dragonets, our age in the
village.
But if what you're really asking is, hey
Willow, have you by any chance fallen in
love with some other dragon while I
abandoned you to go start a war and
frolic with silk wings?
And there is no, I haven't.
You're still the only dragon for me, even
when you ask silly veiled questions.
She tossed a nut at Sundew, which bounced
off her nose before she caught it.
Oh, Sundu said.
Well, then, good.
Fine.
I mean, that wasn't what I was asking, but
since you brought it up.
That's great and good and fine with me.
And Willow prompted.
And thank you for the macadamia nut, send
you guest.
And you're still the only dragon for me
too, Willow, light of my life.
I promise I will never fall for beautiful
silk wing and leave you.
Willow put one talon dramatically to her
forehead.
By all the trees, Sundew said.
Of course, that's obvious.
That's so obvious.
I don't need to say that, do I?
You know all that.
I mean, obviously, as if, leave you for a
silk wing?
Bleh.
Willow giggled.
I know, she said, but you should say it
all the time anyway.
I can't imagine you would take me
seriously if I said things like light of
my life all the time, sundew said
balancing the coconut and its contents
carefully as she spread her wings and
flew off the balcony with Willow.
I will always take you exactly as
seriously as you deserve.
Willow said, grinning.
That is not a comforting answer, light of
my life, sundew said.
Willow started laughing so hard.
She nearly dropped her coconut.
A different set of not quite exactly
guards were gathered outside the strange
dragon's rooms.
These 4 were bent over a map of the
jungle around the village, pointing out
spots where unwanted plants were trying
to get in, and comparing stories of their
valiant battles with dragon traps.
They glanced up at Willow and Sundew, but
didn't move to stop them, or even ask
what they were doing there as they
landed.
Can anyone in the village just stop by to
see the weird dragons?
Sundew asked.
I suppose so, Willow said, but I probably
visit them the most, because I'm the one
who found them.
You are?
Sundu blinked at her in surprise.
Didn't I mention that?
Willow said.
She flicked her wings back and batted her
eyelashes.
I rescued them from a giant anaconda.
If it weren't for me?
They'd be super dead.
And then we'd have nothing but the
remains of 2 interesting corpses to
study.
She sighed.
The Bluer dragon poked her head out of a
room.
In the daylight, it was a little harder
to see the dots of phosphorescent scales
around her eyes, and along her snout
bones, but her deep blue color, unusual
wing shape, and sundew noticed for the
1st time webbed talons were much more
obvious.
Willow, she said brightly.
I always know it's you when I hear
someone talking loudly about heroic
anaconda rescues.
I will forgive you for the corpse comment
because you come with food.
Hi, tsunami, Willow said, passing her one
of the coconuts.
This is sundew, my girlfriend.
Unexpected tiny starbursts of joy
exploded all through sundew's body from
her toes to her wingtips.
They had never told anyone that before.
Hearing Willow say it out loud, casually
to a totally random dragon, was probably
the 2nd greatest moment of sundew's life
right after meeting Willow.
She wondered what the blue dragon must
think of meeting a leaf wing wearing
whatever incredibly giddy expression she
probably had on her face.
Hello, Sundoo.
What kind of tree is that?
Tsunami asked, backing into the room so
they could enter.
The other dragon lay on his side by the
wall.
He looked slightly ill, but he lifted his
head curiously to see them.
It's not a tree.
It's a plant that eats dragons and other
animals, Willow explained.
She's one of the poison wings I told you
about.
That's not what we call ourselves, Sundoo
said quickly.
We're leaf wings, real leaf wings.
She might be able to answer some of your
questions, Willow said to the dark blue
dragon.
Because she's just been to the hives.
Oh, tsunami said, looking at sundew more
intently.
Hi, croaked the other Sea Wing.
I'm turtle.
Sorry I'm not getting up.
I don't feel very well.
He swallowed a lot more of the Gullet
River than I would recommend, Willow
explained.
I'm sure he'll be all right in another
day or two.
The ginger tea has been helping, hasn't
it, turtle?
He more or less agreed, flopping his head
down again.
Poor dragon, Willow said.
You know, I told them to turn around and
go straight back to their continent, but
it's a good thing they didn't.
I don't think turtle would have made it.
Groom, broom, he groaned.
You really came all the way from the
distant kingdoms?
How did you get here?
Sundu asked tsunami.
She could practically hear cricket
banging off the walls of her brain
yelping questions.
These dragons from the distant kingdoms
would absolutely make her lose her mind.
She'd probably be even worse about them
than she was about her beloved mysterious
reading monkeys.
We swam, tsunami said.
She held up one of her webbed talons, then
pointed to what looked like gills along
her neck.
Sea wings can breathe underwater, so we'd
swim until we got tired, take a nap at
the bottom of the sea, ate some fish, and
then keep going.
It felt like heading off the edge of the
world.
For most of the trip, we couldn't see any
land in any direction.
Maybe an island in the distance, unless
we were hallucinating those, but we were
trying to stay on a course due west
following the stars if my brother has any
idea what he's talking about.
It took us about 4 days of almost nonstop
swimming.
But I bet I could have done it in 3 by
myself.
I'm not sure if Turtle is really sick or
just still recovering from all that
exercise.
Oi, turtle protested weakly.
Right here, and really sick.
That's a long time to swim without
knowing anything was out there, Sundew
said.
They must be out of their minds.
What kind of lunatics would swim off the
edge of the world for no reason?
But we did know this continent was out
here, tsunami said, surprised.
Didn't you tell her, Willow?
I thought you should, Willow said.
A Pantalan dragon washed ashore on our
coast several days ago, Tsunami said.
She got caught in a storm and blown over
the sea to us.
In a storm?
Sandu echoed, her ears perking up.
Does she have pale green wings and
glowing wrists?
Whoa.
You know Luna?
Turtles said from the corner.
I thought leaf wings and silk wings
didn't talk to each other, tsunami said
to Willow.
For example, Luna didn't say anything
about this jungle.
Or about dragon eating plants, or dragon
eating giant snakes, or dragon poisoning
rivers, turtle mumbled.
I only met Luna briefly, Sundu said, when
we rescued her from the Flame Silk
Cavern.
Turtle and tsunami exchanged significant
glances.
So that part of her story was true
tsunami murmured.
Willow had never heard of a flame silk
cavern.
I'm sure it was all true.
Sundew said.
Luna's feisty for a silkwing, but she's
still a silkwing, and they're a pretty
simple tribe.
Whatever she told you, you should believe
it.
Really?
tsunami said.
She was very worked up about the plight
of the silk wings.
She wanted us to gather an army and
charge across the ocean and destroy the
hive wings to save her tribe.
Sundew leaped to her feet, her eyes
shining.
Uh-oh, said tsunami.
Yes, Sundu cried.
Do that.
Hang on, said Turtle.
How big is your army?
What kinds of weapons do you have?
How soon can they be here?
Are they on their way?
Are you the advanced scouts?
Send do.
Don't get too excited, Willow said
reaching out to touch one of sundew's
shaking wings with hers.
They are not sure they should get
involved.
Why wouldn't you?
Sundew yelped.
Don't you care about fighting injustice
and and evil?
Evil, you could stop evil.
Did you think of that?
Hey, tsunami protested.
I've stopped plenty of evil, and so has
turtle.
Sendu gave him a skeptical look, but
decided to refrain from asking how that
was possible.
Then stop this one, she said to tsunami.
The hive wings are the worst, and they
deserve to be wiped out.
Tsunami's face closed down suddenly, like
a dragon trap slamming shut.
We don't wipe out entire tribes, she said
firmly, and we will never help anyone
who'd be willing to do that.
But you don't know what they did, Sandu
cried.
She felt like all her hope was slipping
away, like chocolate in a dream, melting
through her claws before she could eat
it.
At that exact wrong moment, Hazel poked
her head in the door.
Wow, she said.
Can't you all hear that?
She jerked one claw over her shoulder.
In the pause that followed, Sundew heard
the unmistakable roars of a horribly
familiar voice somewhere on the jungle
floor outside.
Oh no, she said, looking at Willow.
She didn't even realize she'd held out
one of her talons until Willow took it
and squeezed it reassuringly.
What is that?
Tsunami asked.
Sundew sighed.
My mother is here.
Chapter 10.
Willow, Sundew, and Hazel reached
Sequoia's throne room first.
The leaf winged queen was sitting on her
throne with her eyes closed and her
forehead furrowed, as though she had a
massive headache.
That's only going to get worse.
Sundoo thought grimly.
Your majesty, Willow said.
We heard Belladonna outside.
Sundu finished for her.
I don't know how she guessed I was here.
I often leave the village at night or in
the early morning to hunt.
I didn't think she'd come looking for me
so quickly, or that she'd ever think to
check among the sap wings.
Ah, Queen Sequoia said, opening her
eyes.
She didn't think of it.
I summoned her.
Summoned her?
Sundew said, flabbergasted.
Nobody summoned Belladonna.
Also, how dare the queen?
Why didn't you ask me?
Or at least warn me?
I don't want to see her.
I mean, here, now, like this.
She forced herself not to glance at
Willow, not to give away too much with a
look.
She wasn't ready to tell her mother
everything yet.
She didn't want Belladonna to ruin this
the way she definitely would.
Queen Sequoia looked faintly
incredulous.
I don't want to see her either, but we
don't have time for my peace of mind or
your family drama.
Wasp is about to throw her entire brute
force at us, every claw and tooth and
venomous stinger.
We need a plan, and we need all talons
ready.
All leaf wings, no matter what our
differences have been in the past.
Well, talking to her isn't going to help
Sandu grumbled.
I don't exactly have a choice, Sequoia
said.
I need to know what else she's done and
what she's going to do next.
I told her to bring your captives, or
else I wouldn't release my hostage, the
queen added.
That's you.
She let out a snort of laughter, as if
she was picturing Belladonna's reaction
to that threat, and Sundu had to admit to
herself that it was kind of hilarious to
imagine.
It was slightly less hilarious when
Belladonna swooped in, though, in her
towering cloud of rage.
She came straight through one of the
balconies and slammed her talons on the
polished wood floor, scattering raindrops
everywhere.
She was only wearing a few of her pouches
as though she'd thrown them on in a
hurry.
But Sundew could hear ominous hissing and
clicking coming from a couple of them.
It sounded as though Belladonna had
packed a few of her nastier insect
weapons.
What are you doing here?
She roared at sundu.
You know you're not allowed to talk to
sap wings, and you're definitely not
allowed in their village.
Sundew spread her wings and shrugged
hoping no one could hear her pounding
heart.
What could I do?
They caught me.
Caught, you?
Belladonna snarled.
And, um, dragged me back here, Sundew
said, kicking and fighting the whole
way.
These dragons.
Belladonna scoffed disbelievingly.
Sapwings did that?
Yes, and then they forced me to tell them
everything, Sundew said.
It was barbaric, really.
You should be mad at her.
She pointed at the queen. who rolled her
eyes.
Something about this feels highly
unlikely, Belladonna growled.
It doesn't matter, Queen Sequoia said
standing up.
Belladonna, I should arrest you for
treason.
You did everything I told you not to do.
You were seen by hive wings.
You stole their sacred property, and you
said one of their hives on fire.
Beladan lifted her chin and narrowed her
eyes.
I see you really did tell them everything
she said to Sundo.
Did you bring her captives?
The queen asked.
The flame silk and the others.
I brought the others.
Belladonna said, flicking her tail at the
window.
Outside, Sandu caught a glimpse of
Wolfsbane and Biblus, hovering on either
side of cricket.
No wonder the trees were starting to fill
up with curious dragons, gathering to
stare at the hive wing in their midst.
But not the flame silk.
You cannot have my flame silk, Belladonna
added.
Even in exchange for your daughter.
Sequoia asked lightly, almost as though
she was just curious.
My daughter could escape and kill you all
any time she wanted to.
Belladonna said, with a stern look at
Sundew.
The only reason she hasn't yet is she's
trying to infuriate me.
That's right, mother, Sundu said, with a
theatrical yawn.
It's all about you.
You're the only reason I do anything.
I think about you all day long.
Stop it, you two.
The queen ordered.
Belladonna, bring the other captives
inside.
Hazel, please go retrieve our strange
guests.
Hazel nodded and hurried out of the
room.
What if I don't?
Belladonna started.
I don't care what you don't want to do.
I am not going to let your dragons die.
Queen Sequoia said fiercely.
You may have been apart from us for 50
years, but you're still my tribe.
If we don't work together now, we don't
stand a chance.
She closed her eyes and muttered, one.
Two.
Three.
Belladonna huffed her way over to the
window and signaled to Wolf's Bane.
Are you going to tell us the truth about
that mind control plant?
Sundew asked the queen.
Sequoia opened her eyes, gave her a
strange, clouded look, and hesitated, but
only for a moment.
Yes, she said, I have to.
Sandu wanted to press her further, but
just then Hazel came back in with tsunami
and the unfamiliar silk wing behind her.
The silk wing was very tall, with huge
indigo wings dotted here and there with
iridescent green.
She had an alert, defiant expression on
her face, but she didn't seem worried to
be surrounded by so many leaf wings.
Oh, thank goodness.
Swordell's voice came loudly through the
window.
I was wondering how long we'd have to
wait out here in the rain.
I am completely soggy.
Ah, he said, as he landed on the balcony
and squelched inside.
I'm so sorry about your floors.
Oh man, look at these footprints.
I didn't even know I had this much mud on
me.
I mean, how did that even happen?
We were flying, right?
And yet, Soretail?
The purple silk wing gasped.
He looked up, and his jaw dropped, and he
stared at her for an astonished moment.
Aio!
He finally shouted, bounding across the
room toward her.
All thoughts of his wetness seemed to fly
out of his head, much like the shower of
droplets that covered everyone in the
room as he threw his wings around the
other dragon.
Sore tailed by all the trees, Sundew
huffed, shaking herself off.
She glanced to the balcony and saw
Cricket coming in, carrying Bumblebee.
Their eyes met, and cricket gave her a
tentative, worried smile.
This is my sister, sword tail crowed.
Sundu, cricket, this is Io, my sister.
How did you get here?
Io cried.
That's the longest story ever.
How did you get here?
He asked.
As cricket sidled across the room to
sundew's side.
Sundew noticed that Bumblebee was asleep
and then noticed that she found that
disappointing for some completely
inexplicable reason.
Well, my plan was to hide with some
friend in the yellow jacket hive
chrysalis, Io said to Swordtail, but when
I got there, I was spotted by guards, who
chased me pretty much all the way to the
jungle, I flew inside to escape them, and
almost immediately got caught by this
enormous, horrifying, insanely sticky
plant.
It was going to eat me, sore tail, with
like, it's goo or something.
How wild is that?
But these dragons rescued me?
And they said I could lie low here for a
while.
That is bogkers, Sortell said.
I got eaten too, by giant mouth plant.
Another sword tail.
Sundew whispered to Cricket, just what we
need.
IO seized SwordTail's front talons.
Have you heard anything about blue?
She asked.
Did the hive wings catch him, or did he
find a chrysalis?
Neither.
Swartell said.
He found her.
He pointed at Cricket.
Io saw the hive wing for the 1st time, and
her face underwent an extraordinary
transformation from excitement to fury in
seconds.
She took a step forward, her ears
flattened to her head, but Swordtail
bundled himself into her path and shook
her by the shoulders.
No, no, calm down.
Crickets on our side, he said.
She saved blue, like more than once.
He's here, in fact, in the other leaf
wing village right now.
Oh, Io said.
But, what about, she flicked her tail at
cricket, pointed to her head, and rolled
her eyes back until almost only the
whites were showing. doesn't work on her
he said.
No evil queen in her head, not ever.
Oh, well, great.
IO waved politely at Cricket.
Nice to meet you.
Thanks for saving Blue.
Excuse me, tsunami interjected.
Did you say blue?
It's just, we were told to find a, oh my
gosh, cricket gasped.
She gripped Sundu's arm and pointed at
tsunami.
Oh, oh my gosh.
Do you see that?
What is happening?
Who is that?
Why is she amazing and blue?
And look at her wings, and are those
webbed talons?
Are they for swimming?
Is she a water dragon?
What is she?
And where did she come from?
Oh my gosh, she's from the distant
kingdoms, isn't she?
If you're going to faint, hand me
Bumblebee 1st so you don't squash her by
accident, Sundew suggested.
I should visit new continents more often
tsunami said, with a pleased expression.
I wish everyone was that excited to see
me.
Wait until you tell Sortell that you met
Luna.
Cindu said.
Soretail whirled toward tsunami, his face
incandescent with hope.
Yes, she's all right, tsunami said.
She washed ashore on our continent.
She's the reason we're here.
She says you all need help.
She asked us to look for sore tail and
blue to tell them she's okay.
IO put one wing around her brother, as he
buried his face in his talons and burst
into tears.
Ah, sore tail, she said.
She'll find a way back here.
You'll always find your way back to each
other.
Sappy.
Tsunami commented, but that's basically
what Luna said too.
How does she speak our language?
Cricket breathed.
Is it magic that we understand her?
Is she a magic superpowered dragon like
clear sight?
Oh my gosh.
Can you see the future?
I can see a future, tsunami answered.
One where it takes me the next 3 years to
answer all your questions.
Really?
Cricket gasped.
Calm down, Cricket, Sandoo said.
If this dragon could see the future, she
wouldn't have almost been eaten by an
anaconda.
True, tsunami said, I also wouldn't have
eaten that thing this morning that looked
like a slug and turned out to be a slug.
The queen clapped her talons together, and
everyone fell silent, turning toward
her.
Listen, there's a lot to cover, she
said.
And we don't have much time, so we must
save the introductions, reunions, and
questions until after our urgent
business.
As I understand it, 2 days ago.
Belladonna and the Poison Wings committed
an act of war.
By burning one of the hive wings cities.
During the course of that mission, leaf
wings were seen.
So there will be no doubt in Queen Wasp's
mind that our tribe is still alive, and
that we are the ones who started the
fire.
Can't we tell her it was them and not
us?
Hazel asked, jabbing one of her claws at
Belladonna.
Yeah, give that a try, said Wolf's bang
darkly.
I hear she's quite reasonable.
Sorry, Hazel, said the Queen.
She hates all leaf wings equally, and
she'll be even more furious when she
discovers I'm not dead.
There's no chance she'd let half of us
just carry on living quietly in the
jungle.
She flared her wings and looked over at
Wolf's Bane and Belladonna.
There's also no chance I'd let her kill
the other half of our tribe.
Even if she did promise the rest of us
our safety.
Those are our dragons too.
We don't bow to you, Belladonna snapped.
We don't have a queen.
Sequoia narrowed her eyes, and took
several long, deep breaths without saying
anything.
Finally, she spat, but you do have a
problem, an incoming army problem.
And you won't be able to fight them with
only half the tribe.
Even a full leaf wing tribe wasn't able
to stand against them last time.
And our numbers are much smaller now.
How do you know we have an incoming army
problem?
Belladonna scoffed.
Maybe we scared them.
Maybe they're licking their wounds and
wondering if we're vengeful ghosts.
The queen shook her head.
I know wasp.
She strikes back the moment she's
struck.
I estimate we have a day, maybe two.
While they put out the fire, tend to
their wounded, and relocate their eggs
and dragonettes.
Then perhaps a day to gather her hoard
and travel here.
More likely less.
If they're not on the border of the
poison jungle by tonight, they will be by
tomorrow morning.
Tonight?
Willow gasped.
That's ridiculous.
Belladonna growled.
She can't organize her army or get war
ready that quickly.
Yes, she can.
Cricket said.
She doesn't need to waste time sending
messengers, or waiting for dragons to say
their goodbyes or any of that.
She'll just slither into all their heads
and make them come to her, whether they
want to or not.
I told you about the mind control.
Queen Sequoia said with a sigh.
But you never quite believed me.
She stood up, lifted the vine off the
back of her throne, and held it out for
everyone to see.
This is the other reason she won't waste
any time.
She needs this plant to keep her hold on
her tribe, but Sundu and her friends
burned up her supply.
Which was a good idea, Swartell objected
just so we're clear.
It was very heroic, and a blow for
justice and freedom, and I was definitely
involved.
She might have more of the plant, Cricket
said.
We burned one greenhouse, but she could
have a backup somewhere.
Couldn't she?
Maybe, said the queen.
But she also knows where to find as much
as she needs.
She pointed out the window.
Right here.
And the poison jungle, where it came
from.
It came from here?
Sundu said.
Are you sure?
I haven't been able to sense it
anywhere.
That's because it's quarantined.
Queen Sequoia frowned at the vine. as
though it didn't deserve to live.
It only grows in one particular corner of
the jungle, guarded by a dragon named
Hawthorne, who is forbidden to let it
escape.
Really?
Hazel breathed, her eyes wide.
You've never told me about this.
I've never heard of it either, growled
Belladonna.
It's not a secret we want anyone to know
said the Queen.
It's the most dangerous plant in the
whole poison jungle.
She plucked one of the wilting flowers
off the vine, and held it before her
eyes.
The pale white of the petals was starting
to fade to brown.
But at the heart of the wilting flower
was a glistening dark red seed, so dark.
It was almost black.
Have any of you?
asked the queen.
Heard of the legend of the hive.
Part two.
Tendrils and teeth.
Chapter 11.
The what?
Belladonna barked.
Legend?
Is it story hour now?
I don't care about an old legend.
This is important, said Queen Sequoia.
She held out one talent to Hazel, who
went forward to take it.
Do any of you know it?
Sundu glanced around, but all the other
dragons in the room were shaking their
heads too.
The queen sighed again.
Sundew kind of wanted to poke her in the
snout with her sharpest claw, once for
every sigh.
What did she have to be so tired about?
After 50 years of cowering in the jungle
and not fighting the bad guys.
It was a story from long before Clear
Side's time.
Queen Sequoia began, guiding Hazel to sit
at her feet.
The princess looked up at her great
grandmother with wide eyed awe.
Sundoo wondered if bumblebee would look
like that when she could understand
stories.
Not that I care.
I certainly won't be the one telling
them.
The legend begins with the earliest days
of dragons arriving on this continent
said the queen.
Back when the Leaf Wing tribe and the
Beetle Wing tribe were new, and they came
to these shores to escape trouble in the
distant kingdoms.
The what?
Swartell broke in.
What's a beetle wing?
That's what silk wings and hive wings
used to be, before Clearside came along
and her ancestors split them into 2
tribes.
The beetle wings were more like silk
wings, according to the stories. except
that some of them had deadly weapons, like
the ones you now find among the hive
wings, shooting deadly venom from their
fangs, in particular, according to the
old stories.
Tsunami gave a little jump, as if she'd
been startled by something.
Whoa.
Sortell looked at his claws, as if he was
hoping venomous stingers might suddenly
pop out of them.
What was the trouble that they had to
escape from?
Cricket asked.
Probably the same trouble there always is
Io said.
Dragons being cruel to other dragons
because they don't look or act exactly
like themselves.
The legend doesn't say.
What it does say, the queen went on.
Is that the 1st dragons who landed on
Pentala encountered something...
Very strange.
Her voice dropped so low, sundew could
barely hear her over the sound of the
rain outside.
The night they arrived, as they all
slept.
The earth below them began to seethe with
motion.
Tiny legs crawled across their scales, and
then more, and then more of them.
The dragons awoke suddenly from their
dreams into a true nightmare.
They were covered in fire ants.
Their shrieks rose up to the 3 moons, and
they ran to the ocean, but even as they
ran, more colonies of ants boiled up out
of the ground and attacked.
They marched up the dragon's legs and
burrowed between their scales and dug
their mandibles into their skin.
The ants didn't let go as the dragons
plunged into the sea.
They didn't try to save themselves.
They held on.
Like grim death, until at last the ants
drowned.
Yeesh.
Sortell said, with a theatrical shudder.
But the ends were only the beginning, said
Queen Sequoia.
The next morning, as the dragons were
limping back to their campsite, they
heard buzzing in the air, getting closer
and closer.
When they looked up, the sky was dark
with bees.
So many bees, they blotted out the sun.
The bees descended and attacked all at
once, just as the ants had done.
And again, the dragons were forced to
flee into the bay and hide below the
water.
The legend says they were saved by their
flame silks, who burned the bees out of
the sky.
So the legend of the hive is about creepy
ants and bees?
Io asked.
The queen shook her head.
It got worse.
And stranger.
The swarms of insects kept coming.
And the next attacks came from insects
that normally don't work in groups.
Imagine armies of venomous centipedes.
Battalions of setse flies, swarms of
bombardier beetles.
They killed dragon after dragon with
mindless, unwavering ferocity.
Some of the dragons vanish to the night
never to be seen again.
Others went down right in front of their
friends, suddenly covered in assassin
bugs.
Of course the dragons fought back.
They'd come too far to run away, and
according to the story, they were
refugees who could never return to the
distant kingdoms.
So they fought to stay.
But it seemed that whenever they struck
down one group of attackers, another
would instantly appear in its place.
The insects were followed by coils of
rattlesnakes, a vast pride of lions
murders of crows.
The queen lowered her voice again, staring
into the heart of the pale flower.
These were not ordinary attacks.
The animals moved like a single
organism.
If a crow was struck on one end of the
battlefield, the crows at the far end
somehow knew instantly.
The snakes attacked simultaneously
targeting their victims with coordinated
precision.
But how?
Cricket asked.
This sounds like a myth that's gotten a
little warped over time.
Are you saying this plant works on
anything?
Reptiles, birds, insects, and mammals?
How is that possible scientifically?
Um, I have a more important question
Sandu interjected.
Who was controlling them?
She realized she'd twined her tail around
Willows at some point during the story.
Probably while the ice was trickling down
her spine.
But Belladonna's eyes were riveted on the
queen, and Sundu couldn't make herself
pull away from Willow's comforting
warmth.
Queen Sequoia closed her front talons
around the flower, and looked straight at
sundew.
Nobody knows.
What?
said Swordtail.
Three moons.
I think my chills have chills, tsunami
said, shaking her wings out as though she
couldn't feel them anymore.
How could nobody know?
Cricket asked.
Didn't they find the dragon behind all
the attacks?
The tribes never found anyone, said the
queen.
They searched far and wide for years, but
there were no other dragons on the
continent, as far as they could tell.
But Hazel started, then trailed off.
What they found.
Was this?
Queen Sequoia opened her talons to reveal
the flower again.
The seed inside it glistened, like a
wicked little eye, watching them.
We call it the breath of evil.
Seems a little dramatic, Belladonna
muttered.
This vine covered everything, said the
Queen.
The legend described it exactly.
It is the part of the story that has
survived the most intact.
As though the storytellers knew how
important it would be for us to recognize
it, if it ever appeared again.
This plant was wound around every tree
through every meadow, in every marsh, no
matter the landscape.
It derived across all of Pentala.
But the dragons from the distant kingdom
soon discovered, that when they destroyed
this plant, the attacks waned.
When they cleared all the vine from an
area, that area gradually became safe to
live in, no more attacks.
The animals began to behave like normal
animals.
So long as they lived within the
perimeter the dragons made. where there
was no breath of evil.
I don't like this name.
Swartell said, or this plant.
I just want that on the record.
I don't like it at all.
I can see why Queen Wasp doesn't let us
hear that story, IO said.
It might ring a few bells, even inside a
dense hive wing skull.
Sundew saw cricket wince, and tuck the
sling a little tighter around Bumblebee.
But how does it end?
Willow asked.
The legend of the hive, I mean, there's
not much more.
Queen Sequoia said, spreading her front
talons.
It's all garbled, from millennia of being
passed down.
This is how I understand it.
Something here tried to kill us when our
ancestors arrived, using mind control to
turn the wildlife into weapons, but
destroying the breath of evil took away
its power.
Once they realized that, the tribes
organized expeditions to uproot the plant
across the whole continent.
Hang on.
Can we go back to the thing breathing the
evil?
Sundu said.
The dragon, or dragons, that controlled
everything?
Even though the tribes never found it, it
must have died too, right?
Once the plants were destroyed and it
realized it had lost, she paused and
looked around at the range of frightened
expressions.
Right?
Of course, said the queen.
This was a very long time ago, 1000s of
years.
But I guess the plants weren't all
destroyed after all, said Cricket, lifting
her head to face Queen Sequoia.
The queen rested one talent on Hazel's
head and sighed.
No.
Some of it survived.
Hidden deep in the poison jungle.
Where wasp found it, Cricket said slowly
she must know the legend.
She must have gone looking for it, hoping
she could use it herself.
I wondered how she figured out what to do
with it.
And if it once worked on any animal, why
did she only use it on hive wings?
Why bother with the tree wars?
If she could also mind control the leaf
wings and silk wings?
Queen Sequoia shuttered?
I'm sure she tried.
Belladonna spat.
Probably doesn't work on a superior
species like leaf wings.
Sundew caught IO rolling her eyes.
The point is, this is where she got it
from, Sundew said, so this is where
she'll come to get more of it.
If we really burned up her whole supply.
Not if we strike her first. snarled
Belladonna.
We're going to burn all their hives.
I'm planning our next attack now.
We just need a little more flame silk, and
Yellow Jacket Hive will be a pile of ash
before you can blink.
Wasp isn't going to wait for you to do
that, Cricket said.
Queen Sequoia is right.
She's gathering her army right now.
She'll be here before you can convince
Blue to give you any more flame silk
before you could even get to Yellowjacket
Hive if you already had it.
We must act quickly.
Queen Sequoia rose from her throne with a
commanding expression, and Sandu could
suddenly see why a whole tribe would have
followed her into battle over and over, no
matter how often they lost.
Belladonna, wolf's bane, and the silk
wings, the queen said, pointing to Io and
sword tail.
Wolf's bane looked slightly startled that
she knew his name.
You 4 will come with me.
We will gather our strongest warriors
from both villages, and fly to the
snarling river, to prepare for wasps
attack.
We need to strengthen the jungle's
defenses and hold them off as long as
possible.
Um, Swartell said, I mean, that sounds
awesome, but how exactly are we going to
help?
He pointed to himself and IO.
By talking to the flame silk, Sequoia
said.
I understand his reluctance to burn down
hives.
But I hope you can convince him how much
we'll need him in battle when wasp
attacks.
Also, one of you must contact the
chrysalis.
If they want to rise up and overthrow
Queen Wasp, now is the time.
They must bring their dragons to fight
alongside us, or WASP will win, and they
will never have a chance to be free.
What about me?
Hazel asked. shouldn't I go with you?
The queen's face softened, looking down
at her great granddaughter.
No, she said, I won't be able to think
clearly with you there.
I need to know you're safe here, and that
the rest of the tribe is safe too, because
you'll be in charge of them.
If Wasp gets past us, you'll need to
decide what to do.
Fight her or run.
Run where?
Cricket asked.
Deeper into the jungle, answered the
queen.
Or perhaps farther.
She turned her gaze to tsunami.
That's what I've been saying, Cricket
yelped.
Right, Sundu?
I said we should escape to the distant
kingdoms.
Hey, whoa, tsunami said, spreading her
wings and looking alarmed.
It's not that easy.
Can any of you swim?
Or breathe underwater?
We can swim, Willow said, in the river.
Maybe not like you swim, though.
All right, probably nothing like you.
Not like, swim across an entire ocean for
days and days kind of swimming, no.
Sundoo realized that her mother was
glaring narrowly at willow, and also
realized, a half 2nd later, that she
still had her tail twined with willows
and, oh dear, that probably had something
to do with the look on Belladonna's
face.
Well, too bad, she thought defiantly.
I'm not letting go now.
I'm not ever letting go of her again.
If this is it, all our truth spilled over
the table, then this is my truth.
I choose Willow.
Even if she is a sapwing and not mandrake
mom.
Right, tsunami said to Willow, so how
would you all get there?
Sorry, it just, it seems unlikely.
I've been trying to think about how we
could bring other dragons over here to
help you, if we decided to do that, she
added quickly, glancing at Sundew.
And I can't think of anything.
Maybe if my friend Starflight were here
or Kibli.
Hmm, she crinkled her snout.
I might have a way to ask them though.
What?
Sword Tell asked, how?
How would you do that?
Distant kingdom super dragon magic
Cricket whispered, her eyes shining.
Ahem.
The queen said, taking over the
conversation again.
So, Hazel and Tsunami, you'll stay here
and try to formulate a plan, a way to get
to the distant kingdoms if we need to.
Or another solution in case Queen Wasp
reaches the village.
Belladonna, you may send a few of your
dragons to work with them.
Biblus, perhaps.
I understand she's quite clever.
Yes, I see how much information your
scouts have gathered.
No need to rub it in.
Belladonna snapped.
Queen Sequoia closed her eyes, lifted her
chin, paused for about the amount of time
it took to count to 10, and then turned
her gaze directly on sundew.
The rest of you, she said.
Sundo, willow, hive wing.
You must seek the guardian of the breath
of evil vine.
Hawthorne has had 50 years to work.
It's a long shot, but maybe he finally
found the one thing that could truly save
us.
An antidote?
Cricket blurted.
Sequoia arched an eyebrow at her.
Yes, she said.
That was my dramatic line, young dragon
an antidote.
Something that can break the mind
control?
Cricket said, too excited to be chastised
a way to free the rest of my tribe.
That was our hope, and his quest, said
the queen.
But he never returned.
I have heard nothing in all these years
so perhaps it was impossible.
Or perhaps he is dead.
Or perhaps we'll find him and save
everybody.
Cricket bounced on her talons so
enthusiastically that Bumblebee woke up
with a snort.
Don't get your hopes up too high.
The queen warned.
After all this time on his own.
I'm not sure he could possibly still be
alive.
Not to mention, said Io, that even if you
do cure all the hive wings, they might
still decide to fight for wasp with their
own free will.
This finally did make crickets wings
sink.
They won't, she protested.
I'm sure they won't.
Some of them won't, anyway.
She trailed off, worrying one of her
claws.
Where is this dragon?
Sundew asked the queen.
In the eye of the jungle, Sequoia
answered, I'll give you a map.
It'll be a dangerous journey, but I think
you're the right dragons to undertake
it.
You might want to leave the dragonette
with us, though, Hazel offered.
Cricket closed her wings protectively
around Bumblebee, who shoved them aside
to peek out again.
Her eyes were enormous, and she was
quieter than Sundew had ever seen her.
I'd rather keep her with me, Cricket
said.
She'll be fine, Sandu agreed.
We'll keep her safe.
Just a moment.
Belladonna hissed.
I'm not letting my daughter stroll off on
a suicide mission with only these 2 these
2 strangers alongside her.
She cast a vicious look at cricket and
Willow, especially Willow, Sundew
thought.
I insist they take 2 of my dragons with
them.
Sundew guessed immediately where this was
going.
Ah, no, mother, why?
She protested.
Either you don't go, Belladonna said
firmly, or you take mandrake and Nettle
with you.
Chapter 12.
I think I should be in charge, Nettle
announced, as Sundew spread the map out
on a tree stump in the center of the
sapwing village.
The rain had finally stopped, so the
stump was slightly damp, but the map was
drawn on a large waterproof leaf.
It was also, in Sundu's opinion, not the
most helpful map she'd ever seen, but
Queen Sequoia said this was all the
information she had.
Ha, Sendu said, without looking up at
Nettle.
No, but I'm the oldest.
Metal hissed.
So I have the most experience in the
jungle, and I have been training for a
mission like this my whole life, and I am
a natural leader.
Ha.
Ha, Sundew snorted, outvoted 4 to one.
You didn't even ask them.
They might vote for me.
Nope, said Willow.
Sorry, no, said Cricket.
Me boo.
Bop.
Bumblebee chimed in enthusiastically from
her sling.
Oh, whoops, 5 to one, Sendu said.
Maybe she is smarter than she looks, she
added to Cricket.
She held out her palm and the dragonette
whacked it delightedly.
Man Drake!
Nettle demanded, swelling up with
indignation.
Tell her I should be the leader.
Sundo.
Why would you do this to me?
Mandrake asked plaintively.
Because if she's mad at you, maybe she'll
stop harassing me for a nanosecond.
Sundew pointed out.
Willow, what's the farthest you've been
on this map?
Willow pointed to a cluster of squiggles
northeast of the village, the Mantineal
Grove.
I got too close to it once on a hunt, and
my father dragged me back here and
lectured me for a week about it.
Willow's father had turned out to be a
kind eyed, pale green dragon, with a lot
of nervous energy.
Sundew had only met him for a moment, as
the queen swept him into her entourage
and he paused to wish Willow good luck.
Sundew had noticed, with a twinge of
disappointment, that Willow hadn't said
my girlfriend, in that introduction.
Of course, that probably required a
slightly longer conversation involving
some confessions about sneaking off into
the jungle at night.
Sundew needed to have a similar, slightly
longer conversation with Mandrake, but
not in front of Nettle, and not when they
only had a day to find the antidote, and
bring it back to stop Queen Wasp.
Priorities sundo.
Focus on the mission.
Totally not just avoiding something
enormously awkward.
No.
There's not a lot of detail in this map.
Sunu observed.
She wished she'd had time to restock her
pouches, they felt unfortunately light
for such a dangerous expedition, she
rechecked her list in her mind, hoping
what she did have would be useful.
Most of us haven't gone past the
manchineels, Willow said.
They are scary death trees.
I've read about them, but I've never seen
one, Cricket said, pushing up her
glasses.
Her tail was doing it, so curious, I can
hardly stand it, twitch dance.
Don't even think about it, Sundu said.
No time for research today, Miss Brainy.
We'll go around them.
She rolled up the leaf again and glanced
up at the trees.
The sapwings were frantically busy
hopping from tree to tree, shouting
suggestions at one another, and gathering
in small worried groups to whisper before
splitting up again.
But there were still a few of them who
had stopped to peer down curiously at
cricket and bumblebee.
The 1st hive wings most of them had ever
seen.
Which is, thanks to us, the real leaf
wings who scared off all of WASP's
raiding parties, or tricked them into
getting eaten.
Find something more productive and less
nosy to do, she shouted at the closest
peeping leaf wing, he jumped and scurried
away up the tree, like a startled
squirrel.
Oh my goodness, Willow said, must you be
so terrifying?
It's my special skill, Sandu said, and he
deserved it.
Did he though?
Willow said thoughtfully.
Could you please keep being the one
dragon?
I am not furious at right now?
Sundu said.
Come on, everyone, let's go.
Willow, you lead the way for now, since
you're the most familiar with the jungle
around your village.
Willow hesitated for a moment, as though
she was thinking about pressing her point
a bit more, but instead, she nodded and
headed into the trees, to Sundu's
relief.
Sundu followed, with cricket a half step
behind her.
The hive wing was like a shadow, staying
as close to sundew as she could, although
she kept twisting her head to stare at
weird plants as they went by.
I'm familiar with this area too.
Nettle complained from the rear.
I've been scouting in sapwing territory
since before Mandrake was born.
I know every kind of tree around here.
Me, me, me, me, me, Bumblebee said, in a
hilariously similar tone of voice.
Sundu smothered a laugh and glanced over
her shoulder for the joy of catching
Nettle's furious gowl.
Excuse me, Nettle demanded.
Why are we taking a hatchling with us?
A nasty hive wing hatchling no less.
Oh, is it because we're hoping something
will eat her?
A snack for the dragon traps?
What a good idea.
Maybe you should shut your trap, Sundew
suggested.
Brr, brr, brr.
Bumblebee agreed.
She seemed to be feeling saucier now that
they were heading away from the villages
full of staring dragons.
Mandrake.
Nettle cried.
Are you going to let her talk like that?
If you don't stand up to her now, she's
going to walk all over you when you're
married.
Oh, I have no idea what that feels like
he grumbled.
Willow turned to arch her eyebrows at
sundew.
Don't panic, sundo.
Don't blurt out something idiotic.
This was not the end of the world.
Willow knew about mandrake.
She knew Sundew was supposed to marry him
in some distant future.
She knew Sundu didn't want to and didn't
plan to and wasn't going to, and she knew
that Sundu had been figuring out how to
explain that to him for years.
Willow did think years was a bit of a
long time for Sundew to hang on to that
explanation.
But she also thought sundew would
eventually leave the offshoot tribe and
come live with the sapwings.
She'd always hoped that one day sundew
would magically stop feeling so angry, and
that she'd give up the vengeful life of a
poison wing on her own.
Willow had expected that to be the
inevitable end of any marriage plans with
Mandrake.
Sundew had a different endgame in mind
however.
In her plan, she'd fulfill her destiny
destroy the hive wings, prove to her
mother that she could do it herself, and
return a hero.
Then she'd be able to choose her own
future.
She'd be able to do anything she wanted
once that was done.
She hadn't expected her destiny to be
quite this awkward.
They walked and climbed, and whacked
their way through the undergrowth for a
long time, mostly in silence, apart from
Nettle complaining, and bumblebee
chirping at things.
Willow moved confidently, pointing out
things to avoid, like snake nests and low
hanging strangler vines.
Dense clouds of moss covered the tree
roots all around them, dotted with
sprouts of deadly mushrooms that looked
like eyeballs growing out of the earth
ate me.
The mushrooms chortled.
Just try.
Ferns brushed their scales and whispered
back along their stems.
Strange, strange.
Why?
Beware, beware, creatures out of place.
In their vague, feathery fern way.
Nettle was on a rant about how she'd have
found a better route by now.
When they reached a slope that slanted
sharply down ahead of them, riddled with
the lumpy roots and pricker bushes, a
slick layer of rotting leaves made it
tricky to stay upright, sundew found a
branch that wasn't covered in thorns or
toxic sap, held onto it with one talon
and reached out to support cricket with
the other.
You know, you can go ahead and ask all
the annoying questions buzzing around in
your head, she said, as the hive wing
slipped and slid past her, clinging to
her arm.
Bumblebee leaned out of her sling to gawk
at the fuzzy orange monkeys in the tree
overhead.
Sundew wasn't sure how cricket could
balance it all, with the dragonette
wriggling around like that.
I'd rather listen to you than Nettle.
Oh, really?
Nettle spat.
Leave the jungle once.
And suddenly you're a hive wing loving
traitor to the tribe.
I should have seen this coming.
I always.
Her diatribe turned into a shriek as she
took a wrong step, lost her balance, and
plummeted down the steep hill.
Sundew yanked cricket out of the way, and
Nettle hurtled past, plowing a canyon
through the wet leaves.
Willow managed to leap into the air and
hover before she got knocked over.
She tried to catch Nettle, but the dragon
was sliding too fast.
Wait, come back and tell us again about
how you're the smartest dragon in the
jungle, Sundu called after her.
Nettle screamed back something about
killing sundew.
And then her voice abruptly cut off as
she vanished over the bottom edge of the
hill.
Uh-oh.
Mandrake said.
It was difficult to fly between the low
tangled branches, the hungry dragon traps
and the surprise cobwebs full of
poisonous spiders, but they finally
managed to hop, hover, skip down the
slope to a flat spot at the bottom, which
turned out to overlook a large brackish
lake.
Cricket peered over the edge.
It's not that far down, she reported, but
I don't see Nettle anywhere.
Wow, said Sundew.
I was hoping we'd lose her, but I didn't
think it would happen quite that fast.
Mandrake gave her a look, and she rolled
her eyes.
I'm kidding.
I sure she's fine.
She can handle anything, remember?
What if she fell in the pond and
drowned?
Willow asked anxiously.
Get me out of here.
Nettle's muffled voice screamed from
somewhere below them.
That doesn't sound like drowning, Sundu
said.
She fell on the spot where she could
spread her wings to their full length and
hopped over the edge, floating down to
the muddy banks of the lake.
Her talons squelched into slimy black mud
and nearly flattened a squashy looking
toad, who let out an alarmed blart and
scooted away.
Sharp hollow reeds poked out of the marsh
all around her.
Some of them were broken near the bottom
and nearly hidden by the mud, stabbing
her feet as she picked her way closer to
the water.
From down here, it was obvious what had
happened to Nettle.
A huge cluster of pitcher plants was
gathered right below the hill, gaping
maws, ready to swallow any animal that
tumbled down it.
Each one looked like a long green sack
tipped with stripes of dark pink around
the open mouth at the top.
Sundu had a collection of much smaller
pitcher plants growing outside her nest
to catch flies before they buzzed in and
bothered her.
She really didn't like this big kind
though.
It was super creepy to look at a giant
pitcher plant and wonder whether there
might be a dragon corpse decomposing
inside it.
Or, in this case, a dragon that was still
very much alive and spitting mad.
Get me out.
Get me out of this thing.
Nettle shrieked.
One of the plants wobbled as she slammed
herself into the side.
Whoa.
Cricket said, landing beside sundew.
She's in there?
Why doesn't she just fly out?
Me, bum more.
Bumblebee added, wide eyed.
The inside walls are covered in slime
Willow answered, as she and Mandrake
joined them.
It coats the wings of its prey as it
falls in, making it harder to fly and
impossible to climb out.
There are also sharp hairs lining the
walls, pointing down, so anything that
tries to fly or climb up will get
stabbed.
And if we don't get her out soon.
Mandrake said, she'll either drown or get
digested by the acid pool at the bottom
of the pitcher, which would be bad.
He added, almost as though reminding
himself.
I wish Blue were here, Cricket said
pressing her talons to her forehead.
I'm not sure setting it on fire would
improve Nettle's situation, Sundew
pointed out.
Oh, I didn't mean for his flame silk
Cricket said.
It would just make me feel better.
She glanced down, looking embarrassed.
Sundew understood that.
She had wished for Willow's company a
1000000 times during her mission to the
hives.
She stole a glance at Willow, caught her
looking back, and had to smother a
smile.
We'll have to cut her out, Sundew said
briskly.
Willow and I will start with our claws.
Mandrake and Cricket?
Look for anything else around here that
might be even sharper.
They had to wade into the thicket of
pitcher plants to get to nettles, which
was extra creepy, because Sundew could
sense them all thinking, in essence.
Hmm, yeah.
Come in yum, delicious.
Wanted, mmm, mine.
Like a creepy background chorus of hungry
ghosts.
Their stems were cold and clammy, and the
pitchers bumped against them, some of
them skin crawlingly heavier than
others.
Don't think about what might be in
there.
Do not think about it.
The plant nettle was in had a
particularly smug, plummy vibe to it.
As though it wanted all its neighbors to
notice that it had caught the best prey
and no one else could have it.
Ha.
Ha, ha, hmm.
Look at my yums.
All mine, my yums.
It smirked.
Well, it wasn't going to be so pleased
for much longer.
Willow stabbed her claws into its side
and Sundew felt the plant snarl with
fury.
Chili vibrations echoed through the roots
and leaves all around her, and she
thought some of the plants were leaning
closer.
Mmm, yum.
Climb in here, little yums.
Dangerous, delicious, eat before it hurts
us.
Eat it now, yum.
She added her claws to the grooves Willow
was making, dragging them up and down
digging deeper each time.
They carved a square in the side of the
picture.
Big enough, she hoped, for Nettle to
crawl through.
But the walls of the pitcher were thick
and rubbery, and oozed with slime that
made their talons sting and stick
together.
It felt like their progress was too slow
as though they might look up any moment
and find that night had fallen.
Also, it was incredibly hard to focus
with Nettle's shrieking bloody murder the
entire time.
Sundew took a step back and shook her
aching talons.
I can't believe I'm doing this for nettle
of all dragons.
Here, Cricket gasped behind them.
She leaned between 2 pitchers, and passed
them a wickedly sharp thorn almost as
tall as Willow.
Ah, watch it, Sundu cried.
You nearly stabbed Willow.
Not that nearly.
Willow said.
This is perfect cricket.
Thank you.
She wrapped her arms around the wider end
and thrust the thorn at the plant like a
spear.
To sundew's surprise, it appears to write
through one of the lines they had
carved.
Nettle's shriek instantly went up an
octave.
What are you doing?
She screeched.
Are you trying to kill me?
We're getting you out.
Sandu yelled back, like you've been
screaming about this whole time?
Just get out of the way.
As if there's anywhere to go, Nettle
bellowed.
It's crammed and dark, and things are
stabbing me, and this goo on my tail
really hurts and...
But while she was shouting, Willow had
been dragging the thorn along the outline
of the square, and suddenly, a whole
piece of the pitcher wall fell off, and
Nettle came tumbling out after it.
Ew.
Bumblebee declared, and perhaps her most
accurate observation so far.
Nettle was dripping with pinkish green
slime from horns to tail, and the acidic
rotting smell coming from her, and the
sliced up plant was nearly as bad as a
corpse flower in full bloom.
That took you long enough, she yelped
struggling to her feet.
Her wings were plastered to her side.
You're welcome, Mandrake called from
outside the pitcher plant cluster.
I cannot believe this.
Nettle stamp squelched past sundew and
willow, shoving pitcher plant viciously
as she went by, and marched to over to
the edge of the lake.
The muddy water made the slime look even
more dreadful.
But as she scrubbed it all over herself
hints of her own green scales started to
peek through again.
Are you all right?
Cricket asked.
As if you care, Nettle spat.
Do not talk to me right now.
I don't want anybody talking to me.
That sounded like an entirely fine plan
to send do.
She pulled out the map and held it up
squinting at the lines in the semi
darkness.
She knew the sun was high in the sky, but
only a little of its light filtered down
to them here at the bottom of the
jungle.
It looks like we need to cross this lake
to avoid dimangineals, Sundu said.
Nettle, while you're there, could you
poke your nose in the water and see if a
bladder wort tries to eat you?
I'll feed you and your stupid little
striped monster to the bladder warts
Nettle snarled.
Ta-da!
Bumblebee declared, working 2 of her
wings free and flinging them out to
either side.
Could YouTube please stop yelling at each
other?
Willow asked.
She was standing at the edge of the water
squinting at the cloudy surface that
stretched ahead of them.
It's only making this harder.
Sundew blinked at her in surprise.
It didn't feel harder to her.
In fact, yelling at Nettle gave her
energy, and it stopped her from worrying
about all the really big things she had
to worry about.
Moreover, couldn't Willow see the
difference between nettles yelling
unproductive, vicious, out of control, and
sundoes, hilarious, and morale boosting?
Look, Willow said.
There are plants floating right below the
surface all the way across the pond.
Bet you anything, there are water wheels
everywhere.
Yeesh, Mandrake said with a shudder, and
even Nettle took a step back.
Water wheels?
Cricket asked Willow.
They're like aquatic dragon traps, Willow
said.
Same idea. touch one, and it closes
around you, drags you under, drowns you
and digests you.
Ew. said Bumblebee.
No, bumblebee.
Cricket said sternly.
Not ooh, more like, yikes, terrifying.
Although, speaking purely scientifically
that is pretty amazing.
Plants that can drown you, plants that
slime you and eat you?
I can't believe they didn't teach us any
of this at Terrarium Academy.
This is way more interesting than how to
grow radishes.
I'm glad you're so fascinated.
Nettle said in an icy voice.
Perhaps we could switch to places, and
your tribe could try growing up in a
habitat where everything is trying to
kill you.
Can't I yell at her when she's being mean
to cricket?
Sundew wondered, glancing at Willow
again.
She was studying the trees overhead now.
Although, I guess I've said things almost
exactly like that to Cricket 2.
She nudged cricket, who was looking
pretty deflated.
I bet you're dying to ask about the
mansion eels, she said.
The hive wing wrinkled her snout.
I've been restraining myself, she
whispered.
You can see them over there, Sandu said
pointing to the grove of trees that
crowded all the way up against the left
bank of the lake.
The fruit looks edible, but will make you
insane and then kill you.
Also, the sap is poisonous.
If you stand under one while it's raining
poisonous sap will drip on you and you
will die.
Also, they are covered in wicked thorns.
Like I said, willow chimed in, scary
death trees, she pointed up.
I think we have enough room to fly over
the lake.
If we're careful, go one at a time, and
avoid the dragon traps, trumpet flowers
and were rigelas.
Roar Ridgelas?
Crickets said alertly.
Do you know anything?
Nettle demanded.
Nettle, stop it.
Willow said, in her most extremely very
stern voice, where Ridgulas are like
sticky death shrubs, she said to
Cricket.
If you brush up against one, you'll be
stuck there until assassin bugs come and
eat you.
Urgh, Mandrake said faintly.
You know, I'm really not sure why
Belladonna wanted me to be on this
mission.
So you could keep an eye on send you, of
course, Nettles snapped.
Sundew bristled.
Nobody needs to keep any eyes on me.
Gross.
How dare you?
Sundo.
Stop, Willow said, resting her tail
gently on sundew's shoulder.
Just let it go.
We have more important things to worry
about.
Sundew scowled at Nettle.
It was bad enough when Nettle was just
irritating.
But there would be justifiable murder
involved if Nettle kept making Willow
talk to Sundew like that.
I'll fly across first, Willow said, to
make sure there's a safe path.
No, I'll fly across first.
Nettle said, I'm not scared if that's
what you think.
Willow held out her talons, palms up.
I do not think that.
Of course you can go 1st if you want to.
That's right, Nettle muttered, shaking
the last bits of slime off her wings.
There was mud caked between her scales
and trails of dried slime along her neck
and tail, but at least she was able to
fly again.
She stamped her feet a few times and then
took off.
They all squinted after her, watching her
path as she zigzagged and maneuvered
around the obstacles that hung over the
lake.
It must be exhausting to be that angry
all the time, Willow commented.
I'm not, though, Sundew said.
You know that, right?
That I'm not like that.
I know, Willow said, but her smile seemed
a little hesitant.
Sundew thought for a moment, and then
said carefully.
But it's not bad to be angry.
Sometimes there are things a dragon
should be angry about.
I guess, Willow said. looking down at her
claws.
It's just not usually my 1st reaction to
anything.
Like everything about the hive wings and
what they did.
It makes me really, really sad.
If I think about it too much.
I want to curl up in a pile of leaves and
cry.
But what good would it do to be mad
instead?
I mean, whenever I do get mad, I usually
end up feeling guilty or really tired or
both.
It's not like that for me, Sundu said.
Maybe the guilty part sometimes, but
being mad makes me want to get up and do
something.
It makes me want to fix the bad things.
Isn't that better than curling up under a
pile of leaves and hoping the bad things
go away?
Willow looked into her eyes for a long
moment, as if she was really thinking
about sundew's point.
Yes, she said finally.
That makes sense.
It does?
Sundew said, startled.
In her tribe, arguments went all day.
And nobody ever admitted that the other
dragon had said something sensible.
Willow glanced sideways at cricket and
mandrake, but their gazes were riveted on
Nettle as she negotiated a tricky spiral
under a Strangler vine.
I like that you want to fix the bad
things.
Willows said softly, touching one of
sundew's talons with her own.
But are you only mad at the bad things?
Or are you mad at everybody all the
time?
Sundew bit back a snappy retort.
That wasn't fair.
She wasn't mad all the time, and when she
was mad, the other dragon clearly
deserved it.
She made it.
Mandrake shouted.
He jumped up and down, flapping his
wings.
We can do this.
Do you want to go next?
Cricket asked him.
I'd rather watch someone else one more
time, he said, if that's all right.
I'll go, Willow said.
She brushed Sundew's wing lightly, with
an expression that might have meant, sorry
don't be mad, or we'll be all right, or
I'm totally falling out of love with you
right now.
Sundew wasn't sure, but she wished she
had something to stab to make herself
feel a little better.
Willow's crossing was smoother and more
graceful than nettles.
Objectively true.
Not at all, sundew's biased opinion.
Mandrake went after her, swerving wildly
around Origula, and swooping low enough
that he nearly fell in the lake a couple
of times.
But at last he made it safely to the
other side.
All right, Cricket said. taking a deep
breath.
I can do this.
Let me take Bumblebee, Sundoo said.
I'm more used to this kind of flying than
you are, and she might throw you off.
Snoodoo!
Bumblebee cheered.
She lifted her little talons up and did a
very good impression of something cute.
Something more like a tamarind and
definitely not like a hive wing.
Are you sure?
Cricket asked.
I thought you didn't want her getting
attached to you.
Well, I'm not planning to glue her to me
Sundu said.
I just figured I'd marginally increase
both your odds for survival.
I do like that goal, Cricket said, smiling
as she untied the sling.
She passed bumblebee into sundew's arms
and started rewrapping the scarves around
sundew's shoulders, readjusting her
pouches as she did.
Bumblebee was lighter than sundew had
expected.
A warm little ball of scales with lots of
spiky bits.
Her elbows and wings and horns and tail
all seemed to poke sundew at once, as the
dragonette wriggled around, burbling with
joy.
But after a moment, she settled with her
wings tucked in and nudged her nose under
sundew's chin.
One of her tiny talons wrapped around the
pouch with a jade frog in it.
It felt weirdly comfortable and mildly
alarming at the same time.
This was definitely a small living thing
that might die if sundew did anything
wrong.
But it was also a small living thing that
apparently completely trusted her.
Plants did that sometimes, but plants
weren't exactly cuddly.
We're fine.
Sundu said to Cricket, stop fussing and
get flying.
She watched cricket dart and hover
through the obstacles.
Pausing now and then to peer at a plant
she didn't recognize.
One of them turned out to be an
iridescent pink beetle instead of a
flower, and it shot a blast of acid at
her, that she just managed to duck before
heading down to land on the opposite
shore.
Sundew tugged the scarf a little higher
up Bumblebee's neck.
Our turn, little bug, stay very still, and
do not distract me.
Understand?
Oobi, goo.
Bumblebee said sternly.
She patted Sundu's face.
Do knobby, splam flamp.
I wasn't planning on being splam flam
Sundu retorted, whatever that is.
She lifted off, wobbling a little as she
adjusted to Bumblebee's weight.
Her claws skimmed the lake's surface as
she flew under a crisscrossing tangle of
vines, and below her, she saw blurry
water wheels, snapping shut on the
ripples.
A knobbly reptilian head rose from the
depths to stare at her with yellow eyes
but she didn't stop to figure out what it
was.
Up a little higher, over a knot of dragon
traps, wings tucked to fit between a loop
of dangling snakes, and a glittering web
of poisonous sap.
Now she had a straight line of sight to
the 4 dragons waiting on the far side.
Nettle was twitching her tail
impatiently.
Willow looked anxious.
Not much farther.
She said to Bumblebee.
She beat her wings once and turned into a
dive.
And then suddenly Bumblebee shrieked, be
bluff, and flung herself upward, grabbing
sundew's horns, pulling them down, and
smacking her little body over sundew's
entire face.
Sundew yelped and fell. momentarily
blinded.
Her wings flailed to catch the air.
And instead, she felt one of them catch
on something else.
Something sticky and prickling that
caught and held her wing fast, slamming
her to a stop.
Her momentum spun her toward the caught
wing, she flung out a talon to stop
herself, and felt it smack straight into
the same gluey ooze.
She was trapped, and so was Bumblebee, and
she could already feel the other tendrils
closing in.
Whispered the plant.
So delicious.
Chapter 13.
Sundoo.
Willow screamed.
Sundew couldn't see around the black and
yellow scales draped over her snout.
She didn't even know exactly which kind
of sticky plant had caught them.
Bumblebee, she said, trying to keep the
panic out of her voice.
Are you all right?
Bumblebee said in a small voice.
Good, said Sundew.
Then what in the name of all the trees
was that?
Eep?
Bumblebee said in an even smaller voice.
Bebuff.
Get off my face, Sundew snapped.
Carefully.
I am really mad at you.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Bumblebee protested. wiggling down until
she was hanging from Sundew's snout with
her tail around Sunday's neck.
She managed to scoot herself back into
the sling and leaned into Sundew's chest
patting her heart under the jade frog.
Miss Snoogoo.
Goo is right, Sundoo said, studying their
abductor.
She was stuck on one of the towering
leaves of a plant that sprawled across a
small island in the lake below her.
The leaf was bright lime green, with 100s
of thin red stalks poking out of it that
made the entire plant look fuzzily
scarlet from afar.
At the tip of each stalk was a glistening
drop, like a translucent murder pearl.
Oh, no, Sundu muttered.
Isn't this amazing, Nettle called, with
an undeniable note of triumph in her
voice.
The great and wonderful sundew trapped by
an actual sundew.
That's a sundew?
Cricket said.
Huh.
I thought they'd be prettier.
That thing looks like a giant spider got
turned into a plant and sprouted weird
red hairs all over it.
But you can get away from it.
Right, Sundoo?
Sundo?
Willow cried.
Don't move.
That was an unhelpfully obvious piece of
advice.
Sundu knew that struggling would only
trap her worse, but she didn't exactly
have many options at the moment.
Three of the sticky dewdrops, had snagged
Sundew's left wing tip.
Her right front talon was caught on
another 2, and her back talons were
snared and still more below her.
As she tried to brace the rest of her
body away from the plant.
Huddled in her sling, Bumblebee was
trapped between Sundew and the sundew, but
she hadn't touched the sticky substance
yet.
She peeked at it with wide eyes, more
still than sundew had ever seen her, as
though she understood the danger of
moving.
The other tentacles on the leaf were
creeping toward them, leaning, drooping
closer and closer.
In a few moments, new beads would reach
her scales, latching on with gummy
ferocity.
Soon after that, the tentacles would wrap
tighter, drawing her inescapably into
their embrace, until they held her and
Bumblebee as close as they could, until
they suffocated and died, and were
consumed by the plant.
She summoned all the power of her leaf
speak.
Stop.
She screamed at the tentacles.
The sundew froze.
Each red stalk tentacle paused where it
was, as though the plant was staring at
her with a 100 glistening beady eyes.
Let us go.
She ordered it.
A long pause as confused messages fired
up and down the sundew's synapses.
Can't, it finally whispered back.
Not so much a response as an observation
echoing through the leaves. hungry.
Want this, mine.
One of the tentacles reached for her face
and she roared, stop again.
It froze once more, but it was so close
to her eye now that she couldn't stop the
panic thundering through her heart.
The plant sensed it, and flickered
something curious and malevolent back at
her.
Her fear tasted delicious to it.
I'm not scared.
She snarled out loud.
I want to rip you out by your roots and
burn you to ashes.
Malevolent flicker.
More.
It liked the taste of her anger too.
She shuddered despite herself, and felt a
tentacle snag on her tail.
She had to stay calm, especially for
bumblebee.
The rotten little bugface had gotten her
into this mess, but she didn't have to
die for it.
You do not want this prey.
She thought forcefully and leaf speak.
It will sicken you.
Hmm.
The sundew responded with skepticism.
Sundoo?
I'm coming to get you, Willow called.
No, Sundu shouted back.
You'll only get stuck too.
I can get out of this.
Stay there.
Mafib?
Bumblebee asked, wiggling her head up
closer to sundoos.
She poked the jade frog pout with one of
her claws.
Sme buff?
Sme buff, sundew echoed.
Are you trying to annoy me to death
before the plant eats me?
you wretched little lizard?
Boof.
Bumblebee insisted indignantly.
She leaned under Sundu's left arm and
jabbed another pouch.
Boof, boof, boof.
Sundew was about to yell at her to shut
up.
When a realization hit her like a falling
tree.
Wait, she said, are you trying to say
bug?
Does a mi Zacco?
Bumblebee shouted, as though she couldn't
believe how thick Sundew's head was.
Bluff.
I do have a couple of bugs in there
Sundew said.
That might.
Shush, and let me think.
Shmasham, is-mush.
Bumblebee grumbled.
She draped herself around Sundu's free
arm and glared at the tentacles.
Most of them were still hovering as the
plant decided what to do, but a few were
stealing closer at a snail's pace, as if
hoping no one would notice until too
late.
Bugs.
Boof.
Wait.
Be buff.
What if that actually meant something?
Willow, Sundew called.
Did you see why Bumblebee freaked out?
Did she see something?
Yes, Willow called back.
Didn't you see it too?
Obviously not.
What was it?
It was the biggest set sea fly I've ever
seen, Cricket exclaimed.
It was like 3 times the size of
bumblebee.
All the insects are oversized here
Mandrake said.
At least, that's what my father says.
Now Sundu had a vague memory of something
buzzing nearby.
Right before Bumblebee grabbed her face.
She hated setsy flies.
One of her favorite teachers had been
killed by a setsy flybite.
After that, she'd made it her personal
mission to tell every carnivorous plant
near the village to eat as many set sea
flies as possible, and they hadn't been
seen in her part of the jungle ever
since.
But this wasn't her part of the jungle.
Willow, where did it go?
Can you still see it?
No, Willow said.
Nothing.
Maybe there?
Mandrake's voice said nervously.
Oh, yes, I think so.
Sundu, to your right and above you, on
the vine.
Sundu carefully inched her head around
and looked up.
She glimpsed the shimmer of wings and a
huge blackish brown body, nearly hidden
by leaves.
She tried to think, but it had been a
long time since she'd studied them.
What attracts setsi flies, she yelled to
her friends.
Attracts them?
Nettle shouted.
Why would he want to do that?
Maybe the smell of blood?
Willow guessed.
Bright colors.
Cricket shouted, especially blue.
Really?
Mandrake said.
How do you know that?
I read a study.
Cricket said, from a while ago, way
before the tree wars.
I kind of like reading studies.
Worth a try, Sundew said, thinking
quickly through the items in her
pouches.
The only problem was that she couldn't
reach most of them with her only free
talent, at least not without probably
getting more stuck.
She took a breath.
Bumblebee.
She said.
Are you listening?
Can you do something important for me?
EM, Bumblebee said, in her most solemn
voice, patches of black scales circled
her yellow gold eyes, making her look a
little like a tragic panda as she gazed
up into Sundew's face.
I need you to climb onto my back, Sundew
said.
Really?
Carefully.
Hold on tight, and find the leaf pouch
under my left wing that's a darker green
than the others.
Do not open it yet.
B Mish, Bumblebee said grandly.
She crawled up onto Sundu's shoulder and
started inching her way down Sundu's back
clinging to the pouch straps and the
other side of the slang as she went.
Sandu could hear her singing softly to
herself.
Beamish, Snoo, do.
Bump, bump, Snabble, eh?
B, miss, new, do, bump, bump, snay, all
day.
The dragonette tugged at the fiber ropes
wound around sundew's left wing, and one
of the tentacles above them curled
forward and glommed onto sundew's wing
scales next to the others.
Yuck, dragon, Sundew thought frantically
at the plant.
Dragons so very yuck.
Sick, the plant that eats the dragons.
The sun do thought, but then, shivering
along its leaves from the central core
sick.
Sick.
Poisonous yuck dragons, sundew tried.
Maybe kill the sundew.
Mind the meal.
The plant whispered to itself, Danger.
But, hunger.
But danger.
But hunger.
Zob.
Bumblebee announced, holding up the dark
green pouch.
In the inner fold, you'll find butterfly
wings, Sundew said, pick out the blue
ones, and throw them at the tentacles
right above us.
The dragonette hesitated, and Sunday
realized that was too many instructions
at once.
Do you know the color blue?
Sundu asked.
Bumblebee glanced around nervously, then
pointed it up with a, maybe, expression
except up could be the sky, which was, in
fact, blue, or the tree canopy that
mostly hid it from view, which was not, or
any of the various bright flowers and
curious monkey faces watching them.
Find a blue wing in there and show it to
me, Sundu ordered.
Her arms and back ached from the strain
of pressing herself away from the sundew
and her mind was getting very tired from
trying to keep the leaf speak orders
going at the same time.
The little hive wing dug into the pouch
for what felt like an age, and finally
emerged with a talon full of bright blue
morpho wings.
That's right, Sundew said, twitching more
than she meant to in her excitement.
Another tentacle latched itself to her
tail.
Now.
But Bumblebee wasn't waiting for more
directions.
She threw the morpho wings up at the
stalk of the sundew that was slowly
curving down toward them.
The blues stuck where it landed, covering
the scarlet and green with a small window
of bright azure beauty, like Blue's
wings.
Bumblebee squeaked with delight at
herself. and immediately pulled out
another talon full.
This one, when she threw it, turned out
to have a few other colors mixed in, but
it still looked like a shining mosaic
most of it a blue that shone in the dark
green jungle.
The plant twitched around the scattered
wings, bewildered by the new sensation
that didn't match the others.
The Setsy fly was moving.
Only a little at first, hopping to a
closer leaf, turning in a circle, glaring
its wings and zipping them closed again
Bumblebee?
Sundew whispered, get back in the sling.
Bumblebee clambered rapidly over Sundew's
shoulder again.
No singing or burbling this time.
She crawled into the sling and wrapped it
around herself with a little shiver.
The Setsy zoomed past, close enough for
Sundu to feel the wind of its passing
against her free wing.
She held still as it circled and dove
again.
It was studying the blue shapes with its
huge horrible eyes.
Come on, sundue prayed.
Please let this work.
With a final decisive buzz, the set sea
fly swooped down and landed squarely on
top of the blue wings just above sundew's
head.
She lunged forward and slammed her free
talon into its back, smashing the fly
into the sticky tentacles.
It jerked and spasmed, but the sundew
held it tight.
More tentacles closed in, faster, the
more the fly fought.
Yes.
The sundews leaves hissed.
Take the fly.
Sundew commanded, matching her leaf speak
to the sundew's sly, curling tone.
Delicious, yes.
Dragons, yuck.
Two of the stalks touching her wing
pulled away, and reached for the fly
instead.
Then another.
Then the ones trapping her talon let go.
And gradually she felt the sun do
releasing her, choosing the simpler, less
argumentative prey instead.
As soon as she could, she threw herself
back into the air to freedom, she dove
toward the lake shore, where Willow was
waiting with outstretched arms and landed
with a crash.
Ha, ha!
Bumblebee declared triumphantly.
She rolled herself out of the sling and
did a little shimmy dance in the mud.
Her wings whisked around her, iridescent
and sparkling like a dragonflies.
Be buff.
I say what, eh?
Me, miss, yim, yim, yim.
You wouldn't have had to save the day if
you hadn't gotten us stuck in the 1st
place, Sundew pointed out.
She stretched her cramped wings and tail
and neck and arms, and tried to shake the
feeling back into her toes.
Her muscles were so confused.
She decided to lie down in the mud for a
moment and let them recover.
Good work, bumblebee.
Cricket cooed.
You helped so much.
You're such a smart dragon?
What a good listener.
For tree's sake, cricket.
Sundew said.
Belladonna had never given her that many
compliments in her life, let alone all at
once.
If my mother talked to me like that, I'd
be, well adjusted, Willow guessed, with a
crinkly eyed smile that made it very hard
to scowl at her.
As soft as a sap wing, sundew finished
sticking her tongue out at willow.
Ah, you can be soft, Cricket said to
bumblebee, still in her googly voice.
The dragonette was curled in her arms now
preening and purring like a baby jaguar.
You don't have to be mean and scary.
No, you don't.
You won't be like the other hive wings.
You're too cute, and you have your own
brain.
Don't you?
Snubble, flump.
Bubblebee agreed.
Let out an enormous yawn, and drooped
into cricket's shoulder with her eyes
closing.
Blech, nettle grumbled.
I'm going to be sick.
So sorry, I didn't manage to die for you
Sundu said.
She realized that Willow was lying down
beside her, twining her tail around
sundews and resting her wing across
sundew's back.
You scared me half to death.
Willow said softly in Sundu's ear.
Are you all right?
Can you please promise me you'll never
die?
Yes, Sandu said, nudging her with her
snout.
I promise.
She was relieved to see that Willow
wasn't still upset about their arguments
on the other side of the lake.
It was scarier than a setsu fly to think
that Willow might see sundew differently
once they were around other dragons, that
she might think sundew was just another
nettle.
But that wasn't what she saw in Willow's
eyes.
She saw herself, loved, just the way she
was.
Metal frowned down at sundew and willow
then turned and kicked Mandrake's ankle.
Oh, he protested.
I mean, ah, I'm glad you're alive, Sundu.
Thanks.
Sundew mumbled.
Just going to rest for a moment.
She closed her eyes and took a deep
breath, filling her lungs with Willow's
scent, and her mind with the murmurs of
plants who weren't trying to murder her
at least not right that second.
There were orchids nearby, each vying to
be the most beautiful.
She found the roots of sun lilies not far
below the soil, and quietly sang one up
to the surface, so it would peek through
right between Willow's front claws.
Sundew didn't have to open her eyes to
feel Willow smiling.
I nearly got eaten too, Nettle complained
and I didn't require a nap afterward.
With a sigh, Sundoo pushed herself to her
feet, Nettle was the worst, but it was
true that they didn't have time to rest
any longer.
The sun had passed the midway point of
the sky, and if cricket and Queen Sequoia
were right, the hive wing army was almost
certainly on its way.
Willow leaned over her shoulder as
Thundew unrolled the map again.
Nettles shoved mandrake, so he stumbled
into Sundew's other side.
This is where the map gets extra
unhelpful.
Sundu said, reaching out her wing to help
him catch his balance.
I mean, what are all these small
squiggling lines from here to the eye.
They look like snakes.
Mandrake offered.
Um, someone tell me I'm wrong.
They do look like snakes, Willow said.
That's fine, Nettles scoffed.
I've killed 100s of snakes.
No problem.
But, all at once, Mandrake asked.
I mean, this whole section of the map is
just snakes.
If those are snakes.
Maybe they're not.
Maybe they're very tiny rivers.
It looks like there are words here
Cricket said, crouching closer to the
leap and squinting at it.
You're right.
Willow held the leaf up to the faint
sunlight, and they all tried to read the
miniature letters carved between the
squiggles' shapes.
Does it say tiny rivers?
Mandrake asked hopefully.
Den?
Cricket guessed.
Den of Vipers, Sundew said.
A shiver ran down her spine that felt
like the sinister glee of a plant about
to feast.
The last section of the jungle standing
between us and the eye, is called the den
of vipers.
Chapter 14.
Sundu couldn't tell whether the jungle
had gotten darker because the sun was
starting to go down, or because the tree
canopy was denser here, and there was
less room to maneuver, or because it felt
like beady eyes were watching them from
every tree.
They had been walking, clambering
squelching, slogging, for a long time
since crossing the lake, and still hadn't
run into any snakes.
You are all ridiculous, Nettle declared
shoving her way past sundew as they
climbed over a fallen tree.
Snakes are not scary.
Metal.
You are very welcome to kill all the
viper's forests.
Mandrake said in exasperation.
Do you think they are dragon bite
vipers?
Cricket asked anxiously.
I read that those can kill one of us with
a single bite.
Have any of you ever seen one?
I've never seen one.
We don't exactly get a lot of snakes in
the hives.
Not even in the greenhouses.
I saw some little snakes in a pet shop in
the market.
Do leaf wings have pets?
Yes, said Willow, at the same time as
Sundew said, no.
They glanced at each other.
Sap wings do, Sandu added with a shrug.
Poison wings don't, Willow agreed.
We are not poison wings, Sundoo objected
for the 1000000th time, that really makes
us sound like a bad guys.
I'll stop if you stop, Willow offered.
I mean, sap wings sounds like a tribe
that drips around sticking to
everything.
Cricket giggled, and Sundew smothered her
own laugh.
All right, truce, she said.
Leaf Wings, said Willow.
We're both leaf wings.
But only the drippy, sticky half of us
have pets, Sundew pointed out.
She ducked away from Willow swatting at
her, and thought she saw something dart
by under the leaves, something long and
gold and black and green.
She froze, staring at the ground as the
others kept walking.
But now the leaves were still.
She didn't see any sign of whatever had
moved.
Maybe she had imagined it. as nervous as
she was.
She hurried to catch up to her friends.
I have a cockatoo.
Willow was saying to cricket.
Her name is Takatu, and she's the
smartest bird in the world.
Sundu stop laughing at me.
She shoved Sundu's shoulder
affectionately.
I was only a little older than Bumblebee
when I named her.
I'd like to see you come up with a better
name at that age.
Word a bird, Bumblebee said sleepily from
her sling, and Cricket laughed again.
Could you keep the racket down back
there?
Nettles shouted from up ahead.
They fell silent for a moment, navigating
an uphill slope covered in ferns and moss
covered rocks, and death cap mushrooms.
Sundew glanced up at the looming trees.
She'd never felt trees loom like this
before.
Even with her leaf speak, she couldn't
connect well with them.
These trees grumbled and muttered.
They were unhappy about something that
had gone on long enough to register even
with them.
But they couldn't articulate it.
Of course they couldn't.
Trees almost never could.
They could only radiate discontent and
gloom.
Is it me?
Cricket whispered.
Or is it a lot quieter all of a sudden?
Willow and Sundu both stopped beside her
and listened.
Cricket was right.
The constant chirping of cicadas and
grasshoppers had fallen silent.
There was no sound of monkeys swinging
above them or calling across the jungle.
Sundew couldn't even hear any birds.
The wind rustled the branches overhead.
That was all.
Sundew was searching the treetops for any
birds, when she saw the 1st dragon bite
viper's head.
She looked past it twice at 1st, because
it was perfectly still, but the 3rd time
something about the smooth serpentine
shape caught her eye.
The head was poking up out of a cluster
of green weeds, only a few steps from
willow.
It was, most definitely the head of a
viper. attached to the rest of the body
of a viper, as far as sundew could see.
But it was not moving.
It seemed frozen there, like a statue of
a snake.
She noticed that Mandrake and Nettle had
fallen silent too, and stopped where they
were, at the top of the slope.
They both had their eyes fixed on
something near their feet, and Mandrake
looked close to fainting.
That is really weird, Willow said
answering cricket's question.
She clearly hadn't seen the snake.
With a shrug, she stepped forward, and
Sundu reached to pull her away from the
viper, but it still didn't move.
Willow, she whispered, poking her tail, to
your left.
Ominous paralyzed viper or something?
Willow saw it and started back in alarm
but it still didn't move.
What's wrong with it?
Cricket whispered.
Can't it see us?
Is it dead?
No, Sundu whispered.
As the snake's tongue slithered out
tasted the air, and slithered back in.
Its lidless, bright yellow eyes seemed to
be staring right at them.
But when they edged forward together, its
eyes didn't follow.
It stared directly into space, head
raised, completely still, except for its
tongue.
Should we try to kill it?
Sandu asked quietly as they stepped
forward, keeping their gaze on it.
That might wake it up.
Willow whispered.
I say as long as it's not moving, don't
touch it.
Let's just get away from it.
They moved softly but quickly up the hill
staying on the rocks, and away from the
long weeds as much as they could.
Another snake was poised near the top
staring at nettle and mandrake.
This one was coiled around a thorny shrub
its green and black head jutting out into
the air, like an extra creepy branch.
Has it moved?
Sundu whispered from a boulder behind
them?
Not yet.
Mandrake answered through his teeth.
But neither have we.
See if you can slide away, Sundew
suggested.
We saw one below that stared at us but
didn't attack.
Maybe this one is frozen in place too.
I should wring its neck.
Nettle growled, but she didn't make a
move toward it, and after another moment
Mandrake cautiously sidled a step away
and then another.
The snake's tongue flickered in and out
but it stayed poised in place, enormous
yellow eyes glaring.
Sundu guessed it was as long as a dragon
if you straightened out all its coils.
Let's go, Willow whispered.
Watch where you step.
She led the way as they paced single file
with careful steps along the ridge of the
hill and down the other side.
Sundew kept her wings tucked in close and
her tail lifted off the ground.
Each time her talons came down on a slick
of wet leaves, she expected to see a blur
of motion and feel fangs sinking into her
ankle.
There, Cricket breathed, inclining her
head to the left.
Two more snakes were looped around the
branches of a tree, with their heads
reaching toward the path, staring, and
still, over here too.
Mandrake flicked his tail slightly.
They were passing a patch of tangled ivy
vines and long grass that appeared to
have strange plants growing up from the
center of it, but they weren't plants.
They were more snakes. 6 or more.
Smooth heads curled up like cobra lilies
with their menacing dandelion eyes
glittering.
Why aren't they moving?
Cricket asked.
She hesitated at a large tree root
inspected the shadows around it, then
gingerly stepped over it.
Stupid question.
We obviously don't know, Nettle
muttered.
Never seen snakes act like this.
Maybe they're watching for better prey
than us, Willow whispered.
Sundu could hardly stand it.
Her sore muscles protested at the slow
tense pace.
She wanted to scream.
She wanted to seize a tree and shove it
over on top of the snakes.
She wanted to throw exploding seed pods
at them.
She would rather fight than deal with
this.
This awful creeping, this prickling
feeling of waiting for something to
attack.
They reached the bottom of the slope and
found a stream, its muddy water trickling
slowly over stones.
Willow began to pick her way across
silently pointing to branches that were
actually snakes, rocks that were actually
snakes, and glimmers of fish that were
actually underwater snakes.
There were a lot of snakes in the
stream.
Maybe we should fly.
Mandrake suggested, halfway across.
We could go over the whole den of vipers
couldn't we?
Nettles snorted and jabbed one claw the
trees overhead.
Sundew looked up.
The branches above them were dripping
with snakes.
Scales gleamed between the leaves.
Hundreds of yellow eyes watched them
unblinking.
There were so many coils wound around
each branch, that it was impossible to
tell where one snake ended and another
began.
Sundu glanced back at bumblebee, asleep
in her sling.
Maybe we shouldn't have brought her out
here after all.
The water was very cold around her talons
colder than she thought it should be.
I wish we knew how much farther we have
to go.
They waited out of the stream on the
other side and kept going between trees
that pressed closer and closer, below
more and more frozen, watchful snakes.
Sundew reached out tentatively with her
leaf speak, and felt the presence of
plants so dangerous.
Her tribe had cleared them out of the
area around the village.
Malicious blistering hogweeds chuckled
nearby, spiking through the murmur of the
other plants.
A hungry, gurgling hum underneath
everything, told her that Kudzu vines
were wound throughout this area, devouring
and choking the quieter trees.
But there was something worse.
Something much creepier, something that
reached out to her mind with cold
tendrils.
She hissed softly.
Willow paused to look back at her.
The breath of evil.
Sundu whispered, it's here.
I can feel it.
She could smell it now too.
The same peppery rotting smell that she'd
encountered in Queen Wasp's greenhouse.
She had examined that vine while they hid
there.
But it hadn't spoken to her at all.
Nothing like what was currently reaching
back toward her, as though it was trying
to plant little seeds in her brain, and
slither through the cracks in her
scales.
Look, Mandrake said, pointing.
There was a light up ahead, a break in
the trees where a full sunlight was
shining through to the forest floor.
Maybe that's the eye, Cricket whispered.
Where Hawthorne lives?
How can he live here?
Willow whispered back, surrounded by all
these vipers, and the breath of evil.
Maybe he doesn't, Nettle said.
Maybe he's dead.
That's the spirit nettle, Sundu said.
Let's go check it out.
They headed toward the light, and as the
jungle became easier to see all around
them, Sundew spotted the scarlet and
green vines overhead.
It was here, growing freely, hardly a
day's walk from Queen Sequoia's village
she shuddered.
Why hadn't any scouts encountered it?
Why didn't everyone know about it?
Was it too well hidden behind the vipers
and the Mantineel trees, so no one ever
came this way?
They were almost at the edge of the
clearing. when the snakes suddenly
moved.
An enormous one dropped straight out of
the tree in front of them, blocking their
path.
Five more glided out of the bushes behind
them. others slithered down from the
branches.
They were surrounded, and the vipers
began to hiss.
Sundew?
Willow said, taking a step closer to the
group.
Any ideas?
Why bother asking her?
Nettle demanded.
I have a great idea.
Let's kill them.
She lunged toward the one in front of
them.
It bared its fangs and darted at her, fast
as lightning, and mandrake screamed, and
Sundew felt willow grab one of her talons
as they threw their wings out to form a
shield around cricket and bumblebee.
A gust of wind billowed from the clearing
as something gigantic swooped down, and
then wings blocked the sunlight, and
giant claws stabbed into the snake
stopping it barely a heartbeat away from
sinking its fangs into Nettle's throat.
The snake writhed in its death throes, and
as one, all the vipers around them rose
up like cobras about to strike, glaring
with their yellow eyes.
Begone, shouted the new dragon.
Leave these travelers in peace.
The hissing intensified, slipping along
sundew's nerves and all through her bones
but after a horrible heart pounding
moment of stillness, all the snakes
dropped to the ground and slithered away
into the underbrush.
Well, you very nearly just died.
The giant leaf wing said, smiling down at
them.
He shook the snake's corpse to make sure
it was dead, then tossed it away, like a
weed he'd just yanked out of the dirt.
What kind of idiots come to a place like
the den of vipers?
Desperate ones, Sundew admitted.
We were looking for a dragon named
Hawthorne.
Thank you for saving my sister.
Mandrake interjected.
I didn't need saving, Nettle barked.
I was about to kill it myself.
If you had, then the others would have
immediately killed all of you.
The stranger pointed out.
I mean, only reasonable, right?
You did come into our territory.
No one ever does that.
So, they tend to be a bit
overprotective.
They?
I'm sorry, who?
The Vipers?
They're protecting you?
Cricket asked.
They are protecting you.
What?
Oh, yes, he answered.
I'm Hawthorne, and those were my vibers.
Who wants tea?
Chapter 15.
Hawthorne turned and sauntered cheerfully
off into the sunlight.
Mandrake followed him, blinking in
confusion.
Willow stopped sundew with her wing as
she stepped forward.
I feel like we should be really careful
she said softly.
Me too, Sandu agreed.
Same here, Nettle said unexpectedly.
But this is the dragon we're looking for
right?
Cricket asked.
She adjusted her glasses.
The one with all the answers.
Who knows everything about this vine and
the mind control?
Her tail was twitching with nervous
excitement.
Yes, Willow said.
And he seems nice enough.
It's just everything else.
We'll go with him, Sundoo said to Cricket
but carefully.
Cricket nodded and they edged out into
the clearing, squinting in the much
brighter light here.
All the low hanging vines had been cut
back, along with sections of the canopy
overhead, leaving space for grass to grow
in the patches of sun.
A small vegetable garden covered a
quarter of the clearing, with the
undergrowth cleared away all around it.
And in the center of the clearing was a
house, shaped like a cell in a hive, not
a nest or a hammock, or a platform in a
tree.
Someone, presumably Hawthorne, had taken
the time to turn tree trunks into smooth
flat boards.
Someone had fitted them together, and
someone had woven flax curtains for the
door and windows, then dyed them pale
red.
Sundu pivoted to study the entire space
but she saw no sign of the breath of evil
within the perimeter of the clearing.
She could still hear it though, and feel
it, curling around the edges of her
mind.
Come on in.
Hawthorne called from the doorway.
They stepped up onto a covered porch that
ran along the front of the house.
One end of it seemed to be a small
woodworking studio, where a little half
carved dragon sat on a stump.
Honeysuckle vines adorned the roof of the
porch, adding a sweet smell to the air
and a tranquil murmur to the chorus in
sundew's head.
Inside, Hawthorne's house was breezy, warm
and full of a rose colored light from the
sun filtering through the curtains.
It was all one room, but with a high
ceiling and lots of space, carved wooden
dragons, snakes, trees, and orangutans
perched atop the shelves on every wall.
Sundew looked closely at one of the
dragon heads, and thought it looked a lot
like Queen Sequoia.
Did you make all of these?
Cricket asked, gazing around the room.
Ah, yes, Hawthorne answered.
Lots of time on my talent, you know.
No one else to talk to.
So I thought I'd make some friends for
myself.
This one's my favorite.
He padded a smooth egg shape made of
honey colored wood, with a delicate
filigree of leaves carved around the
top.
It sat on a stand on a little table by
itself, next to the window.
They're better company than you'd think.
Thank goodness I have you, right?
He said to the ag.
Poor lonely dragon, Sundew thought.
But then carving little figures to be
your only friends is one thing.
Organizing a nest of snakes to be your
bodyguards is quite another.
I can't help but notice that you're a
hive wing, Hawthorne said, wagging one
claw at cricket.
I hope you being here means peace has
finally been achieved between the
tribes.
So, maybe I can go home?
He added hopefully.
Nettle snorted.
Peace?
Not even close, she said.
This one's a bit of an ex-hive wing.
At least according to the morons who
believe her.
Ah, hmm, Hawthorne said, crouching to dig
in a cabinet.
Traitor to her tribe, eh?
No, Cricket said.
The opposite.
I want to save them.
Oh, right.
His muffled voice responded.
I know that feeling.
He emerged again, smiling.
I must say, if I'd known so many visitors
were coming, I would have carved more
cups, but these are all I have.
He produced 3 ebony cups and a stone jar
full of tea leaves.
Sundew could smell the chamomile from
across the room.
We'll just have to share, won't we?
Yes, we can manage that.
Oh, no, thank you, Willow said politely.
I'm afraid we don't have time for tea.
We don't?
Mandrake said, with a wistful look.
Nettles stepped on his talon, and he
yelped.
It won't take long, Hawthorne said.
There's a hot spring out bag where I can
get the water.
Not even have honey.
He started toward the door.
Really, no, Sundu said, putting one
talent over the tea jar.
The tribe is in danger.
We must get back before Queen Wasp
attacks, which might be as soon as
tonight.
Oh, Hawthorne said, looking startled.
That does sound serious.
Really worth mentioning, I must say.
Yes, I call that relevant news.
How do you know that?
Someone is quite clever, I see.
He put one talon on his wooden egg and
frowned down at it thoughtfully.
Ah, he said, after a moment.
He looked up at them, his brow clearing.
You know about the breath of evil.
We know it's linked to WASP's mind
control, Sendu said.
We were hoping, did Queen Sequoia send
you?
He interrupted eagerly.
Does she want me back at last?
He hesitated.
That is.
Is Sequoia still queen?
She is, Willow answered.
She is, he said, clasping his front
talons together.
That's that's wonderful news.
After all this time, still alive, I can
hardly believe it.
And she did send you.
What did she say about me?
That you've been working on a cure for
wasps' mind control?
Sundu said.
She said, you know more about it than any
other dragon alive.
Ah, he said.
His long green wings dipped and folded
back.
That is certainly true, isn't it?
I mean, that was her intention sending me
here.
Quite a long time it's been for me to be
here studying it all alone.
I really should be an expert by now.
He laughed.
Are you using it on the snakes?
Cricket burst out.
Is that why they listen to you?
Well, of course, he said.
Rather hard to study something without
doing a few experiments.
So, they obey you?
Nettle said curiously.
You can just order them around.
Are you in their heads, like WASP, when
she controls her subjects?
Cricket asked.
So many questions.
I really don't know if I can do this
without tea.
Hawthorne said, grabbing a teapot and
bustling out the back door.
Willow and Sundew exchanged glances while
he was gone, but for once, Sundew
couldn't guess what she was thinking.
Sundew wasn't even sure what she thought
of the eccentric old dragon.
Hawthorne scooted back inside, steam
rising from the water in the teapot.
He shook out a pile of tea leaves into
each cup and poured the water over top of
them.
See?
Already, he said.
Please do have some.
I'm quite proud of this tea.
He set a jar of honey on the table as
well, with a pleased expression.
No visitors in decade.
This is so splendid.
Hawthorne, Willow said gently.
We really are short on time.
Of course.
He said, his expression clouding.
I am surprised it took Sequoia so long to
send you.
I was beginning to think none of my
messages got through.
Messages?
Mandrake asked.
Well, Hawthorne said, he took a sip of
his tea.
I was forbidden to return to the village
myself, wasn't I?
Sundew gave Willow a puzzled look.
You were?
So I sent messages, however I could, he
said, in coconuts down the river, tied to
the legs of monkeys and birds.
I even sent a few of my vipers, but they
were killed before they could reach the
village.
Such a shame.
They were smart little snakes, just doing
what I'd asked.
I don't think she got any of those
messages.
Willow confessed.
What did they say?
Sandu asked, leaning forward.
Did you find an antidote?
I did, he said.
His eyes suddenly glistened with unshed
tears.
That is, I believe so.
But that's amazing, Cricket said.
Why are you sad?
Hawthorne rubbed his eyes with his
knuckles.
Oh, it's only, you know, a time I've
lost.
All these years I could have spent with
Sequoia.
Cricket sat down beside him and put one
talon over his, where it rested on the
table.
He twitched slightly, as though his
instinct was to pull away from a hive
wing, but he left his talon in hers.
I'm sorry for what you've been through
she said.
I can't imagine what it was like to be
alone for so long.
But what you were doing is so important.
You're going to save so many dragons
Hawthorne.
When all the hive wings are freed, you're
going to be a hero.
The leaf wing who devoted his life to
freeing them.
Your antidote will save my sis, my
mother.
It means everything to me.
Not to mention it'll stop another war.
He sniffed and pulled his talon away to
swipe at his eyes again.
That is something, he said.
If it works, I'm glad to know this wasn't
all for nothing.
And don't get me wrong, I know I deserved
this.
I told the queen I understood and I meant
it.
This was the right punishment for me.
The only punishment.
What?
Cricket said.
Glancing at the other leaf wings as
though they might have the answers.
Willow spread her wings, equally
puzzled.
What do you mean?
She said to Hawthorne.
I thought you volunteered for this?
How could you deserve it?
What were you being punished for?
Sundu asked.
He blinked at them.
Surprise written in every crease of his
face.
Didn't she tell you why I'm here?
He asked.
Sundu shook her head.
She didn't know why she suddenly felt so
full of dread, as though the earth was
about to collapse underneath her.
Because I'm the one who found the breath
of evil.
After everyone thought it had been wiped
out centuries ago, he said.
And I'm the one who gave it to Queen
Wasp.
Chapter 16.
What?
Willow cried.
She staggered back a step, and Sundew
reached to catch her, their wings sliding
together like falling petals.
Hawthorne's words didn't seem to fit
inside Sundew's brain.
She couldn't link them properly to
reality.
They just didn't make sense.
You?
Gave it to her?
Cricket said.
The breath of evil?
What do you mean?
When?
You didn't really.
Why would you do that?
Why would you make her more powerful?
Why would you give anyone the power to
control other dragons like that?
I don't understand, said Willow.
Me neither, echoed Mandrake.
I understand that someone's been lying to
us, and keeping things from us.
Metal snarled.
I may not understand what those exact
things are, but I know that I'm angry
about it.
Hawthorne held up his front talons, palms
out.
I'm sorry, I thought you knew.
I thought Queen Sequoia would have told
you.
Wouldn't you think she would share the
whole story before sending someone on a
quest this dangerous?
I would thank that, Nettle snapped.
She should have.
Maybe she thought Hawthorne was dead.
And if he was, then no one would ever
have to know the whole truth.
Mandrake suggested.
That is not better, Nettle cried.
That is worse.
Talk about cowardly.
Sundew was angry too, but she mostly felt
as if she'd been walking along a strong
branch, and it had suddenly snapped off
and sent her plummeting to the ground, and
the ground was extraordinarily far away
and her wings weren't working, and it was
difficult to focus on being mad and
trying not to plummet at the same time.
I think you need to tell us the whole
story, Sundew said to Hawthorne.
I must have misunderstood something.
He didn't mean he went looking for the
breath of evil.
He can't possibly mean that we did this
to the hive wings.
Hawthorne looked down at his tea, and
fiddled with a handle on his cup.
All right, he said.
But can I please start by saying, I know
you'll hate me at the end of it.
That's all right.
If you could hold back a little bit
though.
I'd appreciate it. 50 years of carrying
this guilt has really been a lot, if you
can imagine.
More explaining, less self pity, nettle
hissed.
He nodded again.
Yes.
Well, let's see.
Queen Wasp was dangerous from the moment
she inherited her crown.
Her mother, Queen Cocineal, was deceitful
and power hungry, but at least she
respected the separate tribe monarchies.
Wasp, though.
She looked at silk wings and leaf wings
and only saw more dragons to crush under
her talons.
She wanted everyone to bow to her.
That became clear very early on.
But that wasn't the worst of it.
She thought our power came from the
trees.
And she thought that if she cut them down
we'd become weak.
She did it stealthily at first.
Stretches of forest cleared and faraway
corners where we might not notice.
Accidental forest fires that wiped out
100s of trees.
Another 100 cut down to build her 1st
hive, and a dramatic performance art
piece when we tried to object.
Oh, are leaf wings the only ones allowed
to use pentalin resources now?
Why shouldn't I build my tribe a city to
live in?
And so on?
He paused to sip his tea again.
Then nudged one of the other cups toward
Nettle and Mandrake with a hopeful
expression, Nettle scowled at him, and he
sighed and returned it to his story.
By the time we figured out what she was
doing.
It was too late for countless trees.
We tried to stop her in all the
diplomatic ways, but she would lie to our
faces, promise to stop, and then turn
around and keep doing it.
Or she'd have her guards throw us out.
The queen of the leaf wings, tossed out
of wasp hive, like a spider that crawled
in the wrong window.
Can you imagine?
I can imagine tossing you out a window?
Nettle offered.
And then she became even worse.
He continued hurriedly.
She announced that according to the book
of Clearsight, the time had come for us
to consolidate the 3 tribes under one
queen.
Her.
She sent Queen Monarch and Queen Sequoia
instructions for formally stepping down
and handing their subjects over to her
control.
We know this part, Sundu said.
Queen Monarch said yes, Queen Sequoia
said no, and the tree wars began.
Not immediately, said Hawthorne.
First we tried to talk her down.
And second, we tried something else.
He cupped his claws around the teacup and
closed his eyes.
I thought we could stop her.
I thought we could save everyone.
By giving Wasp the most powerful weapon
in the world, Cricket asked.
Yes, please do explain the logic there?
Sundew said.
It wasn't supposed to make her powerful.
Hawthorne looked down at his talons.
I thought, if I found the plant and we
used it on her.
That we'd be able to control her.
Willow turned her face in towards
Sundew's shoulder, hiding it for a moment
as she breathed in a small, hiccuping
way.
Sundew wound her tail around willows and
tried to think straight.
We were trying to turn the hive wing
queen into our mind controlled zombie.
We would have done that to her.
The same terrible things she's done to
her subjects.
Instead.
We made her stronger than any other
dragon.
We gave her a way to keep her claws on
her tribe's necks and the power to use
them against us.
She glanced over a cricket, who was
staring at Hawthorne in horror.
I thought we were the good tribe.
How could we do something like this?
When did this happen?
Cricket asked.
Questions that suddenly exploding out of
her, like flame silk erupting from Blue's
wrists.
And how did you give it to her?
How did she get her talent on more of the
plant?
How did she figure out what to do with
it?
She stopped, pressing her talons to her
temples.
Why would you do this?
She threatened our trees, hive wing
Hawthorne said.
With a hard note in his voice that told
Sundew, he still thought his actions were
justified.
The trees we loved.
Our homes and souls.
We saw the war that was coming.
We knew how dangerous she was, and we
knew we couldn't give her the leaf
wings.
So we held a peace summit, and I, I put
it in her food that night.
Willow took one of Sunday's clenched
talons, smoothed it flat, and looked up
at Hawthorn again.
Did the queen know what you were doing?
He made an inscrutable face.
I told her what I wanted to do.
She didn't stop me.
But I can't say she exactly told me to do
it.
She could have stopped me, though.
I was so loyal.
I always listened to her.
If she had told me not to do it.
I wouldn't have.
She never said no.
This is really...
Hawthorne stopped himself, lashing his
tail for a moment.
I mean, he continued in a calmer voice.
Of course it was my fault.
I found the plant.
I slipped it into wasp's food.
That was me.
Even if I did it with the noblest of
intentions.
He really does still think he did the
right thing, Sundoo thought.
And that it just went wrong.
At 1st it seemed like nothing happened.
It clearly didn't work.
Hawthorne said.
He put one talon on the wooden egg again
tracing the leaves with one claw.
Wasp behaved exactly the same.
Both that night at dinner.
And the following morning during
negotiations.
We tried to steer her onto a peaceful
path, we tried subtle suggestions, and
when those didn't work, we tried to order
her to back down.
She hissed at us and promised war, just
as she always did.
So we thought we had failed.
No harm done.
A long shot attempt at salvation that
didn't work.
It wasn't until later.
When I saw her mind control, that I
realized we must have caused it.
I don't know how she figured out what to
do, or where she got the plant.
He tapped his claws on the top of the
egg.
That's what you get for sneaking and half
measures, Nettle growled.
It should have been poison in her food
instead.
That would have saved 100s of dragons.
Nobody argued with her, but Sundew could
see the consternation written all over
Willows and Crickets' faces.
She's right.
But she's also wrong, Sundew thought.
Even I don't think anyone should poison
dragons at a peace summit.
The good news, Hawthorne broke in, slicing
through the tension.
Is the now I know what we did wrong.
We needed to ingest the plant ourselves.
Otherwise, there was no connection
between our minds and hers.
But if you both ate it, Cricket asked
doubtfully.
Who would control who?
Why wouldn't she be the one controlling
you instead?
Ah, said Hawthorne.
His expression lightening.
Those are mysteries I solved with
science.
Experimentation, research, investigation.
All the careful procedures I wish I'd had
time for back then.
It's amazing what you can discover when
you're alone for 50 years with nothing
else to do.
Yes, I know, not completely alone.
Sundew tilted her head at him.
Not completely alone?
she echoed.
Do you mean the snakes?
The snakes, the foliage, my wooden
friends, he answered, waving his claws
around the little house.
I have extremely strong leaf speak, so I
can always chat with the jungle if I get
lonely.
So, you've been experimenting on the
snakes, Cricket said, and you figured out
how to mind control them?
Is that also how you found the antidote?
Yes, exactly.
Hawthorne said.
I tried everything.
And I finally found this.
He darted across the room to a wooden
chest, ornately carved with 100s of tiny
leaves.
Sundew couldn't even imagine how long it
had taken him to carve it.
He lifted off the lid, grunting slightly
at the weight of it, and laid it on the
floor beside him, then beckoned cricket
to look inside.
Sundew edged closer so she could see as
well.
The chest seemed to be full of tiny
gnarled bits of roots.
They looked like ginger root, but smelled
more like old oranges.
From the look on cricket's face, though
they might have been made of gold.
This is the antidote?
She said to Hawthorne in a hushed voice.
She reached in and lifted out one of the
roots, turning it between her claws.
What is it?
It's another plant I found growing in the
jungle, he said.
I call it heart of salvation.
Nettle snorted, and he shot her a half
smile.
I figure if we're going to be all
dramatic with our plant names, I might as
well join in.
Wow.
Cricket said reverently.
And it really works.
It breaks the mind control?
As far as I can tell, he said.
It works on snakes, but who knows about
dragons?
I haven't exactly had any test subjects
for that, have I?
Oh, maybe you could eat one, and we'll
see if it works on you.
She shook her head ruefully.
I am not susceptible to the mind control
she said.
Queen Wasp never injected my egg, so it
doesn't work on me, which means we
wouldn't learn anything from me eating
this.
She sighed and put it back in the chest.
Hawthorne watched the movements of her
claw intently, as if he was trying to
think of a way she could still be useful
to the experiment.
So to test it out, Sundu said, we'll have
to find a hive wing who is all zombie
brained, force them to eat it, and see
what happens.
I'm afraid so, he said, ringing his claws
together.
Well, luckily for us, there is probably
about a 1000 of them heading this way
right now.
Sundew said.
Peck all the weird nobbly salvation
routes you have, and let's go.
Chapter 17.
It took a while to convince Hawthorne
that, yes, they really meant it.
He should come back to the village with
them, that, yes, Queen Sequoia would be
happy to see him, now that he'd found the
antidote, that, no, nobody would yell at
him, probably, and in fact, nobody had
any idea what he'd done except for the
queen, as far as they knew.
Then they had to deal with him being
miffed about everyone completely
forgetting him, and then they had to talk
him out of packing every single one of
his carvings.
There's no time, Sundu cried, as
Hawthorne scooped up an armful of little
wooden sequoias and glanced around
frantically for a box.
Hawthorne, you can come back and get them
later.
Right now, the only thing we can bring is
the antidote.
We need to move as quickly as we can, not
card a house full of nonsense all over
the jungle.
They're beautiful carvings.
Willow interjected soothingly.
Maybe just bring one for now.
Hawthorne's expression relaxed, and he
dropped all the others, reaching for his
egg like favorite.
Yes, we can do that, he said.
As long as I have this friend.
I will be all right.
Wonderful, Nettle said, rolling her
eyes.
You carry that?
Mandrake and I will carry this.
She waved one wing over the chest full of
roots.
Sundew had misgivings about that plan.
Leaving the antidote and the talons of
those two, but cricket was carrying
bumblebee, and Sundu wanted a chance to
talk to Willow out of everyone's
earshot.
It'll be fine.
They'll be careful with it, I'm sure.
What about my vipers?
Hawthorne asked, as they stepped out the
door.
Sundew cast a glance at the sky.
She guessed it was late afternoon.
Ah, what about your vipers?
Mandrake echoed.
They started across the clearing. back
into the snake spangled jungle.
Should I bring them?
Hawthorne said brightly.
I should bring them, shouldn't I?
Your army of poisonous snakes?
To a village full of dragonettes?
Willow said.
I vote, definitely no.
But they might be useful, Hawthorne
argued, his face falling.
Aren't we about to go to war?
Yes, so I hear.
So maybe Queen Sequoia would like a few
zombie vipers on her side this time.
Please don't, Cricket said.
We don't want to make killing dragons
easier.
We don't want to kill anyone.
We're going to free them all with the
antidote, and then there won't be any
war.
Nettle snorted.
Extremely pointedly.
If it works, Hawthorne said sadly, and if
we can figure out how to give it to all
of them.
Ooh, Vipers might help with that.
Sounds like a decent backup plan to me.
That old chimed in.
She'd wound vines around the trunk, and
looped one end over her shoulder, and one
over mandrakes, so it hung between them.
They were both already huffing from the
weight of it.
I mean, no harm done having an extra
secret weapon around, right?
Exactly, Hawthorne said, beaming.
He flapped his wings once and gazed
through the trees, his eyes going weirdly
still.
I'll just have a few of them follow us.
Willow, Sandu whispered.
Should we stop him?
I don't know.
Willow whispered back.
She furrowed her brow at the rustlings
and the leaves.
It feels wrong, but then I'm not even
sure I know what's right and wrong
anymore.
Queen Sequoia was always my moral
compass.
I thought she'd always do the right
thing.
And I wanted to be like her so much.
But what she was going to do to wasp.
And the fact that she lied to us about
it.
I don't know how to feel right now.
Mad?
Sandu suggested.
Really mad?
You're allowed to be angry about this
willow.
She brushed Willow's wing lightly.
I don't want to be mad, Willow
protested.
What good would that do?
If I let myself be really angry?
I might do something terrible, like yell
at Queen Sequoia.
Maybe she should be yelled at.
Sundew pointed out.
But how would that help?
Then she'd feel awful, and I'd feel
guilty, and we'd be distracted from more
important things.
The point is to make sure she knows she
did something wrong, so she won't do it
again.
And maybe she'll try harder to fix it.
I'm sure she already knows it was wrong
Willow said.
I'm not sure he does, Sundew said, nodding
toward Hawthorne.
He was walking at the front of the group
chatting with cricket.
A pair of snakes was slithering along
right by his talons, but he barely even
glanced down at them.
Getting angry will only make me feel
worse.
Willow said firmly.
But I am upset, and just really, really
sad.
She shook herself from head to tail.
That's what this is.
I'm sad.
Well, I am pleased for you that you're
that good at choose your own emotion
Sundew said.
I'm definitely mad.
And I can't just smush that into feeling
sad or something else instead, so you can
go eat chocolate or whatever being sad
leads to.
I'm going to yell at the queen.
Willow shot her a troubled look.
I hope you won't be too mean.
We need her on our side for the war
ahead.
I mean, I want her to keep listening to
us to you.
So I just hope you won't drive her away.
She still talks to Belladonna after all
this time, Sundew said, and she's a
queen.
She should be tough enough to handle it.
Their trip back to the village seemed
faster than their trip out, partly
because they were able to move much more
quickly through the den of vipers, and
partly because this time they went around
the other edge of the lake, which was
lined with sharp marsh reeds and cobra
lilies, but nothing that actually managed
to catch them.
They reached Queen Sequoia's tree palace
shortly after nightfall.
Sundew's Leafsby kept picking up strange
murmurs from the jungle around Willows
Village.
Trouble.
They'd whisper one moment, and then the
next.
All is well.
She wound her mind through the roots and
whispers, but she couldn't pin down what
they were feeling or worrying about.
All is well, all is well.
Dangerous coming.
All is well.
She shivered and pulled her mind back.
It didn't make sense, so she'd have to
ignore it for a while until it did.
Trees could be ridiculously maddening
sometimes.
Hawthorne had pulled his wings in close
and gone quiet as they entered the
perimeter of the village.
He kept looking up at the trees, perhaps
sensing the leaf wings had come out to
watch them pass by.
Sunday hadn't seen any sign of more
vipers beyond the 2 at his feet, but she
wondered if they were out there somewhere
too.
A small deadly army trailing along behind
their leader.
They flew up to the throne room and found
Hazel there, pacing in a circle around
tsunami, who was lying down with her eyes
closed and her front talons clasped.
If the sea wing was asleep.
She didn't look very peaceful.
Her brow was furrowed, and her tail
twitched furiously, as though she might
be lashing it inside her dream.
They landed as quietly as they could, and
Willow signaled.
What in the world?
to Hazel.
She said she could communicate with a
distant kingdom somehow, Hazel whispered
hurrying over to them.
I have no idea what she's doing.
Maybe all the dragons over there are
delusional.
Or magic.
Cricket breathed.
Where's your great grandmother?
Sundu asked.
She left with Belladonna and half the
village, Hazel said.
They're at the snarling river by now, I'm
sure.
She picked up a book from the throne
fiddled with it for a moment, then put it
back.
I haven't heard anything, hoping for a
messenger soon.
What did you find?
We found Hawthorne, Willow said
indicating the old dragon.
And he does have an antidote, but we need
to test it to make sure it works.
As quickly as possible.
Sundu agreed.
So we need a hive wing?
Hazel asked sharply.
She climbed onto the throne and tapped
the small gong hanging above it.
Then let's get one.
Three guards came swooping in from the
level above them.
Go to the snarling river, Hazel
commanded.
Find the queen and find out whether
Wasp's army is there yet.
If so, capture a hive wing on his or her
own and bring it.
She hesitated for a moment, her eyes
scanning the village out the window.
Bring it to the Hemlock Grove on the
banks of the Gullet River as fast as you
can.
I want to go too, Metal demanded.
She dropped the chest and flopped herself
loose from the loops of vines.
I want to abduct a hive wing.
I want to be where the fighting is.
You may go with them, Hazel said.
You can explain everything to the queen.
The guards bowed and flew off with
Nettle.
Their flashing scales quickly swallowed
by the darkness outside.
Hazel hopped down from the throne and
untied the vines around the chest so she
could look inside.
This is it?
She asked, looking up at Hawthorne.
Will this be enough?
It depends on how we give it to them, he
said.
Ideally, they would all eat a piece at
least this big.
He held up his claws to indicate a small
cube.
But it might work if we could get it into
their water supply.
Sundu shook her head.
We need a way to give the whole army the
antidote at once before a wasp realizes
what's happening.
Otherwise, she'll stop them from taking
it the moment she notices.
She frowned at the pile of roots.
She knew the jungle was enormous and
probably contained 100s of plans she'd
never encountered.
But she was still a little surprised that
the heart of salvation didn't look more
familiar.
Oh, Cricket said suddenly.
What if, would it work if we burn it, and
they breathe in the smoke?
Hawthorne scrunched up his snout. thinking
maybe.
We could set the whole army free that way
couldn't we?
Cricket adjusted her glasses and padded
bumblebee absentmindedly.
The dragonette had just woken up and was
trying to clamber out of the sling
babbling to herself.
I would think we'd need more than this.
Hazel said.
What if we plant a few of these and get
our most powerful leaf speakers to grow
them as quickly as possible, so we'll
have as much as we need.
Hawthorne reached past her and gently
closed the chest.
I'd wait to see if it works on dragons
first.
The heart of salvation is rather a pain
to uproot once it takes hold.
You wouldn't want to overrun your village
with it for nothing.
Keep a few aside for planting.
The rest should be enough for the army
and we can grow more for the rest of the
hives later.
Hazel lifted one eyebrow with a wooden
egg wrapped carefully in its sling across
his chest.
She opened her mouth to argue with them
but just then, an abrupt snort from
tsunami made them all jump.
The blue dragon let out a hiss.
And then grumbled, fine, but I'm still
head of school.
Yeah, tell him hugs to him too.
And no, the cows are not bigger and more
delicious over here.
Bye.
She snorted again, rolled over, and sat
up, blinking and rubbing her eyes.
Whew, she said.
I'll never get used to that.
What did you just do?
Cricket asked eagerly.
It's, I, Sandu noticed tsunami slipping
something into a pouch behind her front
leg, something she clearly wasn't
comfortable telling them about.
I was sort of talking to a few of my
friends back on the other continent.
Oh my goodness, how?
With distant kingdoms magic?
Cricket asked.
Yep.
Tsunami said, flicking her wings back.
She looked troubled.
Hard to explain.
Anyway, they didn't have any particularly
helpful ideas, but Moon seems really sure
that there must be a way for you to get
there.
She rubbed her forehead.
Something about a prophecy?
Have I mentioned that I hate prophecies?
She had a prophecy about us?
Cricket yelped.
What was it?
What's going to happen?
No, tsunami said, pointing a stern claw
at her.
Do not get excited.
Prophecies are terrible and annoying.
And this one sounds like a pile of wet
seaweed to me, because there's no way you
can all get over there.
Claire's side did it?
Willow pointed out.
She wasn't a sea wing, but she crossed
the ocean safely somehow.
They all looked back at tsunami.
I guess that's true, she said
doubtfully.
I have no idea how, though.
Maybe there's a clue in the book.
Willow said, or lean towards sundew.
Can we look at it?
Maybe there's something in there that
will tell us how she got here?
I read the whole thing, and did notice
anything like that, Sundew said, but she
pulled it out of its pouch and unwrapped
it anyway.
The faded blue cover and thin pages
looked even more ancient in the glow from
the firefly lamps.
You can check for yourself, but it
doesn't matter if you don't find
anything.
The leaf wings aren't going anywhere.
I'm staying right here and fighting for
our place on this continent, no matter
what WASP does.
And the antidote will work, Cricket
chimed in, so we won't have to run away
although, I mean, I'd love to see the
distant kingdom someday, if there is a
way to get across the ocean.
Hazel glanced out the window.
The sky was fully dark by now, and the
jungle was alive with the sounds of busy
insects, grumbling frogs and night
predators.
Let's get to the gullet river, and hope
the guards return soon, she said.
Tsunami, you study the book in the
meanwhile, Sundu, Cricket, Hawthorne, and
Willow, come with me.
She opened the chest and picked out 2
pieces of the heart of salvation route.
Not me?
Mandrake started.
I'll just...
Wait here then.
We'll be back soon.
Sundew said.
There was no one at the Hemlock Grove
when they arrived.
Hawthorn lay down on the grass, cradling
his wooden egg between his front talons
and one of his snakes slithered up to
coil around his neck.
Cricket watched Hazel pace between the
trees for a moment, and then she turned
to Hawthorn.
Hey, I was wondering something, she
said.
You, Sundew teased.
Really?
Cricket ignored her.
According to the legend of the hive, she
said.
The plant originally worked on everything
right?
Bees, ants, lions, birds, snakes
anything.
But it seems like Queen Wasp can only use
it on hive wings.
I mean, she must have tried injecting the
silk wings too, don't you think?
Maybe even a leaf wing at some point.
So why doesn't a mind control work on
other tribes?
That is an excellent question.
Hawthorne said approvingly.
Thank you, Cricket said with delight
fluttering her wings.
When I found the plant, it was barely
hanging on, he said, there was so little
left, cut off from sunlight, and slowly
wasting away.
I brought it into the sun.
I nursed it back to health.
And while I did, I used my leaf speak on
it.
I trained it, essentially.
I altered it so that it would only work
on hive wings.
Those would be the minds it was drawn
to.
I wasn't sure how well I'd succeeded, but
it seems I did well enough.
He looked horribly proud of himself.
Sunday wanted to scratch his face off.
How could he still be pleased about what
he did, after all this time, and all the
damage he'd caused.
Oh, Cricket said.
Her wings sank to the ground.
I Guess that's very impressive.
It is.
He assured her.
Not many dragons could do it.
It occurred to Sundoo that they should
tell Hazel the whole story.
The future queen had no idea what her
great grandmother and Hawthorne had done
but this wasn't the time.
She could hear muffled yells getting
closer and closer.
The leaf wing guards appeared in the
treetops, carrying a hive wing prisoner
who was blindfolded and tied up with
Strangler vines like an insect in a
cocoon.
They flew him down to the damp earth by
the riverside, and Nettle threw him at
Hazel's feet, grinning.
That was great, she said.
Sundu wasn't sure she'd ever seen nettles
so happy.
It was, quite frankly, very unsettling.
I want more missions like that.
But Hazel wasn't smiling.
She took a step back and gazed down at
the hive wing, then up at Nettle.
I guess this means wasp and the hive
wings are at the river already.
Oh, yes, we are.
The hive wing suddenly snapped.
His fangs glistened in the moonlight.
Even without seeing his pale white eyes
Sundu recognized the creepy extra layer
to his voice, Wasp was inside his mind
using his mouth to speak to them.
We're here, Leaf Wing, and this time
we'll make sure to finish what we
started.
You're all dead.
The hive wing twisted and writhed, trying
to drag the blindfold off his eyes.
Nettle put her front talons on his ears
and pinned him to the ground, ignoring
his flailing.
There were 1000s of hive wings on the
other side of the river, she said in a
low voice, and we could see more flying
in.
They're just standing there. row after
row of them, staring at the jungle with
creepy wide eyes.
It looks like they're waiting for
something.
The rest of the tribe?
Cricket guest.
It would take longer for the dragons from
mantis hive and cicada hive to get here.
Maybe she wants them all in place before
attacking.
Did you see Queen Sequoia?
Hazel asked softly.
Is Blue with her?
Cricket chimed in.
Yes, said Nettle.
She has the flame silk and the other
massively annoying silk wing.
They're working on...
Hazel cut her off by putting her talon
around nettle's snout.
She indicated the hive wing.
Even with his ears covered, they couldn't
risk Wasp overhearing Queen Sequoia's
plans.
Nettle scowled down at him and nodded.
Let's do this quickly, Sundu said.
She held out one talon for the heart of
salvation route.
Hazel used her claws to slice off a piece
about as big as an eyeball, which was an
image sundu immediately regretted
conjuring, and passed it to her.
Nettle lifted the prisoner's snout and
pride is jaw open.
He tried to bite her, but her grip was
strong.
Sundew stuffed the root into his mouth
and Nettle slammed it closed, holding it
shut until he swallowed.
Finally, she let go and stepped back.
That little worm cricket is here, isn't
she?
The dragon spat immediately, the one who
thinks she's so very clever, with her
pamphlets and graffiti and rumors.
Guess what, cricket?
I figured it out.
I know who your father is.
And he's mine, all mine, and I could kill
him in a heartbeat if I wanted to, or I
could let you meet him.
Would you like that?
Wouldn't you like to come back to wasp
hives, so I...
The hive wing trailed off.
His whole body went limp, and his head
lolled back onto the grass.
Sunder reached out and took one of
Willow's talent between hers.
She could feel Willow's heartbeat in her
palm.
For once, it was as fast as sundews.
Hazel turned to Hawthorn.
Does that mean it worked?
She asked.
I think...
Maybe?
he said.
The hive wing jerked once, twice, like a
fish pulled up on land.
He rolled on his side and gasped several
times, as if there wasn't enough air in
the world to breathe.
What is happening?
He croaked finally.
Where am I?
Why does everything smell wet?
Cricket motioned to the others back
crouched beside him, and removed his
blindfold.
From the shadows behind him, Sundew
couldn't see his face, but she could hear
the hitch in his voice.
What's your name?
Cricket asked him.
Inch worm?
He answered.
From vinegaroon hive?
Who are you?
Cricket, she said.
Cicada hive.
How do you feel?
He hesitated for a moment.
Weird?
Empty?
And I seem to be all tied up.
Do you know why you're here?
No, he blurted.
I don't even know where here is.
Try to think back, Cricket said.
You were going about your day in your
hive when suddenly the queen was in your
head.
What did she make you do?
Oh, he said.
Right.
The summons.
I was getting glow where I'm ready for
school.
Glow worm.
He tried to surge upright, but fell back
straining against the vines.
Is that your dragonette?
Cricket said touching his shoulder with
her wing.
We'll make sure she's safe.
Don't worry.
She was summoned too, he said, his voice
racked with worry.
Everyone was.
I think Wasp called the whole tribe.
Are we going to war?
My dragonette is out there.
She doesn't know how to fight.
I have to find her.
He began struggling again.
We are not going to war.
Cricket said.
We're going to stop it.
If I untie you, will you help us stop
it?
Us?
he said warily.
Me, and the leaf wings.
She said.
You'd have to promise you wouldn't hurt
any leaf wings.
I promise, he said.
I promise, I don't want to fight anyone.
I just want to get glow worm and go
home.
That's what we want too, Cricket said.
Sandu felt a jolt of familiar anger.
Is that what we want?
All the high wings get to go home and
keep living their happy lives as though
they didn't nearly destroy us.
Where's the punishment?
The justice.
She knew what Blue would say.
These hive wings are not the enemy.
Queen Wasp is the enemy.
Focus on her.
But the hive wings had benefited from
everything WASP did, and they never
lifted a claw to stop her.
They were part of the problem too.
They needed to learn a lesson and atone
not carry on as though nothing had
happened.
She didn't have a chance to say
anything.
Not that she had any idea what she would
say, before Cricket was standing in front
of Hazel, spreading her wings.
I think it worked. she whispered, pushing
up her glasses.
WASP is gone.
Hawthorne, you did it.
He's free.
Unless he's faking it, Nettle growled.
I don't think he could, Willow said.
And Wasp wouldn't miss a chance to be
scary to my face.
Cricket agreed.
If she was in there, she'd show herself.
Can we untie him?
Let's get the antidote on its way first
Hazel said, in her queenly voice.
Nettle, I assume you want to go back to
the front lines?
Yes.
Nettle hissed with glee.
I'll go too, Sundoo said.
She wanted to see for herself what they
were facing, and if they were able to use
the antidote.
She wanted to see it work.
She wanted to see Queen Wasp's reaction
when all her power evaporated.
Can I come?
Cricket asked.
To check on Blue?
Very well, said Hazel.
Willow and Hawthorne.
You can help me figure out how to get
this hive wing back to his dragonette.
The 3 of you.
Go collect the antidote and fly it to the
queen, as fast as you can.
We have no idea when WASP will decide
it's time to attack.
Sundu found herself starting to bow, and
felt ridiculous.
She had barely known Sequoia and Hazel
for a day, and yet she kept instinctively
treating them like real queens.
But then, out of the corner of her eye.
She caught Nettle doing the same thing.
Nettle of all dragons.
So maybe sundew wasn't that ridiculous
after all.
Willow grabbed one of her talons as
Sundude took a step back.
Please be careful, she said.
Remember, you promised me you'd never
die.
She choked out a half sob, half laugh.
You be careful too, Sundew said, wrapping
her wings around Willow and pulling her
clothes.
I'll see you really soon.
Like, immediately after we save the
world.
Willow laughed again, and then they let
go of each other, and Sundu lifted into
the air to follow Nettle and cricket.
The war was waiting for them.
And one small plant might be the only
thing that could stop it.
Part three.
Leaves in a Storm.
Chapter 18.
I know something, Crickets sang, nudging
Sundu's wing as they flew through the
village.
You know entirely too many things, Sundu
observed, but you are very welcome to
keep them all to yourself.
I know who your one true love is, Cricket
whispered.
It's not mandrake.
I knew it wasn't.
Yes, because I told you that, Sundew
snapped.
You're very clever.
Well, I just wanted to say I like her, and
I like the look on your face when she
talks to you.
I am not even remotely interested in what
you like, Sundu barked, landing on a
branch behind Nettle.
Cricket thumped down behind them, and
they all hurried along in silence for a
moment.
But thank you, Sundu finally grumbled.
I figured it out too, Nettle said
suddenly from the lead.
She swung her head around to glare at
sundew and cricket before moving on.
I don't understand falling for a sapwing
at all, or when that could have possibly
happened, but I also don't care.
And as far as I'm concerned, not having
you for a sister-in-law would be a
stellar development.
Well, not being related to you is one of
my favorite things about her, Sundu
growled back.
Nettle harumped and hopped to the next
tree.
A dewy pine leaned hopefully toward her
and she hissed fiercely at it.
Sorry, Cricket whispered to Sundu.
I didn't think she'd hear me.
I have very sharp ears, Nettle declared.
This conversation can be over now, Sundew
suggested.
She saw the tree palace up ahead and
darted out in front, swinging out of the
tree and flying down to it, inside.
Tsunami had been joined by the other Sea
Wing, Turtle, who looked much less queasy
than he had before.
They both had their phosphorescent scales
lit up, and were leaning over the book of
clear sight, studying each page.
Mandrake came hurrying over as Sundew
landed.
Did it work?
He asked.
As far as we can tell, she said.
She stepped into the loops of vines that
Nettle had abandoned next to the chest
and started tightening them around
herself.
We're taking this to Queen Sequoia now.
We should leave a few here, Cricket said
opening the chest and scooping out a
talon full of roots.
She glanced around for a moment, then
went over to pile them on top of the
throne.
What about you?
Sundu asked tsunami, as Nettle tied the
other side of the looped vines around her
shoulders.
Any luck?
The blue dragon sugar head.
Nothing much about Pyria so far, but Moon
said, a secret hides within their book.
She did?
Cricket asked.
Was that part of the prophecy?
Part of the gibberish, tsunami muttered.
The big secret in there is that the hive
wings have been lying about it for 100s
of years, Sundew pointed out.
That's got to be what that means.
That all the prophecies about uniting
under Queen Wasp were fake.
Yeah, probably, tsunami said with a
sigh.
Let's go, Nettle said, hopping from foot
to foot.
Mandrake, you too.
Not that you'll be useful, but you can at
least try to look like it.
Tsunami?
Cricket said hesitantly.
This is a lot to ask, but could I leave
Bumblebee here with you?
Uh, no.
Bumblebee objected. throwing her arms
around Cricket's neck.
No be, no be, no.
That does look like fun.
Tsunami said wryly.
Bumblebee.
Be reasonable.
Cricket yelled over her wails.
There might be a war where I'm going.
Dragons all stabbing each other.
Very bad things.
I don't want you near that.
I want you here and safe.
Stay be bad, Bumblebee argued.
You save.
I will be careful and I'll come back
soon.
I promise.
She disentangled Bumblebee and the sling
and handed them over to an extremely
skeptical looking tsunami.
Growl face.
The dragonette shouted.
Agna rah, rum, fum.
I'm actually very cool.
Tsunami pointed out to her.
I run a school for dragonettes on my
continent.
Bigger, less noisy ones though.
Bumblebee glowered at her, as though she
did not find this information endearing
whatsoever.
Bye, little bug.
Sendu called as they lifted off.
Be good.
Bumblebee shouted after her, which boded
ill for the rest of tsunami's night.
It turned out to be extremely annoying
and unwieldy, and exhausting, and
aggravating, to carry the antidote chest
with nettle on the other side of it.
Every time Sundew tried to go down, she
went up.
Every time sundew tried to hop over a
stream, Nettle would hop the other way at
the exact same time, and they'd both end
up in the water.
It was lucky that the chest was so sturdy
and thick, or it would have been covered
in dents and scratches in no time, or
possibly collapsed.
But it was also unlucky, because its
sturdiness made it really stupidly
heavy.
But finally, sometime close to midnight
sundew guest, they reached the border of
the jungle and Queen Sequoia's makeshift
camp, which took them a little while to
find.
Sundew had to use her leaf speak to track
down the area where the plants were
complaining the most about activity and
disruption.
A platform had been hastily set up high
in the canopy, balanced between a few
trees and lashed to their branches.
It was close enough to the thin uppermost
branches that the 3 moons could shine
through, illuminating most of the
encampment.
Sequoia stood in the middle of it, with
Belladonna, issuing orders and consulting
with a flow of incoming and outgoing
dragons.
As Sundew and Nettle struggled toward
them, Sundew saw a few warriors she knew
receive an order from Sequoia.
They looked at one another as though they
might not obey, but then Belladonna
barked something furiously, and they
backed away, nodding.
She also noticed the activity in the
trees around them, and sensed it down on
the jungle floor as well.
Her leaf speak told her that several
dragons were gathering plants that could
be used as offensive weapons, blister
bush seeds, and sandbox tree fruit in
particular.
She could hear dragons sending whispered
messages through the trees.
They lowered the chest to the platform
and landed beside it.
Sender realized that Blue and Sordail
were there too, huddled in a corner that
was nearly hidden by leaves, arguing in
hushed voices.
I'm not sure I've ever seen Blue argue
before, Sundew thought.
She wondered if he felt betrayed by her.
Would he still help them fight the hive
wings?
They'd need his help to burn the
antidote.
Sundu realized that she'd been taking his
flame silk for granted as a weapon they
could use.
But it's not our flame silk.
It's his.
As she watched, Cricket landed and ran
over to him, and his face lit with joy at
the side of her.
What is this?
Belladonna demanded, stalking up to the
chest.
Sundu waited until Queen Sequoia had
dismissed the dragon she was speaking
to.
The Queen turned toward her with a
slightly anxious, slightly disbelieving
look on her face.
This, sundew said, is the antidote to the
breath of evil.
She rested one talon on the lid.
Hawthorne was still alive.
He told us a very interesting version of
the events that led up to the tree wars
Your Majesty.
Queen Sequoia flicked her tail from side
to side, studying Sunday's face.
He really found an antidote.
She said quietly.
We think so, Sundu said, at the same time
as cricket blurted, yes.
It's called heart of salvation, Mandrake
added.
The queen let out a long breath.
Then we can finally atone for what we did
she said.
Sandu heard the echo of her own thoughts
like a stab in the heart.
She'd wanted the hive wings to atone.
She still wanted them to.
They were much worse than the leaf
wings.
But Hawthorne and Sequoia did terrible
things too.
The hive wings would be right to want
them to be punished, but they would be
wrong to want the same for the whole leaf
wing tribe.
So maybe, maybe I need to think about
that too.
Hawthorne, Sequoia, and Wasp.
I should be angry at them.
I can be furious at them.
I can fight wasp without hating the
entire hive wing tribe.
I can free the hive wings and spare their
lives without betraying my quest, because
WASP is the real enemy.
Wasp and her mind control.
She dragged the vines off her wings and
off the chest so she could throw it
open.
Here's what we need to do, she said.
We take these roots down to the snarling
river and build a bonfire with them, as
close to the hive wing army as we can
safely get.
Then we set it on fire, they breathe in
the smoke, and we cross all our claws
that this works.
She hesitated, then turned to Blue, who
had stepped forward to listen.
Which means we need flame silk, she said
if blue is willing to give us some.
If he's willing, Belladonis bat, who's
giving him a choice?
I am, Sundu said, frowning at her.
It's his choice.
He doesn't belong to us.
Any more than all the other flame silks
belong to Queen Wasp.
If we force him to do what we want, we'll
be just like her.
She turned back to Blue.
But I'm hoping you'll choose to help us
she said.
This isn't like burning a hive.
This should free the hive wings, like we
hoped.
Cricket leaned into his shoulder and
twined her tail around his.
Please?
She whispered.
Of course I will.
Blue said.
I'll fly down there and light it myself.
He looked up at Queen Sequoia.
But I want you to promise me.
You won't take any part of my fire to
hurt any dragons.
I don't want to find out in 3 days that
some piece of my flame soak was saved, and
then used to burn any more hives.
Belladonna hissed and lashed her tail
which a sundue guest meant that she'd
been planning on doing that exact thing.
I promise, said Queen Sequoia.
Belladonna?
The way she looked at Belladonna made it
clear that wasn't actually a question.
I promise too.
Belladonna said sulkily.
Then let's get to work, said the queen.
I'll have my soldiers build a pyre
tonight, under cover of darkness, while
the hive wings are still frozen out
there.
As soon as the sun rises blue.
I want you to fly down to set it aflame.
Why not right now?
Nettle asked.
Why wait for the sun?
Because I want to see their eyes, Sequoia
said.
I want to be sure it works.
With luck.
The queen will wait to make her move
until morning as well, although we should
be prepared to fire it at once if she
starts to do anything tonight.
Blue nodded, looking terrified.
I'll help build the bonfire, Sandy
offered.
No.
The queen reached one of her wings out to
sundew's shoulder.
I want you to rest.
Rest?
Sundu protested.
The night before war, or a not war
whatever happens, she amended, glancing
at cricket's face.
Yes, absolutely, said the Queen.
You've been traveling all day, and for
many days before this one.
You need to sleep, because 1st thing in
the morning, I want you to take some of
these roots and grow more heart of
salvation.
We need as much as we can get.
There are 1000s of hive wings out there.
Sandu hesitated, tempted to argue, but
exhaustion was beginning to set in, as
though her eyelids were stuck together
with sundew goop.
It had been a long day, along several
days.
It was also kind of a weird, nice feeling
to have someone notice and care.
She couldn't remember Belladonna ever
telling her she needed to sleep.
All right, but only for a little while.
She said.
She took a few roots from the chest and
tucked them into one of her pouches.
The rest were carried off by Sequoia's
soldiers, out through the canopy and down
to the battlefield.
Sundew felt strangely apprehensive
watching them fly away.
The trees were troubled, but they
couldn't tell her why, and it tangled up
her leaf speak, adding tendrils of worry
to every thought.
Is this really going to work?
What if something happens to the
antidote?
What if WASP figures out what we're up to
and manages to destroy it?
Or what if we free the hive wings from
her mind control, but they decide to
fight for her anyway?
Then there really would be war tomorrow, a
war where the dragons sundew grew up with
would all be out in front, with hive wing
weapons pointed at them.
Sundew had spent her whole life being
furious with the hive wings for trying to
wipe out her tribe, but she hadn't ever
quite felt the danger of what would
happen if they tried to do it again.
She'd been mad about dragons who died
half a century ago, but now she had to
picture her friends, her tribe mates, her
parents, as the targets, and suddenly she
understood, painfully and forcefully, what
Sequoia and Willow had felt, and why they
hadn't wanted to restart the war.
But we can still stop it, she hoped.
She prayed, as she climbed up to a
sheltered curve in the branches, and lay
down next to cricket and blue.
If the antidote works, please let it
work.
She closed her eyes and drifted into an
uneasy sleep.
Chapter 19.
Sundew woke before dawn, her heart
pounding.
She couldn't remember her dreams exactly
but she felt as though insects had been
crawling all over her, wasps, perhaps
1000s and 1000s of wasps with eyes
bathoms deep.
She slipped away from cricket and blue
who were still asleep, curled together
like intertwining vines.
Swordtail was sprawled on Blue's other
side, snoring lightly.
The tree branches shook as she climbed to
the top, swaying in the breeze.
Up here, she could smell the ocean.
She could hear the cries of seagulls and
birds of prey as they swooped by
overhead.
Away from the jostling noise of the
jungle plants, her leaf speak could
discern the faraway murmurs of Savannah
grasses.
But this morning there were other smells
other sounds.
This morning she could smell dragons.
She could hear 100s of talons shuffling.
She could sense the plants under their
feet being smothered struggling to
survive.
And from the very top of the tree, she
could see them, columns of hive wings
lined the plain on either side of the
snarling river, stretching to the horizon
orange and gold and black scales
diaphanous wings flickering, 8 dragon in
its place, an exact distance from every
other dragon, they looked too precisely
placed to be real, but they were real.
The hive wing prisoner had been right.
It seemed as though Wasp had summoned
every hive wing in the tribe for this.
She's hoping to wipe us out with one fell
swoop.
Sundu realized, she's going to throw
everything at us.
She wants to finish this today.
Finish us.
It's terrifying, isn't it?
Sundew turned to find mandrake perched on
another high branch nearby.
His eyes were tired, and she wondered
whether he'd slept as poorly as she had
or maybe not at all.
We'll stop them, she said.
We have to.
The sky was shading toward pale gray
streaked with pink.
The sun would slip over the horizon
behind sundew very soon.
If there's a chance we're all going to
die today.
Mandrake, she said.
I'm not going to marry you.
I know, he said. giving her a real smile
for once.
I've always known that.
Really?
she said, because it's not about you.
You're one of the few dragons I actually
like, but you're not Willow, and she's
the only dragon I want to marry.
I hope you do, he said.
I hope the antidote works.
I hope this whole horrible thing ends and
we all get to live happily ever after.
His smile faded as he returned his gaze
to the vast army below them.
Sundew squinted down at the river
searching for the bonfire pile.
It looked pitifully small from up here
especially next to all those 1000s of
hive wings.
Does that look like enough antidote to
you?
She asked him.
He shook his head, looking grim.
No, not even close.
It's not going to be enough.
The smoke might reach the 1st few rows of
dragons, but that will leave 1000s more
still behind them, still under wasps
control.
Thousands more, still coming for us.
Panic surged through her like a jolt of
toxin.
I'm going to make more, she said.
Come with me and help.
He nodded and followed her.
She scrambled down the tree until she
found an open gap in the branches, where
she could spread her wings and drop down
to the jungle floor.
It was still very dark down here, but
Sundu let her leaf speak reach down into
the soil and out through the root systems
tracing them along until she found water
a stream, a tributary of the snarling
river.
That would be the best place to grow more
heart of salvation, in the mud along the
banks, where the damp earth could help it
along.
She heard cracking branches overhead, and
looked up to see Cricket flailing her way
down, catching on every vine and cobweb
as she did.
Mandrake ducked out of the way as the
hive wing landed in an ungraceful
sprawl.
She hopped to her feet, shaking herself
off.
You don't have to come with us, Sundew
pointed out.
Sure I do, Cricket said.
I can help carry roots.
I can harvest them while you make more
grow.
Also, I really want to watch.
I didn't get nearly enough of a chance to
watch that choke cherry grow, and I
imagine it'll be really awesome.
I mean, scientifically speaking, I wish I
could make plants grow just by thinking
at them.
Well, it's slightly more complicated than
that, Sundu said.
But all right, come along.
They hurried through the jungle until
they reached the stream, which wound
between small pitcher plants and gurgled
over smooth stones.
Long, feathery ferns leaned over the
water, as if plotting how to steal it all
for themselves.
Sundew found a patch of dirt, dug a hole
and planted a piece of root in it.
It looked pale and ghostly against the
dark wet earth, like a grub that had
wiggled its way up from the depths of the
underground, or the haunted spirit of a
real plant.
She could still see patches of its white
skin winking through the dirt as she
covered it up, until finally, it was
completely buried.
Mandrake took another piece, and moved
farther upstream to do the same thing.
Cricket stayed beside Sundew, with her
tail wrapped around her talons, watching
curiously.
She wisely, and, surprisingly, kept quiet
as sundew dug her claws into the earth
and closed her eyes, summoning all the
power of her leaf speak.
Hello, little plant.
We need your help.
Hmm.
The plant murmured back softly.
You want to grow, Sundu told it.
Let me help you grow.
You can grow big and grand and wild.
With so many roots.
You won't need them all.
Grow wild.
Spread far.
The plant echoed, more or less.
Stretching its tendrils like a centipede
unwinding.
Grow far, spread wild.
There was some kind of block between
sundew and the plant.
She could reach it, but she couldn't wrap
herself all around it.
She could feel it growing, but she
couldn't latch on to its exact voice.
She felt as if she was hearing it
reflected off another surface.
It was hard to describe.
Like a sound just out of range that she
knew she'd recognize if she got a bit
closer.
Come forth, Sundu called.
Be here.
Let me see you.
The plant's response felt like rustling
in the back of her brain.
Yes, it whispered.
Coming, growing, spreading, taking.
And then suddenly, it was as loud as a
waterfall.
Yes, here and now it roared, as vines
shot from the earth and blasted across
the ground all around them.
Sundew recoiled.
Her leaf speak recognizing them before
her eyes did.
She stared in disbelief as the vines kept
growing, spreading, laughing, inside her
mind, red and green leaves unfurling
white flowers and evil eyed seeds
everywhere.
The antidote wasn't a new plant.
There was no heart of salvation.
She was looking at the breath of evil.
Chapter 20.
Mandrake, stop, she cried.
Too late, too late.
The plant hummed, spread, grow, far, wild
conquer, consume all mine.
The vines had stopped growing outward as
soon as sundew pulled back, but they were
already huge and covered the bank of the
stream.
Cricket was nearly caught in a tangle of
them, but she'd jumped into the air and
hovered above, her talons pressed to her
mouth and her eyes wide with shock.
Mandrake came stumbling back towards
sundew.
She could see that his root had grown as
well, not as vigorously as hers, but
enough vines had sprouted to show him
unmistakably what it was.
What is this?
Mandrake asked plaintively.
It looks just like the breath of evil.
Sundu, what is happening?
We were tricked, she said.
I think, I don't know.
Why would anyone?
But look at it.
The antidote is a lie.
Maybe not, Cricket stammered from above
them.
Maybe another piece of the plant could be
an antidote for the rest of.
No, it doesn't make sense.
Maybe Hawthorne got mixed up and gave us
the wrong thing?
No, said Sundew.
She felt frozen in place, as though the
plant had hypnotized her.
He knew what he was doing.
But I don't understand why.
She tried, tentatively, to reach out to
the plant again with her leaf speak.
Maybe if she understood it.
Maybe if she spoke to it, she could turn
it into an antidote.
Perhaps that was what Hawthorne had
done.
But she found nothing healing about this
plant.
It felt as sinister as the ones in the
den of vipers, far worse than the ones in
Wasp's greenhouse, and when she tried to
investigate it, it reached right back, a
sensation like freezing tentacles
plunging into her brain.
She closed herself off quickly.
We have to warn Queen Sequoia, she said.
She needs to know that burning the roots
won't help.
But Intworm, Cricket said, he was cured.
It worked on him.
I think perhaps it didn't, Sundu said.
She felt a new cold fear, like her skin
turning inside out.
They'd left inch worm with hazel and
willow.
If Wasp was still inside him.
If the antidote doesn't work, Blue is the
1st dragon they'll come for, Cricket said
in a panicked voice.
He'll be out there where everyone can see
him.
We'll go stop them, Sundu said, lifting
into the air.
Mandrake, stay here and destroy all these
vines.
I mean, really destroy them.
You can try, said a voice from the other
side of the stream.
But it won't make much difference.
We're spreading through the jungle as we
speak.
Hawthorne stood on the opposite riverbank
twitching pitcher plants away from
himself with his tail, beside him, with a
dragon bite viper coiled around her neck
was Willow.
Its fangs were bared, and Willow's deer
brown eyes were fixed on sundew, terrified
and defiant at the same time.
Sundu hissed and started forward, but
Hawthorne raised one claw and made a
patronizing, uh, uh, uh, sound.
She could kill him for that sound alone
but she was definitely going to kill him
for threatening Willow.
If you hurt her, Sundu growled.
If you dare.
I know, I know, he said.
You'll do something terrible and violent
to me, but it will be too late because
she'll be dead.
So how about you stay on your side of the
river?
Well, we have our little talk, and maybe
she'll survive this, more or less.
You too, little gnat.
And you, disposable leaf wing.
I can still see you.
Don't even think about sneaking away.
Sundew sank back down to the ground.
Cricket and mandrake did the same on
either side of her.
The moment they touched the earth.
The breath of evil vines slithered around
and around their talons, snarling them in
place so they couldn't move.
There, Hawthorne said.
After all, it would spoil everything if
you went to Warren Sequoia.
My whole brilliant plan, ruined by a trio
of idiots.
I think not.
What brilliant plan, Sandu asked.
So you tricked us into burning a pile of
roots.
Great work.
If you think that means Queen Sequoia
won't be prepared for wasp's attack
you're the idiot.
She'll be ready even when the bonfire
does nothing.
We're stronger than you think.
And so is this jungle.
Hawthorne chuckled.
Oh, I know how strong this jungle is.
It's been my home for 1000s of years
after all.
It came so close to killing me at last
after so many had failed.
But then Hawthorne came along and rescued
me.
Gormless, lovely dragon husk.
He's been so useful.
I think I'm going to keep him forever.
Or at least until his bones rot, and I
can't move him anymore.
Silence fell. chilling and horrible, like
a dragon trap, closing its jaws around
them.
Sundu couldn't breathe.
She couldn't think.
She could only stare into Willow's
frightened eyes.
Her pulse pounding.
How do I save you?
How do I save you from this?
What?
Mandrake said finally.
Is Hawthorne?
Aren't you Hawthorne?
Cricket asked.
He, he, said the dragon in front of
them.
A sneering sort of wheeze.
The outer bark is Hawthorn, yes.
All these years, he thought he was in
control.
He thought I was merely one of the voices
in his head.
His beautifully carved seed just
whispering back to him.
He took out the carving that Sandu had
thought was an egg.
But of course, it's supposed to be a
seed.
The breath of evil's seed.
Hawthorne cubbed the seed in his talons.
Such a clever scientist.
Left to test his experiments on himself
poor fellow.
Imagine what he might have figured out if
he'd had other test subjects.
Aren't I lucky he didn't?
The vines tightened around sundew's
talons.
WASP, she growled.
So you've been here, in our jungle this
whole time, you knew we were still
alive.
Hawthorn threw back his head and
laughed.
An awful slithering noise that sent cold
vibrations through sundew's leaf speak.
Wasp, really, he said, when he finally
caught his breath.
No, no, no.
She's a perfect ally.
All poison from her core out.
But in the end, she's my puppet too.
I let her do all her great evil things
because it pleases me.
But one day, she'll realize I've hollowed
out her brain, and she has no more
control than her lowliest worm of a
subject.
Then, who are you?
Cricket burst out.
Hawthorne's face went very still, his
eyes flickering white, green, white
green.
I am the rightful owner of this continent
he growled in a low voice.
It was mine.
All of it mine.
Every insect and blade of grass and grain
of sand.
I ruled it all.
And then you came, with your outsized
brains, and your clumsy crushing talons
and your fire, and you stole it from me.
All these 1000s of years.
I've waited to recapture my home and
destroy you all.
I abided my time, and planned my
vengeance.
Even trapped in the jungle, I knew I'd
find a way one day.
I had no idea how easy it would be in the
end.
You foolish, short sighted dragons.
You came looking for me.
You fed me to your enemies.
You let me spread and infect you, and
soon, every one of you will be no more
trouble than my obedient snakes here.
I will always be trouble.
Sandu said.
You can't control leaf wings, and you'll
never control me.
Or you.
She tried to say to Willow with her
eyes.
Yee, hee, Hawthorne said again.
His grin widening so far, it looked as
though his face might split in half.
You are pleasantly stupid.
You really haven't figured out the next
stage of my plan.
Let's see, how did you put it?
When the bonfire does nothing.
But of course, the bonfire does something
you splintery twig.
Cricket gasped, apparently guessing it
before Sundew did.
What?
What does it do?
Mandrake asked.
Well, Hawthorne did have very powerful
leaf speak, said the thing inside the
dragon facing them.
He almost managed to put a cage around
me.
He took advantage of one of my weak
little shoots, who would have done
anything to survive, and he really did
adapt to that branch of me to only work
on hive wings, aggravating monster.
He abruptly stabbed himself in the neck
then tortled as blood trickled down from
the wound.
I could work with it though.
It was a good start, but not what I
needed.
Not what I wanted.
I wanted everyone.
So once I was finally inside him, I had
him fix me.
All his little chains are gone.
And now, I will have what I want.
He stretched his wings and closed his
eyes. breathing deeply.
The fire has been lit, he murmured.
The smoke is rising.
They are breathing it in, and me along
with it.
All those brave leaf wings ready to
fight.
Oh, there's your mother's son do.
The queen will be mine soon.
It's too bad the chrysalis didn't make it
here in time.
But I will get to them eventually.
For now.
At least I have these 2 sweet little silk
wings to infect.
Blue, Cricket said softly, tears rolling
down her snout, and sword tail.
And Queen Sequoia, Nettle, Belladonna
Wolf's Bane, those poor dragons.
Thorn sharp rage surged through sundew.
She had never been so furious in her
life.
She felt like the vines around her should
erupt into flames, like she was a white
hot sun about to set the entire jungle on
fire.
She sank her claws into her rage, holding
it close and letting it build.
Her anger would get them out of this.
Her fury was a weapon, and she knew where
to point it now.
Next important question, said the thing
inside Hawthorne.
Which of you 4 should I infect first?
Chapter 21.
Calm now.
Hawthorne purred when nobody answered
him.
Make this easy on yourselves.
He eat a tiny piece over the root or one
of the seeds, and all your worries will
be gone.
Wouldn't you like that?
Who'll go first?
Sunday's eyes were locked with willows.
The viper's fangs were so close to
Willow's neck, no matter what sundew
tried, the moment she made a move, those
fangs would sink in, and Willow would be
lost.
Even if she could somehow kill Hawthorne
in an instant, which wasn't likely.
She wasn't sure that would stop the
viper.
As far as she could tell.
The thing controlling all the dragons was
also controlling the snakes.
So killing Hawthorne.
Even killing wasp might not be enough to
stop it.
Willow blinked once, twice, 3 times.
She slowly rolled her eyes down into the
left at the mud between her and
Hawthorne.
Then she looked back at sundew
meaningfully.
Wait, I have more questions first, Cricket
babbled.
Why aren't your eyes white, like the
dragons who are controlled by WASP, or
your voice, why isn't it all double
weird?
Like when WASP talks through another
dragon?
Sundew shifted her gaze to cricket, trying
to look as though she was listening, when
really, all her attention was focused on
her leaf speak.
She had to weave it past the creepy
shivering tangle of the breath of evil
burrowing through the earth around and
below it.
Her awareness slipped out of the nest of
vines and across the stream, tiptoeing
through the water wheels.
The earth between Willow and Hawthorne.
What had Willow seen there?
What did she think sundew could use?
The pitcher plants here were too small to
swallow a dragon, they had to content
themselves with insects, frogs, and
occasional small monkeys, but they were
still very smug about it.
Do you know what I ate today?
Well, do you know what I ate?
Self important?
Like all pitcher plants everywhere.
Even if sundew made them enormous, they
couldn't attack Hawthorne or the snake
for her.
They caught their prey by sitting there
with their gaping mouths open.
Sundew reached farther and found
mushrooms, water lilies, and arrowroot.
None of that would be helpful.
Wait.
There was a tiny sprout buried among the
pitcher plants.
Normally, it wouldn't survive another
moon cycle.
The self satisfied plants around it would
crowd it out of existence and steal all
its prey until it wasted away.
But sundew could save it, and maybe it
could save them in exchange.
She had to be precise though, and fast.
Hawthorne was explaining something about
cells and fungi to cricket, something
about the hosts or playthings of hosts
having the white eyes, but not the hosts
themselves.
She asked another, even more scientific
question, she was stalling, whether she
guessed what sundew was doing or not.
Hello, beautiful plant, Sundew whispered
with barely a shimmer of leaf speak.
She didn't want the thing to notice what
she was doing, and she wouldn't be
surprised if it could overhear leaf speak
conversations.
Oh, she realized suddenly, that's what I
was hearing in the trees.
They sensed the breath of evil.
They were warning one another of trouble
but Hawthorne was talking over them with
his own leaf speak, telling them all was
well.
He was confusing them and me.
The little plant said in a teeny, tiny
voice.
Would you like to be bigger?
Sundu asked, in the plant's own language
she sent it visions of sunshine pouring
through its leaves, all the pitcher
plants bowing before it. 1st choice of
all the prey that wandered through.
All the creatures it could eat.
Ooh, the plant murmured.
I can make you strong.
Sundu whispered, and big and tall.
If you will eat one thing for me.
She showed it the viper.
The slithering feel of it, the flickering
danger of it.
Its exact location in space relative to
where the sprout could be.
Ooh, would love to eat that, yes, give
please.
The plant said, more or less.
It's yours.
Take it.
Take it fast.
Now.
Sundew shoved all her power through the
systems connecting them, flooding the
little plant with strength.
A swarm of sundew tentacles erupted from
the earth near Hawthorne's feet, bright
red and green, like the daylight version
of the evil vines.
The sundew shot up and out, all its arms
growing as thick as anacondas in the
space of a heartbeat.
And one aimed straight and true for the
viper around Willow's neck.
The sticky droplets caught the snake's
tail, body, head, mouth all at once
yanking it up into the air.
The viper writhed furiously, snapping at
the tendrils of goo.
But the sundew sucked it in and rolled it
up fast, like a frog catching a fly on
its tongue.
Or a grasshopper.
How dare you?
Hawthorne roared.
Several of the tentacles had snared
around Hawthorne as well as they shot
from the ground, but Sundew could see
that he was fighting them off with his
own leaf speak.
A few of them were withdrawing, reaching
toward Willow instead as she backed
away.
No, Sundu commanded.
Eat that big one.
The infected one.
Leave the other.
I helped you.
Listen to me.
Loud, strong, loud, whine did the sundo
so loud hurts.
Even with her strength behind it, the
sundew would give up soon.
It was never meant to be an aggressive
predator.
She needed something else to fight
Hawthorne with, and the vines were
getting tighter and tighter around her.
Sundoo looked around frantically, and saw
with horror that one of the vines had
crawled up cricket's leg and wound around
her neck, squeezing.
Cricket was trying to bat it away with
her wings, but her breath was already
coming in choked gasps.
Maybe I don't need one more hive wing
Hawthorne growled, especially a deceitful
inquisitive one who won't shut up.
Let her go, Sundu shouted.
I'm the one who's all the trouble.
Fight me, not her.
I know you are, the thing said, but you
will be useful to me.
I'm going to use your leaf speak to
retake my continent between you and
Hawthorne, and I suppose this feeble worm
over here, he added, indicating
Mandrake.
We can spread across all of Pentala in a
matter of days.
I don't think so.
Willow said from above him.
Hawthorne started to look up, but he was
too slow to see the thorn, as long as a
dragon's tail in her talons, too slow, and
still too tangled in the sun do to escape
or move, or fight her off.
The sharp end of the thorn slammed into
the base of his neck.
And he fell, killed instantly, as all the
breath of evil vines screamed with fury.
Chapter 22.
Willow let go of the thorn and lifted
herself up, her wings beating as she
pressed her talons to her face.
Willow, Sandu cried.
Get to cricket.
The vines were seething with rage and
confusion.
As far as sundews leaf speak could gather
they were bewildered by the sudden loss
of Hawthorne, like arms that had been cut
off an octopus, but still grabbed for
prey.
They'd lost their brain for a moment, but
they were still deadly, and she was sure
the brain was still out there, even with
Hawthorne dead.
Willow snatched a branch from the ground
and flew to cricket, who looked close to
passing out.
Don't land, Sundew warned, or it might
get you too.
Willow nodded, hovering over the massive
vines.
She snapped the branch in half and
stabbed the sharp splintery end into the
vine near Cricket's neck.
Sundu could hear that tendril hissing
bleating to the others that it was
wounded.
But the other vines couldn't help.
The plant's voice was still loud, but the
power to hold the dragon's captive was
fading.
Sundew felt the bonds around her talons
slacken and fall.
Cricket gasped for breath as the one
around her neck dropped away.
The moment the vines were loose enough
the 3 dragons all threw themselves aloft
out of reach in case they moved again.
Mandrake took off across the stream and
into the trees, and the other 3 followed
him high up into the branches of a giant
baobab.
Sundew through her wings around Willow as
soon as they landed.
They held each other for a long moment
without speaking, their necks curved
around each other.
Their hearts beating as fast as rain in a
thunderstorm.
Why did the vines let go?
Cricket asked in a shaky voice.
I thought there was something out there
controlling Hawthorne, and the snakes, and
the vines too.
Maybe it's dead, Mandrake said
hopefully.
Sundu let go of Willow reluctantly and
shook her head.
No.
Willow killed one of its heads, but it's
got more than one.
It still has WASP, Willow agreed.
They all fell silent, thinking of the
other dragons it might have by now.
The dragons near the smoke.
Sundew pressed one of Willow's talons
between hers.
That was a pretty important head, though.
I think the thing was using Hawthorne's
leaf speak to make the vines attack us.
Without his leaf speak to control them
the vines can't move any more than
ordinary plants can.
What do we do now?
Cricket asked.
We fly to the border and try to save our
tribe, Sundu said, and our friends.
She lashed her tail.
We fight that thing, and kill it exactly
the way Willow did.
I don't know about you, but I'm ready to
kill it a lot.
Wait, Willow said. pulling sundew's
talons toward her.
No, that's exactly what we shouldn't do.
What?
Sundew flared her wings.
We have to.
We have to go now.
I really want to destroy some things.
The 4 of us, against the entire hive wing
tribe, Queen Wasp, all the best leaf wing
fighters, and our friends, Willow said.
We don't even know what to destroy.
She is right.
Cricket said.
I'm all for killing Queen Wasp, but if
that thing can be in any dragon.
What are we supposed to do?
Kill everyone?
We're not doing that, and you know it
sundo.
She did know it.
Even if there was a way to kill all the
hive wings, she didn't think she could
after all.
Not now that she knew hive wings she
cared about, or now that she'd learned
the truth behind all of this, and what
the leaf wings had done to them.
And especially not now that she'd heard
the voice of their true enemy.
And, of course, she could never hurt Blue
or Queen Sequoia, or Swordtail, or even
Belladonna, who usually made her madder
than anyone.
If they were all lost to the thing, and
she felt grimly certain they were, there
would just have to be another way to save
them.
Fine, yes, but we still have to go see
what's happening.
We have to fight, she argued.
We will fight, Willow said.
We'll use this rage, I promise.
We have to start by using it to save
everyone else.
I want to go to Blue more than anyone
Cricket said.
But I also need to make sure this doesn't
happen to bumblebee.
Or Hazel, Willow agreed.
We need to protect the dragons who are
left, so we have someone to fight with
us.
Sundew dug her claws into the branch and
felt the tree wince.
Sorry.
She flickered through her leaf beak
sending a filament of comfort out to
smooth over the scratched bark.
All right.
All right, she said.
Let's go.
They sped through the trees as fast as
they could move, keeping to the higher
branches, where there was more room to
fly, at least sometimes.
Sundew's village was 1st, closer to the
snarling river.
Sundir reached out to the dome as they
arrived, and moved the plants to make a
hole near the top.
They hurtled through, startling all the
dragons below them.
It took several moments of confusion
hissing, yelling, and threats before the
villagers realized that their savior's
sundew was one of the attacking dragons.
That cricket was their erstwhile hive
wing prisoner, and that they weren't an
advance party of invaders from Queen
Wasp.
But they are coming, Sundu said, we have
to fall back to the other, to the sapwing
village and regroup with the dragons
there.
Fall back?
Cobra Lily objected.
Are you saying we lost already?
Is Belladonna dead?
Several voices asked in alarm.
Not exactly, but she's lost to us right
now.
Sundu said.
I can explain everything, but I'd rather
do it once to everyone, and I'd rather do
it after we get all our dragonettes out
of here.
Leaf wings don't run away. someone
shouted.
We stand and fight.
We bear our fangs and raise our claws and
and end up as mind controlled zombies
just like the hive wings.
Sundew snapped.
Don't be idiots.
This isn't a normal threat.
We have to find an unnormal way to fight
it, and we need all the dragons we can
gather, so we get to safety 1st, then
make a plan.
I'll round up the dragonettes.
Cobra Lily said unexpectedly.
She loped gracefully off to the nursery
area, and several other dragons followed
her.
Several more stayed to keep arguing with
Sundoo, but she ignored them and flew to
the outer wall of the dome, the same spot
where she used to sneak out to meet
Willow.
She rested one talon on the woven
branches and nudged them apart, hoping
they felt her love for them as she did.
She loved all the plants that made up
this dome, which she'd built to protect
her tribe.
She hated to leave it.
She hated to imagine the breath of evil
slithering over it, stealing its light
and smothering it.
Dragons began climbing out through the
hole.
She tried to count them all, but lost
track around 50.
She guessed about a 3rd of the village
was here.
Most of them probably planning to be
called up as the next wave of soldiers.
A lot of them were carrying weapons of
some sort.
Many of them had pouches like hers slung
around them, hopefully full of useful
deadly things.
She wished she had time to refill her own
pouches, but she'd have to do that later
when all the dragons were somewhere
safer.
They moved a bit slower now, hampered by
their numbers, and the slowest among them
including 2 dragonettes who couldn't fly
yet, one elder who hadn't left the
village in years, and 3 limping dragons
who'd been recently wounded by various
jungle dangers.
Do you think WASP in the army are right
behind us?
Mandrake worried, pacing beside Sundew?
How soon could they get here?
I'm surprised we haven't seen anyone
yet.
Willow admitted in a low voice.
I would have thought the, the other mind
would have sent something to chase us
down as soon as Hawthorne died.
Maybe the smoke didn't reach all the leaf
wings, and they were giving it a fight.
Sundew guest, feeling proud of them, and
horribly worried for them at the same
time.
Also, it doesn't know where to go, Cricket
said.
What?
Willow tilted her head.
When Wasp takes over a dragon, she
doesn't get his memories and thoughts and
knowledge, Cricket said.
The other mind might have stolen our
friends, but it doesn't know everything
they know.
It wouldn't know the way to Sundew's
village.
But it will know the way to mine, Willow
said, because it was there inside
Hawthorne.
That's true, Cricket said, although it
might have trouble remembering the way
since it didn't come from the border
before, and without Hawthorne's leaf
speak, it won't be able to clear sundews
and dragon traps out of its way, like
sundew is doing for us right now.
Sundu was surprised that she'd noticed.
She was doing it almost automatically
sending her leaf speak out ahead of the
group to check for dangers.
So, when we met Hawthorne in the den of
vipers, Mandrake said slowly, were we
talking to the real Hawthorne, or the
thing inside him?
It seems like it had all of Hawthorne's
memories.
I think it was the real Hawthorne, cricket
said.
But he's spent the last 50 years being
manipulated by that voice in his head.
He might not have known what it was going
to do.
Maybe he didn't even know the antidote
wasn't real.
But he was doing what it wanted him to do
even when it wasn't controlling him.
Sundew shuddered.
Imagine spending 50 years alone, with no
one but an evil voice to talk to.
Perhaps Hawthorne had been more than
adequately punished after all.
Do we need to talk about what it is?
Mandrake asked.
What's using the plant to control
everyone?
And is it the same dragon who used it all
those 1000s of years ago in the legend of
the hive?
Cricket asked.
If so, where is he?
And why hasn't he come out in all these
years?
Or is it a group of dragons, and are they
hiding somewhere?
Sundew looked over at Willow.
And she saw from Willow's face that she
had come to the same conclusion as
sundew.
I think it's not a dragon.
Sundu said slowly.
I think it's the plant itself.
Willow nodded.
Cricket blinked at her.
The planned?
But how?
That's plants don't have a consciousness
or a voice, or make sinister evil plans?
Some of them do, actually, Sundew said, I
can vouch for that.
They don't usually have voices like ours
and I'm guessing this one didn't until
dragons came along and did adapted to use
us.
Yeesh.
Mandrake said, stepping carefully over a
fallen branch, and eyeing it as though it
might suddenly leap up to attack him.
It's just a guess, Willow added.
We need to find out more so we can stop
it.
It was late morning when they reached the
other leaf wing camp.
Sundew had seen the guards patrolling in
the trees, watching them arrive, but
nobody came out to stop them.
We'll have to warn them that not all leaf
wings can be trusted anymore.
She thought with a shiver, now that
anyone could have the enemy lurking
inside them.
They left the dragons from Sundu's
village, gathered in a huddle in the
biggest clearing, glaring up at the
curious dragons around them.
Bumblebee came galloping across the
throne room when cricket and sundew
landed, her wings flopping to either side
of her.
To sundew's surprise, she beelined
straight for sundew and bonked into her
feet, bouncing and reaching to be picked
up.
Hey, little bug, Sundew said, lifting
her.
The dragonette's yellow and black stripes
seemed cuter than they had the day before
and her snout was warm as she snuggled
into Sundew's neck.
Sundew found herself feeling weirdly glad
that they'd come back instead of going to
fight.
Saving bumblebee from the other mind.
That would be worth it.
What has happened to me?
Tsunami and Turtle were the only other
ones there, both of them still leaning
over the book of Clearsight.
Any luck?
Willow asked them.
Tsunami shook her head.
Not yet.
I must admit, I like this clear side a
bit better than I did before, though.
Why did you ever not like her?
Cricket asked, obviously shocked.
Because I thought she was an idiot who
nearly let her boyfriend destroy the
world, tsunami said.
Although, to be fair, I guess so did we.
What?
Willow asked.
Long story. tsunami said.
They turned as Hazel swept into the room
with a few leaf wing guards behind her.
Where's Inchworm?
Sundu asked, if he was still here, in the
village, with wasp inside him.
I had my guards take him back to the
snarling river, Hazel said.
Why, what happened?
Where's the Queen?
Did the antidote work?
Willow told her the whole story, as
quickly and briefly as she could.
By the end of it, Hazel was looking as
shattered as Sundew felt.
So you think this other mind got
everyone?
she asked.
I think we have to assume so, Sundu
answered.
Even if the smoke didn't reach all the
leaf wings, all it needed was Queen
Sequoia.
Once it had her, it could convince
everyone else to take the antidote, and
no one would know that wasn't a normal
order from our queen.
So, we have to get everyone and hide
somewhere, Hazel said, rubbing her
forehead.
She turned to the guards and put on her
queen voice.
Gather the entire tribe.
Tell them we're using the evacuation plan
and moving out before noon.
Pack lightly, if at all.
Bring weapons.
Try not to panic the dragonettes.
Tell them, tell them all is not lost.
If we move swiftly, make sure they know
we can still save our queen and our
friends, and that I'll tell them more
once we reach safety.
But where is that?
Willow asked, as the guards nodded and
flew away.
We can keep retreating farther into the
jungle, but eventually we'll hit the
ocean.
So then we cross it, Cricket said.
I still think we have to get to the
distant kingdoms.
That's our only hope.
How?
tsunami said, slamming the book of clear
sight shut.
This thing is no use.
Turtle and I can't swim 100s of you
across.
Let me see that book, Hazel said.
Turtle brought it over to her, and she
flipped through it, brushing her claws
across the pages.
Sundew tried to think.
Maybe we could build giant floating
platforms, she thought, and pile everyone
onto them, and take turns pulling them
across the ocean.
She had a notion, although she wasn't
sure where it had come from that their
earliest ancestors had arrived here that
way, more or less.
But we don't have time to build platforms
big enough for all the remaining leaf
wings.
Maybe we do.
Maybe we can buy ourselves time.
If I go back and fight, with Cobra Lily
and some of the others, while everyone
else starts building.
This book feels weird, Hazel said in her
regular voice, turning it over and
running one talon over the back.
I can't say I approve of whoever
bounded.
Willow cracked a smile for the 1st time
all day.
Trust you to care about the book binding
of the ancient magical sacred text, she
said.
Well, look at how the bat cover is
thicker than the front cover.
That's just messy.
The end pages are sewn down with these
perfect little stitches.
It looks like gold thread, but maybe it's
flame silk.
The kind that doesn't burn.
So someone put all this effort into
perfectly sewing down the end papers
around the edges, but left the middle all
lumpy.
She stared at the inside back cover for a
moment.
Hazel.
What are you doing?
Cricket gasped, as the leaf wing sliced a
long slit around the edges of the last
end paper?
You're destroying the book.
But Hazel wasn't listening.
She reached 2 claws between the paper and
the leather, and carefully, delicately
slid out the folded page that was hidden
inside.
It felt as if the whole world was holding
its breath.
Sundew wasn't sure why this felt so
important.
It would probably be something like the
rest of the book, a prophecy about
something that happened centuries ago, or
another sentimental letter about being
nice to one another.
And yet, even her scales prickled with
anticipation as Hazel carefully unfolded
the secret note.
It's a map.
She said wonderingly.
Chapter 23.
Hazel spread out the map on the throne
and they all crowded around to look at
it.
The ink was faded, but still legible.
Sundew stared at the odd shapes, and
recognized the peninsulas that jutted
into Dragonfly Bay.
Willow leaned against her shoulder, her
scales warm and smooth.
That must be the distant kingdoms, Cricket
said, pointing to the coastline on the
far right hand edge of the map.
Yes, tsunami agreed.
That's the ice kingdom up here, the
kingdom of sand all along here.
And this is the eastern coast of Pantala
Hazel said, pointing to the coastline on
the left.
Even in a one page drawing, the distance
between the 2 continents looked immense
uncrossable.
Sundew's heart sank.
So these dots in between, Turtle said
could those be islands?
Yes, Cricket cried, making them all
jump.
That's it.
They're islands.
Look.
Clearsight drew little arrows from one to
the next.
Start here.
Then fly here, then here, next.
Her claw hovered above the map as she
pointed out the route.
That's how she got to Penthala, Willow
said wonderingly.
She must have used her future site to see
which direction the nearest island was, so
she could rest between flights.
That's amazing.
And then she wrote it all out, so someone
could follow the islands back across the
ocean one day.
Hazel's face was aglow with excitement, or
a whole tribe of someone's, this is what
we need to get to the distant kingdoms.
Oh, wow.
Cricket said.
We are going.
We're really going?
She looked out of the trees.
And Sundu could guess what she was
feeling.
On the one talon, the distant kingdoms
and bumblebee's safety, on the other.
Blue.
If that were willow trapped by the other
mind, Sundu wasn't sure she'd be able to
fly away, no matter what the stakes
were.
Yes, we're going, all of us, right now
Hazel said.
Oh.
Everyone, tsunami said, sounding slightly
alarmed.
I mean, right, yes, of course.
Everyone, I'll just come home with a
whole other tribe of dragons.
Make that too, said a voice behind them.
Sundu's heart nearly flew out of her
chest before she spun around and saw that
the speaker was IO.
The tall purple silk wing glided into the
throne room with a few other silk wings
behind her.
Sundu recognized cinnabar from the jewel
hive chrysalis, who waved at her and
cricket.
Oh, tsunami said.
I mean, sure, what difference does 7 more
silk wings make?
There are about 200 more of us at the
mouth of the Gullet River, Io said.
I thought we'd sneak in the back way to
join you, but it sounds like we're too
late. 200 tsunami said faintly. 200
silkwings came to help us?
Hazel said.
Sorry, I only made it to Yellow Jacket
Hive, Wasp Hive, and Jewel Hive, Io
said.
I didn't have time to get to the others
but I can round up more if I go back
now.
The chrysalis is bigger than anyone
thinks.
200, Willow said to Sundo, her eyes
shining.
I told you they were worth saving.
We found a way to the distant kingdoms
Hazel said to Io.
We need to go before Wasp and her army
get here.
Are we going to fight them?
One of the silk wings asked nervously.
We will, but not today, Hazel said.
We're not ready.
Wasp can infect leaf wings and silk wings
now.
If we stay to try to fight.
We could all end up under her control
with no chance of ever fighting back.
IO flared her wings and growled.
She can control silk wings.
Then I have to go warn the chrysalis.
We need to get everyone out of the
hives.
Hazel hesitated, then looked at Willow, as
though she was hoping to find a plan in
Willow's expression.
What's wrong?
Cricket asked.
I was right.
Someone needs to stay behind to gather
the rest of the silk wings and bring them
over the ocean too.
Sundu realized what Willow and Hazel had
figured out.
The problem, she said, is that we'd have
to leave them a copy of the map.
And if there's a copy left on this
continent, It could fall into the other
mind's talons, Willow finished, or
tendrils or whatever.
Oh, Cricket said, her wings starting to
droop.
Hey, no, IO said loudly.
Come on, there's no way we're flying to
safety and leaving 100s of silk wings to
be zombified.
Could you seriously abandon them all like
that?
Seriously, when we could save them?
But it puts our whole escape at risk
Hazel pointed out.
If we leave right now with the map, WASP
and the other mind won't be able to
follow, we'd be completely safe over
there, but if we leave a copy of the map
they could find it and come after us, they
would come after us.
Also, by the way, there are some other
dragons over there, tsunami said in a
rush, who might not be super excited
about you all arriving, and PS, also
would definitely not like you to be
followed by a creepy hive brain army.
They won't get the map, Io said
fiercely.
I'll hide it somewhere safe, so even if
they catch me and take over my mind
they'll never find it.
You have to let me save the silk wings.
Look, if WASP gets them, it'll double the
size of her army, you don't want that
right?
So this is practical.
And also, obviously, the right thing to
do.
I mean, really.
Hazel sighed and rubbed a spot over her
eyes.
I wish great grandmother were here to
tell me what to do.
She is not, Sundew said, which means
you're the queen for now.
Hazel gave her a wry half smile.
Unless Belladonna is right, and it should
be you.
No thanks.
Sundew shook her head.
You're the exact right queen for us.
You have the voice and everything.
I do.
I've been practicing it.
Hazel agreed.
She lifted her chin and turned to IO.
Her entire posture becoming majestic and
imposing.
Very well, we'll make you a copy, and
you'll go save the silk wings.
I can make the copy.
Total volunteered.
He fiddled with his claws when everyone
looked at him.
I, um, I have excellent penmanship.
Do that, Hazel said, producing a chief of
bookmaking paper from a hollow behind the
throne.
Just one copy, and make it perfect.
Io, decide who's going with you.
Me, Cinnabar said immediately.
Um, Sundu interjected.
One small thing.
If you happen to run into 3 leaf wings
out there, please bring them with you.
Their names are Bryony, Pokweed, and
Hemlock.
Hemlock, Willow said.
Your father?
Sundu nodded.
They weren't exactly close, she and her
father.
He was usually too busy following
Belladonna's orders, and he was terrible
with words, but he was still her father
and she was leaving him here.
She had no idea where he might be or how
to get him a message.
She just had to hope IO found him before
the other mind did.
Hazel was about to issue another order
but stopped as they all heard crashing
from overhead.
Sundew felt all her muscles tense as she
looked up.
They couldn't have reached us this
quickly.
They can't be here already.
Bumblebee squeaked, and Sundu realized
she'd tightened her arms around her.
The dragonette squirmed out of her grasp
and clambered onto Cricket's back
instead.
But it wasn't a hive wing who came
hurtling pell mell through the trees.
It was one of Hazel's leaf wing guards.
He catapulted to a stop in the center of
the throne room, gasping for air.
Are they here?
Hazel asked.
No, he said, shaking his head.
But something else is happening.
They've set the jungle on fire.
Oh, no, Sandu thought.
She opened out her leaf speak, and had to
slam it closed almost immediately.
The shrieking trees filled her head with
rage and sorrow.
She couldn't bear the entire jungle's
panic in there along with her own.
She clenched her talons into fists.
The other mind couldn't win.
She couldn't run away and let it think it
won.
Get everyone to the coast.
Hazel ordered the guard.
We'll gather on the north shore of the
mouth of the Gullet River.
Use the evacuation plan.
Everyone was assigned to a trio, and all
the dragonettes and elders have someone
responsible for them.
Tell them to go right now.
He flew off, and she spun toward turtle.
Draw faster, dragon from across the sea.
Our dragons don't have an evacuation
plan.
Mandrake interjected.
He saw the look on Hazel's face and
stammered, but we can make one right
now.
Sundu grabbed his shoulders.
You can organize them.
You'll be great at this, mandrake.
It's just like sorting the insect
collection.
Yes, he said, his face brightening.
I am good at that.
So go sort leaf wings, she said.
Make sure they know where they're going
or have someone to follow.
He sprang away, leaping from the edge of
the platform.
Sundew turned and found Willow watching
her, standing only a wing length away
with a worried look on her face.
Beyond them, the other dragons had all
leaped into motion, flurrying about as
turtle bent over the throne, drawing the
copy of the map.
Why aren't you going to organize your
tribe?
Willow asked.
Because he'll be better at it, Sundew
said.
Willow narrowed her eyes.
You're their natural leader.
They should get used to following Queen
Hazel's orders anyway, Sundu pointed
out.
Sundo.
Willow hesitated, then took a step closer
spreading her wings.
Sundew spread hers as well, until the
edges brushed together, encircling them
in a small green bubble of quiet.
Please don't do whatever you're thinking
Willow whispered.
I can't run away, Sundu protested.
I am so angry, Willow.
I want to go set all of them on fire.
I want to set everyone in the world on
fire, and drip poisonous sap on their
heads, and pull out each of their claws
and then stab them in their faces, and
then set them on fire again.
I know, Willow said.
So do I. That caught sundew off guard.
You do?
Yes, Willow said.
They said our trees on fire.
The only trees we have left.
They stole my queen, and that, that thing
was going to use your leaf speak to
devour all of Pentala.
When it said that, I felt everything
you're feeling, son do.
I never let myself get mad like that
before.
And your anger helped you save us, Sundew
said, with the thorn.
Right, Willow said.
Yes, fine.
You can make thee, I told you so, face
but I'm going to make it right back at
you.
You're right that you should be mad.
But I'm right, that you should focus on
who deserves your anger and when to
fight.
They all deserve my anger, Sundew said
her voice rising.
You know they don't.
There's a monster inside them.
There's a monster leading them.
If you scatter your anger around like
dandelion seeds.
You'll hurt everyone. tire yourself out
and end up with a bunch of indignant
dandelions.
But if you summon it all together, and
aim for the monsters, you'll win.
I know you will, because your sundew, my
forever dragon.
Sundew's eyes filled with tears, and she
covered them with her talons.
That's not fair.
You're turning me into you.
Look at my stupid leaking face.
I think you mean, ah, you're my forever
dragon too, Willow, Willow said, in a
rather terrible imitation of Sundoo's
voice.
You know you are, twigs for brains.
You're like, really good at this romance
thing, Willow observed.
Sundu laughed around her tears and
thought, how can I be this furious and
this sad, and this terrified, and this
full of love, all at the same time?
Wait, I have one more really excellent
point, Willow said.
If you go tearing off to fight the thing
right now, fueled by super rage.
It will 100% gobble up your brain, and
then it'll have Pentala's most powerful
leaf speak.
Without Hawthorne, that plant can only
grow at whatever speed it normally grows
at.
Probably pretty fast, sundew guest, like
a weed.
But nowhere near as fast as it could grow
if it had Hawthorne.
Or you.
So you need to get far away from it more
than anyone, if we want a chance of
saving this continent when we come back.
Sundu sighed and leaned into her.
All right.
You're right.
As usual, Willow, Willow added, in her
sundew voice, smiling through her tears.
When we come back.
Sundew kept those words close to her
heart, as they flew to the coast, as they
gathered the bedraggled remnants of their
tribes, as they looked west, to the line
of fire that rose toward the sunset, and
then east, over the Beatle Dark Ocean
into apparent nothingness.
She repeated them to herself as they all
lifted into the sky, following Queen
Hazel's southeast to the 1st island on
Clearsight's map.
We are coming back.
We'll get everyone to safety. figure out
how to stop the other mind.
Gather some allies.
Sundu looked over her shoulder at the
continent that was vanishing into the
distance and the dusk.
And then, we'll be back to deal with
you.
Epilogue.
The white dragon paced furiously over the
snow dusted grass, the sound of frozen
blades cracking under her talons, carried
across the wide open tundra.
Draboa sighed and wheeled down toward
her.
She couldn't keep hiding in the clouds
forever.
Each moment she delayed, would only make
the young ice wing queen more hostile.
She landed on claws that were instantly
freezing, even though she'd been alive
for so long, she'd never gotten used to
cold temperatures, her sand winged blood
wanted to be out in the desert, rolling
in warm sand.
Finally, Queen Snowfall shouted, bounding
over, I don't have time to wait around
forever.
I have an entire kingdom to run.
Sorry, Treboa said.
She inclined her head as politely as she
could without actually bowing.
Queen Glacier usually arrived after I
did.
Well, Snowfall dug her claws into the
ground, scowling, her wings gave a little
tremor.
Treboa had noticed that happen before
whenever she mentioned Snowfall's late
mother.
It made her think maybe there was a heart
under Snowfall's icy exterior after all
one that mourned for glacier, but there
weren't many other signs of it.
I guess I'm more punctual than she is
snowfall blurted, so you'll have to be
too.
I will try, Jerboa said, inclining her
head again.
Have you thought about what I asked?
The ice wing queen began pacing again.
Before Turboa could answer, she
interrupted herself.
Well, I've changed my mind.
I need something else instead.
Turboa arched one eyebrow.
Oh.
The Great Ice Cliff, Snowfall said, it's
completely stupid.
I've always thought so, Treboa agreed.
It protects our southern border from, I
don't know, invading sand wings.
If they were dumb enough to try that
Snowfall said.
I've only seen its animus magic work
once.
Shooting ice spears at any dragon who
crosses the border that isn't an ice wing
Treboa said.
That's why we meet on this side of it.
Snowfall rolled our eyes at the
obviousness of this observation.
But here's the problem.
Maybe most dragons would try to attack
that way overland, and so we'd be
protected.
But what if Dark Stalker comes back, or
another dragon like him comes along.
And they try coming at us over the water
instead.
What if they fly around and come in our
northern border or east or west?
Jerboa's side.
It's too cold for anyone to do that, she
said.
The truth is, other tribes are not the
slightest bit interested in stealing your
kingdom.
Maybe not, but they might be interested
in killing all of us, Snowfall said.
I can think of a very big, scary, awful
dragon who was pretty recently interested
in that exact thing.
It was very unfortunate that Snowfall's
rain had begun as a result of the plague
Dark Stalker had sent to wipe out the ice
wings.
He hadn't succeeded, and he was gone now
but as a result, Snowfall had ended up as
an incredibly paranoid, perpetually
anxious queen, which made her exhausting
for Jaboa to deal with.
So I want you to expand the great ice
cliff for me, said the queen.
She waved one talent at a kingdom behind
her.
I wanted to go all the way around, along
the entire border of the kingdom.
She paused, then gave Jerboa a narrow
suspicious look.
Something has happened, but you can't go
tell Queen Thorn.
I have never spoken to Queen Thorn.
Treboa said truthfully.
That didn't mean she never would, but
snowfall seemed satisfied enough with her
answer.
I have scouts patrolling around our
borders day and night.
Snowfall said in a hushed voice.
I've told them to fly out into the ocean
as far as they can, to keep an eye on
everything for me, just in case someone
does attack.
Oh, Jerboa said again.
She had discovered that this was often
the only contribution she needed to make
to a conversation, especially when it was
with a queen.
And guess what one of them saw.
Snowfall whispered.
Druboa arched her brows again.
Dragons!
Snowfall shouted, 100s of dragons, coming
this way, across the ocean.
I don't know from where, but they're
coming from my kingdom, and I won't let
them.
Build me more ice cliff right now.
Maybe they're not coming for your
kingdom.
Jerboa pointed out.
She had a pretty good idea of what
dragons those were, from what Moon and
Luna had said.
She hadn't realized they were so close
though.
Maybe instead of shutting them out with
magic, you should see if they're all
right.
Maybe they need help.
Snowfall screamed.
No, it's an invasion, and you have to
stop it.
Queen Snowfall, Treboa said firmly. trying
to cut off the tantrum before it got much
worse.
Your mother and I had an agreement.
She never abused my animus powers.
And look how she ended up.
Snowfall cried, even more frantic.
She could have won the war of Sandwing
succession.
She could have protected the tribe from
the plague.
No, Jerboa interrupted.
If she had come to me then, if I had
known, we would have stopped it sooner
and saved her.
But she couldn't get to me.
She was too sick.
That's why she sent you.
And I rather wish she hadn't.
Queen Glacier was a reasonable dragon to
deal with.
Queen Snowfall on the other talon.
She should have told me about you sooner
snowfall said.
Our own animus dragon is exactly what we
need.
I'm not your animus dragon, Jerbo
observed, and I have bad news.
She saw the panic sparking in Snowfall's
eyes, and hurried on quickly.
Animus magic isn't working.
Right now, apparently.
Queen Snowfall stared at her.
Confusion and rage and alarm battling in
her expression.
Sorry about that.
Truboa added, What?
Snowfall roared.
Jerboa spread her talons.
It just isn't.
It's not working for me or any of the
other animus dragons.
All previous spells are still working, but
nothing new can be cast.
She shrugged, her wings rising and
falling in the chilly air.
How is that possible?
Snowfall shouted.
Why is this happening now?
Just when I found you.
I need that magic.
Or perhaps, Jerboa said.
This continent would be better off
without animus magic for a little while.
Snowfall jabbed one claw at her.
Prove it.
Prove that it doesn't work.
Jerboa agreeably snapped a frozen twig up
from the ground.
I hereby enchant this twig to turn
anything it touches green.
She said.
She held it out to Snowfall.
Absolutely not, Snowfall snapped.
With another shrug.
Jerboa tapped herself with it.
Shoulder, snout, wings.
Her colors stayed the same.
She poked a nearby rock, but it remained
as gray as ever.
Snowfall grabbed the twig out of her
talons and glared at it, then threw it as
far as she could.
Treboa kept quiet, resisting the urge to
say, see?
If you can't do magic, Queen Snowball
spat, then what good are you?
You're completely useless.
Jerboa watched the queen spin and fly
away.
Fury radiating off her like a cloud of
ice particles.
Completely useless, Treboa thought
allowing herself the smallest of smiles.
Yes.
Just like I've always wanted.
A guide to the Dragons of Penthala.
Hive wings.
Description.
Red, yellow. and or orange, but always
mixed with some black scales, 4 wings
vary from dragon to dragon.
Examples include deadly stingers that can
extend from their wrists to stab their
enemies, Venom in their teeth or claws.
A paralyzing toxin that can immobilize
their prey.
Others can spray boiling acid from a
stinger on their tails, Queen, Queen
Wasp.
Silk wings.
Description.
Silkwing dragonettes are born wingless
but go through a metamorphosis at age 6
when they develop 4 huge wings and silk
spinning abilities, as beautiful and
gentle as butterflies, with scales in any
color under the sun, except black.
Abilities, can spin silk from glands on
their wrists to create webs or other
woven articles, can detect vibrations
with their antennae to assess threats.
Queen, Queen Wasp.
The last silk wing queen, before the tree
wars, was queen monarch.
Leaf wings.
Description. wiped out during the tree
wars with the hive wings, but while they
lived, this tribe had green and brown
scales, and wings shaped like leaves.
Abilities.
Could absorb energy from sunlight, and
were accomplished gardeners.
Some were rumored to have unusual control
over plants.
Queen.
Last known queen of the leaf wings was
Queen Sequoia, about 50 years ago, at the
time of the tree wars.
This is Shannon McManus.
We hope that you have enjoyed this
production of Wings of Fire, Book 13, The
Poison Jungle, by 2ET Sutherland.
This audiobook was produced by Dion Audio
and directed by James Barish.
Executive producer Melanie Gagney.
Print edition published by Scholastic
Press, an imprint of scholastic Inc.
Text copyright 2019 by 2AT Sutherland
Production Copyright, 2019 by Scholastic
Inc.
All rights reserved.